hinter alexander keller ich geb direkt
in den saal da geht es nämlich darum was
ich ihnen gerade vorhin erzählte ob die
berliner als landesverband die
ausgeschlossen wurden doch noch
teilnehmen können oder nicht da gab es
gerade einen antrag dazu der wurde
begründet und der versammlungsleiter auf
dem fleck
führt jetzt die debatte um diese frage
ein antrag gestellt
die berliner delegierten zuzulassen ich
um eine sekunde 1 sekunde geduld
das berliner landesschiedsgericht hatte
die berliner delegierten im vorfeld von
diesem parteitag ausgeschlossen das
bundesschiedsgericht hatte dies
bestätigt und der bundesvorstand hatte
gestern in seiner sitzung in riesa diese
beiden gerichtsurteile des bundes und
des landes schiedsgerichtes bestätigt
und die delegierten ausgeschlossen
dieses angezweifelt beraten die
situation insgesamt ist in dieser frage
sicherlich sehr misslich dieser antrag
ist aus unserer sicht hier so nicht
zulässig die
warten sie kurz
die
einladung und akkreditierung obliegt dem
einladenden für die einladung
zuständigen gremium das ist in diesem
fall der bundesvorstand ob die der
bundesvorstand hat die berliner
delegierten nach unserer kenntnis am
gestrigen abend ausgeladen ob das
richtig ist falsch ist gutes schlecht
ist was auch immer das ist nicht leicht
mich an uns das zu bewerten und es ist
aber auch nicht eine sache die der
parteitag oder parteitag bei seine
eigene zusammensetzung abstimmen könnte
insofern sehen wir diesen antrag als
unzulässig an wir verweisen auf die
entscheidung des bundesvorstands das
muss ansonsten anderweitig geklärt
werden das können wir hier nicht als
ersatz gericht oder irgendetwas
hier beschließen
so das ist die begründung des
versammlungsleiters diesen antrag doch
noch die berliner zuzulassen nicht
weiter zu handeln auch anderweitige
einwendungen ansonsten darf ich ihnen
kurz schon mal mitteilen wir wählen ob
man darf prüfungskommission aber auf dem
bereich der akkreditierung wird schon
mal in offiziell gemeldet dass um 11 uhr
481 delegierte
akkreditiert sind da ist also noch ein
bisschen raum im saal
so gibt es weitere wortmeldungen zu
diesem punkt
ansonsten
mit dem punkt meint er die
ordnungsgemäß ich oder die
bundesparteitag ordnungsgemäß einberufen
wurde und wie gesagt da gab es vorhin
diesen antrag die berliner delegierten
24 an der zahl
einzuladen und abstimmen zu lassen
vorgetragen des vorgetragenen einwände
die ordnungsgemäße ladung fest der
einwand wird zu protokoll genommen es
uns auch schriftlich vorgetragen wurden
von den delegierten und insofern
fahren wir hier fort
wir finden uns im topf vier und da kommt
es als nächstes zu wahl einer eine
wahlkommission der mandat zur prüfung
kommission antragskommission und
beschluss über die verwendung
elektronischer stimmen geredet rein um
das verfahren etwas in sich kohärente
und zu haben schlagen wir vor dass wir
zuerst über die verwendung
elektronischer stimmen geräte abstimmen
wenn sie das ablehnen sollten bräuchten
wir naturgemäß eine etwas umfangreichere
zählkommission als wir das brauchen wenn
sie die elektronischen abstimmung geräte
ich hier heute zu lassen
unsere
wahlordnung
regelt
die
verwendung von elektronischen geräten im
paragrafen 9a können heißt es dass auch
elektronische stimmen geräte verwendet
werden können wenn die versammlung dies
beschließt da stehen wir jetzt direkt
davor
und da müssen ein paar voraussetzungen
erfüllt sein die
erfahrenen parteitags gänger wissen dass
es muss also insbesondere der gesamte
prozess muss von mitgliedern der
wahlkommission begleitet werden wir
müssen also gleichwohl gleich eine bald
deutlich kleinere wahlkommission wählen
aus celle auswertungs einheit befindet
sich sichtbar im versammlungsraum das
wäre zu unserer rechten von ihnen aus
gesehen linken seite des präsidiums erst
insellösung von außen nicht
beeinflussbar weder menschlich noch
technisch
es muss ich nun wären von dieser sache
jetzt formal
uninteressant oder beziehungsweise nur
für den internen partei gebrauch
interessantes haben wir zwei
interessante gäste mit alexander keller
am set so ist es wir haben ein wichtiges
analysewerkzeug bei phoenix über viele
jahre jahrzehnte bewährt bei parteitagen
dass es die einordnung durch profilierte
kolleginnen und kollegen aus der
hauptstadt und bei uns ist ann kathrin
müller vom spiegel und alexander kissler
von der neuen zürcher zeitung ja der
partie hat begonnen wir sind noch in der
anfangsphase
der stärksten phase würde man beim
fliegen sagen
die lokale hat ja vorhin gesagt die
destruktive zeit der vergangenheit die
müssen wir hinter uns lassen er war ja
selbst bestandteil dieser vergangenheit
gewiesen werden denn auf diesem
parteitag nach ihrer einschätzungen
rechnungen beglichen oder ist da ein
mindestmaß an harmonie und ruhe zu
erwarten eines werden rechnung blick
verglichen in der hoffnung dass es dann
harmonie und ruhe gibt also kino copala
hat ja einen team zuvor gestellt was er
gerne in den bundestag gewählt haben
möchte 14 namen genannt also neben sich
13 und wenn es diese gäbe dann sagt der
kämmerer harmonie und ruhe als er
versucht sozusagen die delegierten
darauf einzustimmen seinen vorschlägen
zu folgen ob das so gelingt wenn man
sehen ist es ja ausgefallen dass es
diese liste gegeben hat das sind also
wunschvorstellungen des alten und
möglicherweise des neuen bundes
sprechers des parteivorsitzenden ihr in
der afg heißt es ist einfach
ungewöhnlich für eine partei wie die afg
denn das klingt jetzt ein bisschen nach
hinterzimmerpolitik deshalb vorher schon
alles entschieden worden ist verlässt
die afg ihre
überzeugungen da eben eine
basisdemokratische partei zu sein das
ist zumindest ein partei geschichtliches
novum da haben sie recht das ist
gewissermaßen das antlitz der gremien
demokratie dass man dort kurz aus der
kiste hervor geholt hat allerdings wird
ja nicht ob block abgestimmt das hat
zunächst mal geht es darum wird das 1
203 bundessprecher geben wird arrow
paller der erste bundessprecher der
einzige sein oder nach mit nach wie vor
über die einzelnen positionen
abzustimmen sein und wenn ich das
anarchische element der auf die richtig
teile wird man ihnen vermutlich zum
bundessprecher erneut bestätigen aber
gewiss nicht alle positionen seiner
liste durch wegen das kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass das blog durchgeht das
wäre dann die dir eine machtübernahme
des copa lagers
vorher gab es ja mutmaßlich eine
mehrheit des neuen lagers der
sogenannten gemäßigten im bundesvorstand
soll das jetzt endgültig lahmgelegt
werden von kampala wirklich dann
derjenige sein der auch dann die
richtung vorgibt ohne ständig im streit
mit anderen bundessprecherin oder
bundessprecherin zu liegen es wäre
zumindest folgerichtig also tatsächlich
war der bundesvorstand das einzige
gremium in der partei wo es diese
mehrheit noch gab wenn man mal ehrlich
ist auch im netzen parteitag hat
eigentlich auf andere lager immer mehr
durch bekommen als sie um
dementsprechend ist es natürlich dann so
dass kubala die mehrheit hat und damit
auch entscheiden kann
mit seinen leuten was er durchziehen
will das unterscheidet ihn dass coop
aller lager das jetzt möglicherweise den
bundesvorstand dominieren wird vermeulen
lager ist das der unterschied vor allem
darin dass dafür ein höcker einen langen
arm auch wenn er jetzt nicht
oder dass das am langen arm von wie ein
höcker auch läuft auch wenn ich jetzt
nicht am bundesvorstand tisch sitzt was
ist da der eigentliche unterschied
radikalisierung weiter nach rechts
weiter nach osten also ich würde vor
einer allzu großen rolle des herrn hüppe
zurückschrecken also in den medien dass
er also glaube ich so als der große der
große böse lord voldemort im hintergrund
der gesamten partei gezeigt wäre meines
erachtens nicht ich glaube er nimmt sich
wichtiger als er ist aber er hat
natürlich einfluss so was ist nicht und
versucht ihn ja gewissermaßen teils
einzubinden teils still zu stellen mit
dem vorsitz einer neu zu schaffenden
programmkommission klar ist natürlich
dass das degree liste zukunft heißt team
zukunft von von ropal dass die natürlich
schon stärkeren inneren wie äußeren
charakter des ostens hat also auch von
den westlichen vertretern dominieren
doch dort diejenigen über den östlichen
konzepten und das ist eben stramme
rechte fundamental opposition mehr
anfangen können als etwa mit der losung
das gegenteil ein kleinwächter wir
müssen unbedingt regierungsfähig werden
gestern ist ja einen diskussionsprozess
eingeführt worden dass alles weiter
jetzt neben kino kubala quasi eine
doppelspitze möglicherweise bilden kann
wenn man bei dieser doppelspitze leiten
wird aus zwei bundessprecher oder einer
sprecherin an einem sprecher
das ist das realistisch ist das
vielleicht sogar die wahrscheinliche
neue zusammensetzung denn da stehen ja
eine menge
profilierter politiker dahinter nicht
zuletzt alexander gauland war das schon
ein hinweis dafür die neue spitze
aussehen wird nämlich genauso wie die
spitze werde in der bundestagsfraktion
das ist ja ganz interessant eigentlich
sagt die afg immer wir wollen keine
ämterhäufung wie diese anderen parteien
die alten parteien und gleichzeitig
haben sie ein problem dass sie niemanden
gefunden haben den sie so als perfekten
kandidaten neben in europa haben das
heißt sie müssen jemanden wählen der mit
ihrem bruder arbeiten kann und den dann
nicht wieder blockiert und dann wenn
dann jemand antritt der ihm sozusagen
gefehlt und wird alles weil es probieren
und hat auch ganz gute chancen
dann konnte müller vorhin gesagt
kontroversen sind ja auch zu erwarten
in der partei jetzt hat die nokianer
nochmal appelliert in seiner
begrüßungsrede kollegial gemeinsam
kooperativ dieser anhält wie wird das
tatsächlich sein wird dieser parteitag
schon die kontroversen befrieden können
oder dauert das noch sehr viel länger
es kann die kontroverse in dem moment
überhaupt nicht befrieden wenn sich ein
lager mehr oder minder auf allen feldern
durchsetzen sollte also die einigkeit
hier ein hoppala vorschwärmt ist
natürlich eine einigkeit die sich hinter
ihm einreihen da werden auf keinen fall
alle mitmachen sie werden mutmaßlich
niederlagen erleiden aber sie werden
doch danach nicht alle aus der partei
austreten oder zähneknirschen sagen ja
hoppala den weg ist der richtige kuba
ist nach wie vor jemand da im westen
nicht mobilisiert dessen konzepte kaum
zu übertragen sind auf den westen so
wird die auseinandersetzung bleiben ist
allerdings durchaus sein dass ist sie
momentan wahrscheinlich prognose dass
das ehemalige model lager aber als
geschwächt hervorgeht und mahlzeiten
wird dass es intern wie extern einfach
nicht diese kampagnenfähigkeit hat die
es braucht entscheidend fand ich am
gerät von ropal einsatz noch dass er
gesagt hat wir brauchen unterschiedliche
konzepte für ost wie west also hat
anerkannt dass man nicht den ganzen
sächsischen weg deutschland überstülpen
kann und das wird glaube ich dann auch
die gretchenfrage sein wenn er
bundessprecher werden oder bleiben
sollte ob er bereit wäre da wirklich
unterschiedliche konzepte gewähren zu
lassen das muss man beobachten da wage
ich keine prognose jetzt man merkt schon
dass die personen die zuvor an der seite
von herrn oyten standen nämlich zb
johanna klar dass die die noch vor
wenigen wochen wollten das kubala
zurücktritt jetzt wird sich gar nicht
mehr selber antreten also natürlich hat
kubala relativ entspannte lage jetzt
ihre drei tage weil die die eigentlich
seine kritiker waren oder auch sind gar
nicht mehr gegen ihn geklärt treten was
bedeutet es eigentlich für die partei
wenn jetzt jemand klar an der spitze
steht er auch den weg von tino keller
sie haben sich gerade auch schon
angedeutet mit den äußerungen seiner
gegner im bundesvorstand den man auch
führungsschwäche nach sagt die
eigentlich nicht nur eine
führungspersönlichkeit ist
dieses wenig charisma hat da wird man
ihnen nicht zu nahe treten was bedeutet
das für die partei ich habe dieses
urteil nie so ganz geteilt weil ich
finde dass er mit seiner art ist ja dann
doch ganz gut geschafft hat dass es
jetzt eben keinen starken
gegenkandidaten gibt also er könnte ja
wirklich relativ entspannt in diesen
parteitag gucken nach der vorarbeit die
er und seine leute um ihn herum
geleistet haben und als es da diese
kleine aufregung gab wird jetzt wie ein
hacker antreten oder nicht hat er das ja
auch dadurch dass er dann doch netzwerk
hat geschafft dass diese kampfkandidatur
jetzt nicht kommt also dass er da so gar
keine führungsstärke hat das sehe ich
nicht so
sie haben selbst angesprochen kann der
kissler die unterschiedlichen
erwartungshaltungen die
unterschiedlichen einstellungen
überzeugungen zwischen west und ost den
mitgliedern der partei auch den
potenziellen wählern der partei da sind
ja riesige gräben in dieser
erwartungshaltung lässt sich das
überbrücken überhaupt wenn eine partei
tatsächlich auf beide seiten setzt weil
wenn man das eine zugeständnis macht zu
ärgert man die anderen und umgekehrt
also die idealform dfb offenbar vorstand
ist dass man eine bewegung ist in
verschiedenen regionalen fenster auch
der also unterschiedliche ansprüche
unterschiedlich interessiert dazu
bräuchte sie allerdings im gesamt teil
der republik aus der gesamten republik
verschiedene gesichter daran mangelt es
momentan einfach sei es darf natürlich
auch nicht vergessen es werden hier ja
gegenkandidaten aller voraussicht nach
antreten gegen herrn hopp alle als er
kleinwächter mit meines wissens antreten
herr fest hat bisher auch nicht
zurückgezogen also mal wird dann sehen
wie stark sich die mehrheitsverhältnisse
unterscheiden im vergleich zu den
letzten beiden bundesparteitag klar ist
natürlich auch auf einer relativ
schwaches ergebnis hatte ist der
landesverband nordrhein westfalen der
mitgliederstärkste hat also auch die
meisten delegierten und er wird danach
nicht geschlossen als europa fan gruppe
den saal verlassen insofern bleiben die
debatten die wir hier kurz angerissen
haben uns natürlich erhalten
in kanada wird den werden die
kampfkandidaturen die jetzt zu erwarten
sind bei der wahl des bundesvorstandes
da gibt es ja neben den stellvertretern
auch noch eine ganze reihe von
beisitzern aber auch die diskussion über
die inhalte werden die eben in der
partei jetzt auf diesem parteitag in
lang der ost west linie geführt
es gibt ja auch am besten leute die
diese ost position wenn man sich jetzt
erstmal so bezeichnen teilen also das
ist nicht so glasklar in ost und west
verbände geteilt und dann tatsächlich
ein bisschen entlang den alten lagern
obwohl ich das so empfindet es
inzwischen so eine große mitte mittige
gruppe gibt die sich damit abgefunden
hatte oder die gar keine probleme damit
hat das eben diese alten flügelposition
eben sehr stark in der partei sind und
dann gibt es einen kleinen rest
sozusagen der alten leuten leute die das
nicht gut finden aber dieses mutige
lager ist da und die würden sich da gar
nicht so stark abgrenzen und bei den
inhaltlichen diskussionen ist es ja
interessant ukraine russland corona
europa diese dinge werden glaube ich
nicht also der wird es debatten geben
aber die werden nicht so straff denke
ich laufen wie beim letzten parteitag
soll die afc ja das recht dass die
nächste landtagswahl in niedersachsen
ist auch im westen nicht gerade eine
hochburg der afd kann es sein dass sie
tatsächlich im westen also auf dem
parlamentarischen auf der
parlamentarischen ebene so langsam
abstirbt den osten immer stärker wird
also das was wir hatten ja als liga ost
bezeichnet hat also eine ostdeutsche
regional aber möglicherweise auch eine
ostdeutsche volkspartei das ist nicht
ausgemacht aber momentan wachsen wir
mussten die bäumchen himmel für die
kommunalwahl in sachsen also vermutlich
wird diese wahl ohne das ausgegebene
ziel aus gehen nämlich dass man landräte
stellt und bürgermeister sieht nicht so
aus in thüringen sind die umfragen auch
nicht so dass man sagen können es ist
ein reines erfolgsrezept also da
überschätzt sich auch perücke etwas und
die frage ist einfach hat man das
personal im westen das hatte offenbar
niedersachsen nichts hätte man in
schleswig holstein nicht wie der satz
ist auch noch verdachtsfall jetzt
geworden
der alte parteivorstand hat den jetzigen
verklagt vor was umgekehrt also man hat
glaube ich im westen noch keine
mehrheitsfähige antworten finden auf die
frage wie kann man denn das wollte man
ja sein eine freiheitlich konservativ
bürgerliche antwort sein auf die anderen
grossen parteien und da haben sie
einfach im westen ein sehr sehr großes
personalprobleme wir drei haben hier auf
dem parteitag beobachterstatus was uns
in die lage versetzt wird demnächst das
interview hier in riesa vor zusätzlich
bedanken die ganz 2 kathrin müller und
alexander kissler das geht jetzt gleich
weiter mit doris müller
dankeschön alexander keller ja wir sind
hier in den letzten zügen der formalie
da gehen ist in der zeit in der sie
dieses interessante gespräch mit den
beiden kollegen geführt haben um die
frage der elektronischen stimmabgabe
wissen ja dass der afg parteitag sehr
viele abstimmungen mit der
elektronischen stimmabgabe
führt ob das so bleibt bei den wahlen
zum bundesvorstand ist erstmal
abzuwarten aber geht natürlich schneller
als wenn jeder zu fuß das ins kästchen
wird mit der stimmkarte die dann
händisch eingeworfen werden kann dann
sind wir jetzt in den letzten zügen und
danach geht es direkt in das
kerngeschäft afd wie geht es weiter mit
dem parteitag der tiere daran programm
oder personal diese frage wird
beantwortet werden in allernächster zeit
und die letzten züge über die
hören wir uns jetzt bei ich habe flac an
dem versammlungsleiter geschrieben mit
der blauen stimmkarte bitte
gegenprobe wäre das nicht gut findet für
die rote stimmkarte
kann ich
nicht erkennen dass der jurist
enthaltungen
auch keine enthaltungen sichtbar dann
danke ich ihnen dann haben wir das so
beschlossen
wir kommen dann als nächstes zur
zählkommission die zählkommission muss
nicht so groß sein wie wenn wir hier
händisch abstimmen müssten ganz
anders
erzählt formalia in der es darum geht
haben den parteitag sie zusammen also
choreografieren und einfach frei zu
gestalten als über die bühne zu bringen
dazu gehören natürlich logischerweise
zählkommission mandats
prüfungskommission also ist jeder
mitglied und delegierter hier rechtmäßig
auf dem parteitag und wie gesagt die
sache mit den elektronischen stimmen
geräten in diesem punkt sind wir zurzeit
noch und danach geht es um die frage wie
und welche tagesordnung gibt sich die
afg für den wahlleiter schlagen wir vor
lars könig live für mich ist
vorgeschlagen gibt es weitere vorschläge
oder kandidaturen
ein pullunder ist die hilfreich für
dieses amt aber nicht zwingend notwendig
ich hier keine weiteren vorschläge oder
kandidaturen herr könig stehen sie
bereit
steht bereit
hervorragend
dann kommen wir zur abstimmung die kann
offen erfolgen wenn sich kein
widerspruch erhebt widerspruch kann ich
nicht erkennen dann darfst jetzt in die
blaue stimmkarte bitten wenn sie herrn
könig zum wahlleiter bestimmen möchten
dankeschön gegenprobe mit der roten
stimmkarte
sehe ich
keine enthaltungen
kann ich auch keine sehen dann ist der
wenig einstimmig gewählt da bin ich
nehmen sie die wahl an
herzlichen glückwunsch und dann als
nächstes werde ich um vorschläge für
einen stellvertretenden wahlleiter
airbus der vorschlag lautet mario
assmann mario assmann ist vorgeschlagen
gibt es weitere vorschläge oder
kandidaturen
das kann ich nicht erkennen dann frage
ich herrn assmann ob er bereit steht
hermann steht bereit gibt es weitere
vorschläge hatten wir bereits dann
kommen wir zur abstimmung können wir
offen machen wenn da jetzt niemand
widerspricht widerspruch kann ich nicht
erkennen dann bitte ich sie um die blaue
stimmkarte werden erstmal zum
stellvertretenden wahlleiter befördern
möchte
dankeschön gegenprobe mit der roten
stimmkarte
kann ich keine erkennen
enthaltung mit der weissen stimmkarte
auch keine
wir bleiben koreanisch das
ist ein einstimmiges wahlergebnisse ohne
enthaltung erstmal nehmen sie die wahl
an
herzlichen glückwunsch hat die wahl
angenommen
ich darf die herren könig und assmann
bitten dass sie nachher bei wahlgängen
hinten am eingang jeweils mindestens
einer von den beiden immer dabei ist um
dort zu überprüfen dass dort alles seine
richtigkeit hat außerdem haben sie an
dieser stelle linken wir uns ganz kurz
nur noch einmal aus um eine rede eine
kurze begrüßungsrede ihnen jetzt nicht
vorzuenthalten die kino propeller der
bundessprecher gehalten hat und damit
den parteitag in riesa lernte
begrüße ich begrüße sie recht herzlich
heute hier liebe delegierte zu unseren
dreizehnter bundesparteitag der
alternative für deutschland hier in
sachsen hier in riesa herzlich
willkommen
persönlich bedanken möchte ich mich bei
den vielen fleißigen helfer um die
bundesgeschäftsstelle herum auch unserem
bundesgeschäftsführer hamburger mike um
es der hier hauptsächlich verantwortlich
war für die organisation für die
durchführung beziehungsweise für die
bereitstellung und natürlich ausstattung
dieser messe halle für die planung und
organisation vielen dank den vielen
fleißigen helfer auch den vielen
ehrenamtlichen helfern liebe freunde
[Applaus]
ja liebe landsleute
diesen mittwoch den 15 juni war ein
guter tag für die demokratie
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat
entschieden
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel hat die
rechte unserer partei verletzt und damit
das grundgesetz als sie 2020 die
landtagswahl in thüringen quasi
rückgängig machen ließ und die wahl
thomas kemmerich mit den stimmen der
alternative für deutschland als einen
schlechten tag für die demokratie
bezeichnete wäre merkel noch kanzlerin
wäre jetzt der rücktritt fällig liebe
freunde aber merkel ist ja bereits weg
unsere politik hat sie allerdings nicht
in der forderung nagel muss weg
erschöpft wie viele journalisten sagten
das haben wir in der zwanzigsten
wahlperiode des deutschen bundestages
bewiesen wir haben lösungen und konzepte
und deshalb sagen wir auch heute nicht
einfach scholz muss weg für uns ist
nicht wichtig wie derjenige heißt oder
welcher partei derjenige angehört der
deutschland abschaffen will unser motto
lautet deutschland muss bleiben und
dafür kämpfen wir
[Applaus]
und dafür kämpfen wir für deutschland
und für die freiheit und deshalb sind
wir die letzten hüter des grundgesetzes
liebe freunde
bundeskanzler olaf scholz spricht von
der grössten transformation unserer
industrie und ökonomie seit mindestens
100 jahren wir stehen vor großen
umbrüchen und herausforderungen auf dem
kontinent europa die veränderungen sind
größer als viele von uns vor einigen
jahren noch gedacht hätten diese
wahrheiten und realitäten denen können
wir uns nicht entziehen wir können die
uhr nicht zurückdrehen wir müssen den
bürgern zeigen wie deutschland wie
europa im jahr 2050 in unserer
vorstellung aussehen soll und genau das
ist unsere aufgabe
wir brauchen eine differenzierte
standortbestimmung um unsere
politikansätze zukunftsfähig zu halten
denn eines steht fest die zeit der gis
fangen dann kann politik ist vorbei denn
eines steht fest die zeit der gießkanne
politik ist vorbei wir müssen beachten
wir müssen unsere ansätze dahingehend
ausrichten was wirklich die wähler was
die bürger in unserem land brauchen es
gibt keine patentrezepte mit denen wir
als alternative überall gleichermaßen
erfolgreich sein werden das haben wir
alle in den vergangenen wahlergebnissen
erleben müssen und das bedeutet wir
müssen wissen welche bürger wie im
wahlkampf erreichen können und auf diese
wähler müssen wir auch unseren wahlkampf
abstimmen nicht auf die wähler die wir
vielleicht gerne hätten aber nicht
sofort erreichen können und ja dazu
gehört disziplinierte arbeit denn die
ist die grundlage für unsere erfolge
herausforderung haben wir im osten
genauso wie im westen
und genau deshalb genau deshalb müssen
wir die unterschiedlichkeiten zwischen
osten und westen ernst nehmen und
unterschiedliche ansätze finden um
unsere ziele auch zu erreichen welche
spektrum an standpunkten wollen wir
haben ohne dass die wiedererkennbarkeit
unserer partei verloren geht genau diese
fragen muss der neue bundesvorstand
beantworten und das wird eine der ersten
aufgaben des neuen bundesvorstandes auch
sein im westen müssen wir wieder stark
werden und zweistellige wähler
ergebnisse erzielen und liebe freunde
besten ist auch nicht gleich westen auch
dort gibt es strukturschwache gegenden
und auch regionen in denen unternehmen
den weltmarkt anführen wir müssen
denjenigen und diejenigen erreichen die
um ihren arbeitsplatz fürchten und
ebenso muss unsere politik die
ansprechen die auf grund schlechter
infrastruktur und hoher abgaben kein
eigenes unternehmen gründen oder lieber
ins ausland gehen anstelle in
deutschland zu investieren diese bürger
müssen wir erreichen und darin liebe
freunde besteht kein widerspruch
denn die alternative für deutschland
ist im jahr 2020 klar dem kurs
angekommen den freiheitlich sozialen
kurs und dieser kurs ist die
programmatische klammer und bindet alle
bürger ein die an der wertschöpfung in
unserem land teilhaben den freiheitlich
und sozial sind keine widersprüche
sozial bedeutet nicht dass man den einen
was aus der tasche nimmt um den anderen
zu unterstützen es bedeutet einen
ehrlichen kassensturz liebe
parteifreunde und wir werden damit so
viele finanziellen mittel freimachen
dass alle etwas davon haben wir werden
die kleinen und mittelständischen
unternehmen und die selbstständigen
entlasten und wir werden den sozial
schwachen die unterstützung zukommen
lassen die sie in den umbrüchen die wir
gerade alle erleben auch benötigen wir
lassen keinen landsmann zurück und dazu
gehören natürlich auch die die uns alles
ermöglicht haben und nun in die armut
gestürzt werden und das sind unsere
rentner ein würdiges und würdevolles
leben im alter muss selbstverständlich
sein
[Applaus]
wir befinden uns nun im zehnten jahr
unseres bestehens und wir haben wichtige
programm eckpunkte erarbeitet zb ein
sozial und rentenkonzept was wir
verabschiedet haben in den parlamenten
haben wir pakete mit sofortmaßnahmen
gegen die folgen der inflation geschnürt
in unserem grundsatzprogramm und unserem
wahlprogramm haben wir zahlreiche
initiativen aufgezeigt die wir all jene
und wie wir alene entlasten können die
tagtäglich zur wertschöpfung in unserem
land beitragen und die sozialsysteme
aufrechterhalten und weiter erfolgreich
rücken zu können brauchen wir eine
vertrauensvolle gute und zielgerichtet
der vorstandsarbeit das muss das ziel
sein und dafür sind wir hier heute in
riesa auch zusammengekommen hier wollen
wir heute gemeinsam die destruktive
stimmung der vergangenen zeit hinter uns
lassen wir dürfen
wir dürfen und sollten auch heute hier
kultiviert streiten und gemeinsam für
die wichtigste sache kämpfen und die
wichtigste sache in unserem land ist für
unser land für deutschland und für
unsere bürger politik zu machen liebe
freunde
um nur einen antrag herauszugreifen der
antrag europa neu denken zeigt
eigentlich bei diesem parteitag dass wir
europa ihm nicht entfliehen wollen wie
es uns häufig auch vorgeworfen wird
sondern dass wir eine vision haben
hinter der sich repräsentanten
verschiedener parteiströmung mit ihren
namen auch verein können und für dieses
mal anderen themen liegt ihnen liegt
ihnen allen 107 seiten starkes
antragspaket
sie interessante und zukunftsweisende
anträge für die erarbeitung und auch für
die sichtung gilt mein dank der bundes
programmkommission albrecht glaser der
dem vorsteht vielen dank für diese
geleistete arbeit der letzten tage und
wochen
[Applaus]
ebenso bedanken möchte ich mich schon
jetzt für die bereitschaft der zu
wählende versammlungsleitung der
schriftführer und auch der
wahlkommission werde delegierte liebe
freunde der zentrale punkt dieses
parteitages sind die wahlen zum
bundesvorstand und deshalb mein appell
auf diesem parteitag muss ein
bundesvorstand gewählt werden der
kollegial und konstruktiv vertrauens und
rücksichtsvoll zusammenarbeit und ich
betone ist immer gern es geht um arbeit
und den einsatz für unsere partei und
die vielen ehrenamtlichen mitglieder
denen wir in ganz deutschland das
verdanken was wir bislang aufgebaut
haben und darum geht es auch heute und
deshalb herzlich willkommen auf diesem
bundesparteitag zum bundesparteitag
unserer alternative für deutschland
packen wir es an drei harte tage viel
glück allen die kandidieren möchten viel
glück für unseren parteitag vielen dank
wie sie vorgeschlagen wurden herr doktor
dietrich soweit kino kuba in seiner
eröffnungsrede in der er den slogan
merkel muss weg der afb der jahrelang ja
in alle hunde war von allen funktionären
gewechselt hat in deutschland und muss
bleiben ja und wir sind hier immer noch
in der frage wer rückt wo in welche
gremien für den und das verfahren für
die anträge und das verfahren für die
frage wie wird sich dieser parteitag
strukturierende ganz interessant wir
sind gerade dabei in einer debatte in
der der bundesvorstand einen vorschlag
gemacht hat indem er
menschen vorab und funktionäre vorab
genannt hat und den parteitag gebeten
hat dieser in die antragskommission mit
aufzunehmen das wird ja heute mit
sicherheit ein spannender und morgen
spannende sache wer da in der
antragskommission und wie viel da sind
da hat der bundesvorstand ein paar
vorschläge gemacht und hat den parteitag
gebeten
zwei aus dem delegierten raum und aus
den delegierten zu bestimmen spontan und
in dieser debatte sind es war ein
bisschen zögerlich am anfang haben hat
sich niemand gemeldet aber jetzt ist
jemand am mikrofon der sich zur
verfügung stellt offensichtlich nicht
zur verfügung vielen dank
steht nicht zur verfügung
kandidaten für zwei positionen und gibt
es trotz alle themen die kandidatin
marie aus der mitte des parteitags
gekommen sind und die jetzt zusätzlich
zu der liste der vorstand vorgestellt
hat
das ist nicht der fall und gibt doch
doch dann machen wir das einzeln aber
ich frage dann ob es ein spricht gegen
eine nur einzeln abstimmen ob es ein
spruch gibt widerspruch gibt gegen eine
offene abstimmung
das ist aber nicht der fall dann kommen
wir zur abstimmung zuerst wer herrn
doktor dietrich in die antragskommission
berufen möchte ich jetzt um die blaue
stimmkarte
dankeschön gegenprobe mit der roten
kann ich
keine doch einzelne
einzelne rote karten enthaltungen
[Musik]
dann enthaltung kann ich nicht sehen
einzelne
gegenstimmen ansonsten großer mehrheit
gewählt doktor dietrich nehmen sie die
wahl an
jawohl herzlichen glückwunsch
und dann kommen wir zur abstimmung wenn
sie frau böswald in die
antragskommission berufen möchte ich sie
jetzt um die baustellen karte
dankeschön gegenstimme der roten
stimmkarte
einige gegenstimmen enthaltung
einige enthaltung dann mehrheitlich
gewählt frau böswald nehmen sie die wahl
an
jawohl erklärt ja dann herzlichen
glückwunsch an haben wir eine
antragskommission gewählt vielleicht
organisieren sie sich bei nächster
gelegenheit
vielleicht nach der tagesordnung der
gleichen einmal einmal weiter zusammen
dass sie ihre arbeit ein bisschen
aufteilen und auch einmal sich
gegebenenfalls mit der technik und der
verwaltung hier ins benehmen setzen
ja darf dann war
zudem der parteitag bestimmen wird wie
er programmatisch und
inhaltlich weiter vorgehen wird
da gibt es ebenfalls ein recht weit
gehenden antrag der ihn bereits vorliegt
der das ganze versucht zu sortieren der
verfahrens antrag des bundesvorstands
das sind dort die ziffern 2 bis
8 die
wird ihnen gleich hier kurz vorstellen
eine anmerkung bereits an dieser stelle
sie sind gemeinde zwei hände hoch hebt
das ist immer das zeichen dass jemand
direct date für sie eingreifen sind
wahrscheinlich einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag beratung und
diskussion um die an der störung an der
satzung und in ordnung des
bundesverbands mit bezug auf wahlen
insbesondere das hat der richter des
bundesschiedsgerichts da fehlt nach
auffassung des präsidiums die explizite
nennung um die leute klarstellung halber
dort noch mit rein des antrags sg o1 der
nämlich explizit diese amtszeit der
richter des bundes schiedsgerichtes
regeln möchte
herr kuss sie haben gleich das wort
werden aber zuerst einen antrag zur
geschäftsordnung am blauen saal mikrofon
ich habe noch einen antrag vor eintritt
in die tagesordnung würde ich darum
bitten die
akkreditierungs möglichkeit für die
vertreter der freien medien die bis
heute noch nicht hier akkreditiert sind
zu ermöglichen unterteilt sondern biete
darüber befinden die akkreditierung auch
nach der frist ermöglichen
[Applaus]
zur erklärung wir hatten alle eine frist
wir von der presse mussten uns bis zu
einem bestimmten zeitpunkt akkreditieren
bei der afg und danach war das fenster
geschlossen jetzt gibt es ein geo antrag
wahrscheinlich tagesaktuelle
journalisten die das prozedere der
akkreditierung
haben möchten noch zuzulassen um
die genaue akkreditierungspraxis ist dem
präsidium dort nicht bekannt das ist
nicht unser tätigkeitsbereich gleichwohl
können sie also hausherr in dem sinne
ist der bundesvorstand und sie können
den bundesvorstand als parteitag
durchaus anweisen derartiges zu tun und
dann kann der bundesvorstand das machen
oder auch nicht ich weiß jetzt nicht ob
da jemand möchte ich da
sich die aussprache zu diesem antrag
dass kein geschäftsordnungsantrag im
engeren sinne wie eine geschäftsordnung
der katalog
vorgesehen ist also dass auch einmal
vorweg wenn sie ein
geschäftsordnungsantrag kamen da gibt es
in der geschäftsordnung einen festen und
abschließenden
katalog aber
verfahrensanträge sind darüber hinaus
auch natürlich möglich insofern kommt
treten wir ein über dieses verfahrens
einen antrag in eine aussprache wird
dazu das wort gewünscht vielleicht schon
an
herr kuss
und diese neuen antrag es geht es geht
jetzt um den antrag von hinter spanien
auf zulassung von medienvertretern sie
müssten vielleicht noch einmal kurz
fällt antragsteller spannender wenn sie
noch einmal
konkretisieren mögen werden da
zugelassen werden soll weil das uns hier
gerade noch nicht ganz klar ist
das ist so ja es geht darum konkret geht
es um kompakt und herkert simon kaufmann
hat mir ebenfalls gestiegen dass er
nicht zugelassen ist weil die
akkreditierungs frisst ihm nicht bekannt
war und ab gelaufen ist und der antrag
besteht darin diese frist zu verlängern
im prinzip auf umgehend und somit kann
der bundesvorstand für jede einzelne
vertreter dieser den medien vielleicht
melden sich ja noch mehr beliebig
entscheiden ob er die zu lassen will
oder nicht nur die frist die
ursprünglich jetzt abgelaufen ist die
sollte bitte verlängert werden bzw
entfallen okay nur zum verständnis da
hat also jemanden frist versäumt und und
damit befassen wir uns hier jetzt gut
das
nehmen wir zur kenntnis führt dazu das
wort gewünscht
das ist
antwort man hier vorne ganz kurz zu
diesem für diesen antrag wie wir haben
an dieser stelle niemanden abgelehnt wir
haben nur das gab eine frist und
innerhalb der frist sind aktive anträge
nicht eingegangen wenn die jetzt da sind
also ich glaub von uns hat niemand was
dagegen dass die teilnehmen nur halt
eben es hat alles seine ordnung und hat
seine disziplin und wir müssen halt
gucken dass wir halt auch alles damit
die bundesgeschäftsstelle die dinge auch
regeln kann der braucht es bestimmte
bestimmte zulassungskriterien und
verwaltung müssen das auch prüfen ob das
alles alles stimmt deshalb also ich kann
da zu wenig sagen und wir selber sind
etwas verwundert darüber über diesen
diesen antrag aber wir sollten doch
dieser diese medien sollen sich doch
einfach melden und dann werden wir
darüber im einzelfall entscheiden ich
denke es ist das sollte natürlich dabei
sein überhaupt keine frage also können
wir das irgendwie so regeln in der
richtung sollte funktionieren
[Applaus]
ok dann wollen wir das
ja wie gesagt es gab
15 oder 16 mai in der wir uns
akkreditieren mussten und explizit war
auch überall kommuniziert dass danach
keine akkreditierung möglich ist aber
jetzt fordert der parteitag der darüber
jetzt befindet denn auch über dieses
thema
ob es eine verlängerung gibt
enthaltungen dann ist das eine einfache
mehrheit für diesen antrag und der
bundesvorstand für das sicherlich
entsprechend umsetzen so wir kommen dann
aber jetzt wieder hier zu unserem
kerngeschäft wir wollen den tag
sortieren und dazu zum verfahrens antrag
hat dann herr kurz das wort wie gesagt
unter der ziffer 3 regen wir dringlich
an den antrag sg1 mit 1 uhr ein herr
cruise sie haben das wort vielen dank
ganz kurz
vielleicht haben sich manche gefragt
wieso jetzt gerade ich jetzt diese
ganzen anträge hier vortragen das liegt
einfach daran dass ich nicht mehr für
den bundesvorstand kandidieren
und deshalb bin ich jetzt unterfangen
und kann eben hier völlig
entspannt diese dinge vortragen da gibt
es keine irgendwelche
interessenkonflikte okay wir wissen alle
allerdings länger dabei sind wissen wir
hatten schon fürchterlicher schlachten
geschlagen um die tagesordnung und wir
haben natürlich was sind lernfähig und
wir haben einiges dazu gelernt und
deshalb haben wir uns auch im vorfeld
sehr viele gedanken gemacht auch eben
dieser vorläufige antragskommission noch
einmal ganz herzlichen dank an die
kollegen die sich darum bemüht haben
dass wir das alles strukturiert haben
und das haben wir dieses ganzen anträge
die wir im antrags buch haben haben wir
jetzt zusammengefasst in verschiedene
punkte und die möchte ich ihnen gerne
vortragen es sind jetzt insgesamt noch
sieben punkte einen haben wir schon
abgehandelt also insgesamt 18 den ersten
hatten wir und ich fange jetzt einfach
weiter es ist manchmal ein bisschen
mühsam biete einfach um verständnis aber
ich glaube den schwierigsten teil den
technischen vortrag foren über die
stimmgerät das haben sie auch gut
verkraftet ich denke da werden wir auch
diese sachen gut verkraften und
diejenigen die es heute nacht nicht die
usa hatten sich zwischen zwei und drei
die diese ganzen verfahrens antrag zu
studieren
die haben jetzt die gelegenheit in der
nächsten zehn minuten viertelstunde zu
verstehen und zu versuchen zu verstehen
um was es hier geht ok also der erste
punkt den wir vorschlagen den
delegierten ist dass wir unter dem
tagesordnungspunkt 6 also der bestand
der nächste punkt bericht der mandats
prüfungskommission dass wir unter diesem
punkt den antrag sn eins nämlich
ausschluss der bundes delegierten des
landesverbandes berlin vom 13 parteitag
behandeln erster punkt der zweite ist
wir empfehlen dass die anträge die drei
anträge die sich mit der zahl der
bundessprecher befassen das ist
theo acht änderung der anzahl möglicher
bundessprecher das ist der b s 1 anzahl
bundessprecher senken auf ein oder zwei
und der bs 2 anzahl bundessprecher auf
ein bis drei festlegen dass wir diesen
punkt unser top 8 nämlich beratung und
beschlussfassung über änderungen an der
satzung und ordnungen des
bundesverbandes das wären dort behandeln
punkt 2 es kommt punkt 3
wir empfehlen dass wir
und da geht es jetzt um die sogenannten
fach anträge ja da haben wir die hammer
unterteilt in folge die politisch etwas
brisant sind und solche die eben die wir
immer haben und wir haben da einen
ersten teil jetzt genommen mit vier
anträgen die wir gerne hier war sie
behandelt haben wollen etwas vor den
anderen acht die wir dann relativ weit
hinten dann behandeln würden einfach
damit wir auch über diese dinge reden
ich halte es für wichtig dass wir dinge
nicht immer ständig unter den teppich
kehren sondern dass wir offen und frei
wie wir es in der afg gewohnt sind mit
offenem visier kämpfen und einander
sagen was wir denken über diese dinge
und dann können wir auch eine
entscheidung treffen und dann ist ruhe
das hoffe ich zumindest das ist dringend
notwendig deshalb das sind es handelt
sich hier um die vier anträge
t5
einsetzung einer untersuchungskommission
personalbudget auftrag und missbrauchte
arbeitsgruppe verfassungsschutz dann um
den antrag sieben
aufhebung der beschlüsse für auftritts
verboten von andreas kalbitz und
verbindung damit sn 12 der ja da auch
der eigentliche beschlusstext ist dann
hast drittes der tee ohne neuen
beschluss über nächsten parteitag als
delegierten oder mitglieder parteitag
zusammen mit theo 10 beschluss über
nächsten parteitag als
mitgliederversammlung und habe in
verbindung damit der fach antrag essent
17 nächste parteitag soll
mitgliederversammlung sein ich halte das
für wichtig dass wird es auch mal klären
dann als vierter punkt in diesem ersten
bereich s9
landesverband zentrum automobile von
unvereinbarkeit liste streichen zusammen
mit msn 10
okay dass ich dann natürlich wenn wir
das machen einen neuen punkt einfügen
dass die anderen immer nachrutschen das
selbstverständlich ist der
vollständigkeit halber in diesem
verfahren antrag natürlich immer jeweils
auch genau klassifiziert und erwähnt
damit ist alles seine ordnung hat ok ich
komme zum 4 vom vierten punkt den wir
vorschlagen denn wir empfehlen und das
ist dass wir direkt nach dieser
behandlung dieser etwas vier politisch
brisanten themen dass wir dann zu den
politisch interessanten themen kommen
nämlich zu den resolutionen dass wir
dann die resolutionen zwischen top 13
und 14 einschieben und zwar handelt es
sich um die vielen folgende resolutionen
erwähnte nur kurz damit sie sich schon
darauf freuen können dass wir am ende
unseres wahlmarathons daneben auch
wirklich schöner gute themen noch haben
über die wir dann diskutieren können es
geht um 21 resolution für den bau neuer
atomkraftwerke in deutschland verbunden
mit es n2 und n3
dann den co2 die resolution europa neu
denken dann die theo
333 waffenlieferungen stoppen dialog
starten gesamt europäische
friedensordnung sichern dann den sn vier
unserer partei fdp bei der streitkräfte
dann den sn fünf der islam gehört nicht
zu deutschland kein ruf des muezzins in
unseren städten und sf6
energiesicherheit stadt energiewende
jetzt und zuletzt den sn 7 aufnahme
positionspapier digitalisierung des bfa
10 also das sind alles sehr interessante
themen ich freue mich schon auf die
debatte
dann können der fünfte punkt da gehen
wir mal dass glaube das dürfte der
relativ leichtes design von ihnen das zu
entscheiden da geht es darum dass wir
keine anträge haben zudem top 17
beratung und beschlussfassung über
änderungen an der wahlordnung deshalb
empfehlen wir ihnen einfach diesen top
zu streichen ich glaube da gibt es keine
bedenken und dann käme der feste punkt
da geht es jetzt um den zweiten teil
dieser fach anträge die wir dann am
schluss dann machen würden vor dem
schlusswort unter nationalhymne und da
geht es um die folgenden acht anträge q4
abwendung drohender internationale
isolation der afd mit verbindung mit s m
11 dann theo sechs einsetzung einer
kommission zur vorbereitung einer partei
strukturreform dann theo 11 prüfung des
vorliegens von parteischädigendem
verhalten mit 18 in verbindung dann als
vierter antrag des n8 beitritt zu
europapartei identity- and democracy
partie dann sn 13 aufbau eigener tv
sender dann sn 14 ausbau von präsenzen
in weiteren sozialen medien dann ist ein
15 einrichtung einer arbeitsgruppe für
demoskopie und wahlforschung und last
but not least sind 16 änderung
geschäftsordnung der bundesfachausschuss
ok und dann käme als letzter punkt noch
der vorschlag unserer antragskommission
die gesagt haben dass bs4
automatischer parteiaustritt mit
fraktionsaustritt und auch spo drei
gleichzeitigkeit von mitgliedschaft
schiedsgericht und kreisvorstand dass
diese anträge wohl nicht zulässig sind
und deshalb empfehlen wir da eine
nichtbefassung
okay so viel dann geführt dass sich für
die geduld für das durchhalten das ist
der antrag den wir jetzt stellen würden
ich denke wir können sicher gern
diskutieren aber wir haben sehr gut
überlegt und durchdacht und jetzt müssen
wir einfach sind sie dran ich gebe
zurück an die versammlungsleitung
dankeschön
vielen dank meine damen und herren für
die geduld ich habe das laufen lassen
weil mich unser antrag als
pressevertreter nicht vorgelegen hat
deswegen musste ich genauso
aufmerksamkeit
zollen wie sie fazit kann ich nur
zurechtrücken dass mit diesem ganzen
nach verfahrensanträge die der
bundespost endlich jetzt gestern nach
wahrscheinlich überlegt hat und heute
per e-mail heute nacht verschickt hat
folgendes heraus kristallisiert es
sollen erst führe die
bundesvorstands malen abgestimmt werden
und dann über die programmatik
dann eröffne ich jetzt zu diesem
verfahren beantragt
die
ausbau oder gern erst einmal schnell
herr meier dort
zur frage ob der antrag sn 1
zurück überhaupt sich der erledigt hat
auch herr meier
hallo
ja in der tat die berliner delegierten
sind ja nun nicht dabei sind jetzt gäste
allerdings ist die sache damit ja noch
nicht zu ende denn in der weiteren folge
muss er jetzt aufgeklärt werden ob nicht
partei
ordnungsmaßnahmen ergriffen werden
müssten insbesondere gegen frau beatrix
von storch traum habe ich
ich habe gerade gerade einen
änderungsantrag zu diesem antrag
eingebracht ihr müsste eigentlich schon
vorliegen und der änderungsantrag der
lautet der bundesparteitag beschließt
dass er gegen tricks von storch
wählte bundesvorstand von storch ein
parteiordnungsverfahren einleitet danke
also
der antrag ist hier eben bei uns aus dem
drucker gekommen der antrag ist
unzulässig wir haben hier keine
initiative einbringen es gibt eine
antragsfrist ist ein völlig neuer antrag
der eben nicht den anderen antrag nur ab
ändert also an huckepack so ein antrag
als haben ein trojanisches pferd zu
nutzen den komplett umschreiben das geht
eben nicht ändert das gesicht des
antrags insofern ist antrag als
änderungsantrag unzulässig
völlig neuer anträge müssen mit einer
antragsfrist könnte der bundessatzung
entnehmen gestellt werden insofern ist
er am tag essen 11 in jedem fall
unzulässig die frage die sich aber
gleichwohl stellt ist ob der orgie
ursprungs antrag ob sich der erledigt
hat wenn sie das vielleicht kurz einmal
kurz mit ja oder nein beides in ordnung
vielleicht kurz erläutern mögen der
antrag hat sich natürlich erledigt
insofern kann sich das gut dann nehmen
wir nehmen wir das
dann nehmen wir das zu protokoll der
antrag sn 1 wird da mache ja nicht mehr
aufgerufen hat sich erledigt vielen dank
das war der andere nahmen die gäste und
aussprache werden sagte dass die
berliner delegierten außen vor bleiben
[Musik]
das rot roten ja die zusammenfassung ist
sehr sinnvoll
allerdings finde ich es gut wenn sie das
ganze vorziehen und zwar erst die ganzen
satzungs sache machen und dann die wahl
machen wir haben einen tag mehr wir
wissen wie es wieder aussieht am sonntag
wir können heute abend in kassel durch
zehn morgen früh mit den wahlen beginnen
das wäre sinnvoll im sinne auch der
mitglieder auch die sitzungswoche mal
durchkriegen dessen beantrage ich das
dass wir die
vorschläge vom bundesvorstand zwar
übernehmen aber die reihenfolge vor den
ganzen wahlen ziehen danke
also wenn wenn sie
sie erstellen aber dort einen
änderungsantrag an dieser stelle auch
schon mal vorweg die werden nachher
schriftform verhängen für
änderungsanträge die anträge betreffen
die im antrag schon bekannt waren jetzt
zu diesem der ihnen so kurzfristig
vorgelegt wurde nicht das heißt ich
nehme jetzt einmal auf sie wünschen dass
sämtliche
tagesordnungspunkte die sich mit
satzungsänderungen und befassen nach
vorne gezogen werden wenn es jetzt noch
einmal kurz das wäre dann der tom genau
das konnten die top 14 bis18 dass die
eingereiht werden wo es jetzt wo jetzt
der top acht ist genau
so wir haben den top
den top den top 17 allerdings nicht weil
es da keine anträge gibt dass es da
würden sie sich schon dem
verfahrensanträge anschließend darf
annehmen dass es korrekt gut das heißt
der antrag lautet entsprechend dass die
dass der top 14 neuer top 8 wird der
reine tor macht ist dann hinfällig
werden einen antrag an nur einen top
hätten unter dem die satzungs anträge
befasst werden top 14 würde top acht top
15 dass die schiedsgerichtsordnung
würde top 9 der vorläufigen tagesordnung
würde top 10 und top 18 der tagesordnung
das ist die geschäftsordnung für
parteitage würde
top11 der bisherige top 8 entfällt und
die nummerierung würde sich entsprechend
verschieben das ist hier die zuschauer
live zuschauer partei formalia sind eine
zähe und manchmal langjährige sache aber
sie sind ja vorgeschrieben vom
parteiengesetz das wird auch genau
beobachten das muss auch rechtlich alles
einwandfrei sein dass es immer zu beginn
des parteitages so nicht nur bei der afg
ich habe vorhin von analysewerkzeugen
gesprochen weil phoenix und die beiden
profiliert und profunden kenner kennerin
der afg aus berlin vorgestellt vom
spiegel unserer neuen zürcher zeitung
und jetzt haben wir aus der gleichen
richtung aber politikwissenschaftler
professor wolfgang schröder von der uni
kassel und gleichzeitig tätig am
wissenschaftszentrum in berlin schüler
vielleicht ganz kurzen was er gerade
erlebt haben dieser antrag des
sächsischen ehemaligen
bundestagsabgeordneten smoke man gegen
seine parteifreundin wer trickst von
storch dass gegen sie ein
parteiordnungsverfahren eingeleitet
werden sollen wegen der umstände dass
hier die berliner die delegierten nicht
an parteitag teilnehmen können da
wirklich um rechtliche fragen und auch
eben eine disziplinierung oder eine rüge
durch den bundesvorstand oder ein
schiedsgericht oder es sind das viel
mehr politische hintergründe die da eine
rolle spielen ja wie so häufig bei der
afg vermischen sich da die motivlagen
weil das parteiengesetz natürlich
vorschreibt dass die dinge ordnungsgemäß
abgewickelt werden ist klar dass dieser
tatbestand berücksichtigt werden muss
andererseits hat man bei den ganzen
konflikten in der afg immer so eine
vermischung von habituellen persönlichen
programmatischen und rechtlichen fragen
zu berücksichtigen und hier geht es auf
der einen seite um rechtliche frage das
spielte sich ja auch schon im antrags
buch wieder und andererseits ist klar
dass es eine retourkutsche des flügel
mannes mayer gegen die pragmatikerin
storch und das ist natürlich ein offener
ausgang hier weil dieser parteitag immer
wie wir das aus der vergangenheit kennen
auch bei diesen punkten
gewisse emotionale höhe findet und das
recht ist da ein instrument mit dem man
diese konflikte austrug jetzt haben die
streitereien und möglichkeiten für die
dfg ja auch bekannt ist der partei nicht
immer gut getan wirklich geschadet haben
sie ihr bisher noch nicht wie sehen sie
denn die entwicklung der afg soll ja
hier zum großen friedenspfeife rauchen
kommen durch die wahl des neuen
bundesvorstandes lässt sich da etwas
erkennen wo sich die afg hin entwickelt
oder liegt die zukunft ziemlich im nebel
also die afg ist einer ganz schwierigen
lage zehn waren hintereinander verloren
eine nicht überzeugende führungsspitze
kein thema was fliegt und die innere
befriedung ist weiter denn je entfernt
und dieser parteitag soll zur beruhigung
beitragen
ob das der fall sein wird oder ob
weitere verwerfungen das feld bestimmen
würden das können wir erst am ende sagen
auf jeden fall ist der rahmen für die
afg denkbar schlecht um hier grund unter
die füße zu bekommen weil die politische
lage auch nicht so ist dass eine partei
wie die afg augenblicklich wirklich
gebraucht wird wirklich die themen
bestimmen kann wenn man den letzten
wahlen nimmt da können wir feststellen
dass es eine stärkere
wettbewerbssituation in der mitte gibt
und unter dieser stärkeren
wettbewerbssituation der mitte leiden
die kleineren parteien das betrifft
nicht nur die afg sondern auch die
linkspartei und sogar die fdp wir werden
dieses thema noch weiter vertiefen vor
allen dingen wenn wir dann mehr
informationen über den parteitags
verlauf haben das ist auch ein aspekt
ansprechen der sagen die elf die in
einer schwierigen lage der tatsächlich
das ausdrückt nehme ich die beobachtung
durch den verfassungsschutz und zwar auf
bundesebene durch das bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz auch einzelne
landesverbände in thüringen in
brandenburg und niedersachsen glaube ich
auch einzelpersonen werden ja beobachtet
was bedeutet das eigentlich für die
partei bern höcker sagte ist mir alles
egal andere sind als belastung wie ist
da wirklich die reaktion in der partei
auf diese beobachtung denn das ist ja
mitunter ein massiver eingriff ins
parteileben das ist massive bedrohung
für die afd wenngleich wir
unterschiedliche wahrnehmungen ost und
west unterscheiden müssen im osten hängt
natürlich mit der stasi vergangenheit
zusammen dass man sagt neuer wer von der
stasi beobachtet wurde der ist heute
geadelt so sehen wird das auch gegenüber
dem verfassungsschutz was natürlich
quatsch ist weil erstens ist diese
gleichstellung vorkommt illegitim ich
muss in dem moment unterbrechen wir
werden das nachher weiterführen wir
müssen nochmal aus riesa weg gehen und
zwar nach brüssel und ursula von der
leyen es geht nämlich um die bekanntgabe
ob die eu kommission den
kandidatenstatus für einen zukünftigen
eu beitritt der ukraine gutheißt oder
nicht wir gehen live nach brüssel
[Musik]
in tages und kommt aufzuspalten dann
erst von einem zweiten teil und dann
einmal beantragen das einen antrag den
co2 dann dort einzureihen und einmal den
theo drei dort einzureihen das sind dann
zwei anträge die werden wir dann gleich
getrennt auch zur abstimmung bringen die
anträge sind aufgenommen auch hier ist
die beratung verbunden und wir machen am
anderen saal mikrofon weiter kritisch
hallo
einen schönen guten morgen auch ich habe
einen antrag zum verfahrens antrag und
zwar unter punkt 4 soll top 13 erster
teil der antragsbearbeitung dann den job
13 2 enthalten dort soll der theo 7
behandelt werden ich beantrage dazu die
nichtbefassung nichtbefassung mit
theorie sieht
[Applaus]
gut
sie dürfen begründen wenn sie mögen
natürlich dann machen wir einmal hier
vorne weiter hieß
schönen guten morgen von ihrem schönen
sachsen
es geht auch darum die sache anträge
quasi nach vorn zu holen damit sie also
auch wirklich an exponierter stelle
stehen und dann im politischen geschäft
beziehungsweise bei den medien auch ein
größeres gewicht haben und da geht es
hier mir zumindest persönlich geht es um
den antrag neue kernkraftwerke bauen
also statt mit der ideologisierten
energiewende seit vier jahren zur kurzer
begründung seit vier jahren war kann wir
das thema im bundestag erst etwas
zögerlich dann immer immer stärker immer
fordernder in der zwischenzeit ist die
cdu und gefallen sie fordern also auch
dass die kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen am
96 hat herr lindner auch darüber
gesprochen dass sich das vorstellen kann
das heißt die stimmung bei den
politikern kippt und die stimmung in der
gesellschaft gibt auch in unsere
richtung weiter ebenso massiv mit diesem
thema aufarbeiten eine letzte umfrage
hat also gezeigt dass 56 prozent der
bevölkerung der befragten waren glaube
ich 20.000 leute
die kernkraft befürworten ich erinnere
daran an den parteitag in dresden als
wir dort also auch durchgesetzt hatten
sie haben das beschlossen wir haben das
beschlossen die krone resolution damals
vor allen anderen zu behandeln und es
war eines der top themen in den medien
und des dort konnten wir also unser
profil schärfen wie wir zu bestehen und
das war sehr sehr wichtig und deswegen
bitte ich darum erstmal natürlich
unseren antrag unseren sachen antrag
neue kernkraftwerke zu errichten nach
vorn zu holen zu holen also nach top 7
also auf top 8 vielen dank
vielen dank auch der antrag wird wie
alle jetzt die gestellten
änderungsanträge
zur gemeinsamen beratung verbunden und
wir machen
am saalmikrofon roth weiter
wir brauchen jetzt ein starkes
politisches signal und das brauchen wir
heute vor dem personal wahlen und
deswegen beantrage ich die
sache anträge die die resolution die die
wichtigen resolution
stellen und zwar co2 tee und theo 3 und
diesen kernkraftwerks antrag vor dem
personal waren verfolgen personal wahlen
stattfinden zu lassen
die anträge sind ja schon gestellt
dann machen wir blauen saal mikrofon
weiter
meine man diesen damen und herren ich
möchte keinen den änderungsantrag
stellen aber einigen der delegierten
wurden veraltete unterlagen ausgereicht
wir haben eine schwarz-weiß version mit
durchgestrichenen unterlagen zu bekommen
wir können praktisch der reihenfolge der
erinnerungs anträgen nicht folgen bei
uns der aktuelle antrag des
bundesvorstands nicht verdient ich bitte
darum dass den delegierten aktuelle
versionen ausgehändigt werden
also die version ist nach meiner
kenntnis überall aktuell der einzige
unterschied zwischen den farbigen und
den nicht farbigen ist der drucker aus
dem die dinger gekommen sind die sind
mehrere hochleistungsdrucker im einsatz
gewesen heute früh und da es aber einen
schwarz weiß und der andere farbig das
was da drauf steht ist ansonsten
identisch
das ist so bunt ist immer schöner wissen
wir aber
ja wir haben das wir haben das gerade
abgeglichen zb unter punkt 6 bei der
beschlussfassung zur geschäftsführung
parteitag da haben wir unterschiedliche
versionen
ok bei ihnen sollte oben drüber stehen
letzte fassung des vom bundesforschungs
am 16 juni 22 beschlossenen verfahrens
anfrage zum 13 bundesparteitag sollte
oben drüber ständiger das ganze papier
sollte auf vier seiten seien
also bei der einen steht letzte fassung
des verbundes parteitags hier steht
finale fassung des bundes parteitags und
wie gesagt es gibt auch unterschiede bei
den pumpen
also das wird jetzt hier wird gerade
noch mal geprüft da wo finale fassung
steht das suggeriert zwar so einen
gewissen abgeschlossenen
zustand aber nach der finalen fassung
kamen noch die letzte fassung
das ist immer schön mit ultimativen
dortmund zustimmen möchte danke ich
beantrage zehn minuten pause damit
vielleicht allen delegierten die gleiche
fassung zugeordnet werden kann also das
stimmig lassen zu dass ihre geschäfte
auf antrag gerne ab vielleicht können
wir aber auch einfach die zeit nutzen
und die wortmeldungen weiter abarbeiten
vor der abstimmung über diese punkte
werden wir sicherstellen dass die wissen
worüber sie abstimmung dass die
ordnungsgemäße unterlagen haben zur
zur bearbeitung und um sich ein bild zu
machen
gut ist zu ist an dem geschäft
zurückgezogen es ist auch noch einmal
per e-mail verschickt worden also wer
die möglichkeit hat das auf seinem
mobilgerät sich kurz anzeigen surfen da
haben sie es auch und wenn sie über ein
farbdisplay verfügen dann sogar im bund
und in farbe
dann machen wir erstmal mit wortmeldung
weiter im roten saal mikrofon
guten morgen mein name ist henning
dornauf aus nordrhein westfalen es geht
jetzt um die frage was machen wir mit
den anträgen ich sag mal so personal
wahlen sind schillernd programmatik ist
trocken keine frage und gerade aus dem
zeit aus der situation heraus appelliere
ich an alle lasst uns die frage welche
anträge wir behandeln oder auch welche
anträgen wir nicht verhandeln jetzt
klären jetzt sind wir alle fit jetzt
sind sind maximale anzahl an delegierten
es da das heißt wir haben auch die
größten wirkliche
legitimation dieser anträge wenn sie
denn abgestimmt werden statt das
irgendwann sonntagabend mit 100 leuten
noch schnell durch zu rutschen und von
daher
möchte ich jetzt einfach die gelegenheit
nutzen sagt leute lasst uns die
programmatik auch eine legitime basis
stellen lasst uns die sachen jetzt
erledigen weil bis zur wahl der
bundessprecher werde alle dableiben
danke dann geht's weiter am blauen saal
mikrofon
ja so gewollt kreisverband
oberspreewald-lausitz
landesverband brandenburg wir sind
antragsteller von
unter top 13
[Musik]
top
13.3
tagesordnung 9 und 10 sowie sn 17 wir
würden da der dem vorschlag des
bundesvorstands gerne folge leisten
womit wir nicht folge leisten würden es
mit dem dritten antrag und zwar den
vierten antrag und zwar geht es darum
dass er unter top 20 unter
20.3 fest krankheit ist dieser
tagesordnungspunkten ich denke dass es
wichtig und es wurde ja vorhin auch
gesagt dass wir mit offenen visier hier
kämpfen wollen und es wurde versäumt bei
dem antragstext unsere begründung zu
verlusten link beziehungsweise den
delegierten die begründung die wir da
beigefügt haben zu veröffentlichen ich
weiß nicht wer dort entscheidungsbefugt
überhaupt ist um was ein zu putzen auf
jeden fall würden wir den antrag stellen
dass dieser unter dem top vor der wahl
des neuen bundesvorstandes kommt also
fort top11
wenn sie mir noch einmal die sn noch mal
sagen mögen und im moment tue das ist
unser top 20 jetzt verankert
10 11 10 18 okay das ist beitritt zur
europapartei dts trotz für schuld u
ja genau 18
18.11 und sm genau das steht jetzt der
fed und da 20.3
der antrag steht dass es vor ort und vor
der
neuwahl des bundesvorstand also im
prinzip vor top 11 es ist extrem wichtig
vielleicht auch für die delegierten weil
es ja auch eine personalie geht die
wahrscheinlich hier und heute
kandidieren möchten gut also beantragt
ist
das jetzt hier als 20 3 vorgesehenes im
änderungsantrag das
vorzuziehen da müssten wir dann
entsprechend einen zweiten teil und
einen dritten teil der
antragsbearbeitung entsprechend haben
dass der tagesordnungspunkt zwar weiter
aufgesplittet werden und dann vor top
elf mit aufruf der beiden anträge dort
theo 11 und sn 18 erfolgen ist
aufgenommen
dann machen wir hier vorn am rednerpult
weiter
vielen dank liebe
versammlungsleitung sehr geehrter
bundesvorstand die parteifreunde auch
von meiner seite einen wunderschönen
guten morgen hier in die halle in riesa
schön dass wir diesen parteitag zusammen
verleben können
[Applaus]
ich danke auch ganz herzlich den
mitarbeitern der satzungskommission 4 in
einsatz nun ich halte die grundsätzliche
entscheidung die mit dem vorschlag
unterbreitet wird für falsch dafür
politisch unklug und das will ich kurz
begründen ich will dazu eingangs etwas
grundsätzlicher ausführen liebe freunde
als ich heute morgen in die halle kam
und die ersten interviews mit
journalisten führte da war welches die
erste frage der presse
werke kandidieren sie als
bundesvorsitzender das war die erste
frage der presse was habe ich gesagt ich
sagte
diesem land läuft einiges schief unter
anderem läuft in diesem lande schief
dass zu viel über einzelne person und
deren machtambitionen und
machtinteressen geredet wird aber zu
wenig aber zu wenig über inhalte und zu
wenig über die zukunft deutschlands
die parteienvertreter die haben so ein
drei klagen wenn sie mal eine
sonntagsrede halten einen dreiklang mit
denen sie ihre dienste ethos beschwören
wollen aber dieser dreiklang ist schade
wenn er aus den mündern der
parteienvertreter kommt dieser dreiklang
lautet ihr kennt ihn alle erst das land
dann die partei und die person liebe
freunde diesen dreiklang den sollten wir
mit leben füllen diesen dreiklang den
sollten wir uns zur herz neben diesen
drei klaren den sollten wir heute und
hier auch zelebrieren erst das land dann
die partei und zum schluss dann die
person
wir müssen mit inhalten punkten und wir
haben so viele gute
alleinstellungsmerkmale in dieser
verrückten zeit die uns vom ei parteien
kartell abheben und die müssen heute zu
beginn des parteitages und wir sind dort
drei tage zusammen wir haben zeit wir
haben ruhe die gesamte agenda
abzuarbeiten die müssen heute zu beginn
des parteitages unbedingt platziert
werden und ich habe mit durchaus
erschrecken ich muss es mal so deutlich
formulieren
gemerkt das obwohl heute und die meisten
von euch wissen dass sicherlich heute
sich der 69 jahrestags der des
aufstandes in der ddr der 90 66
jahrestages eines freiheitskampfes der
deutschen nation gegen ein
unterdrückungsregime sichert wir heute
nicht diese gelegenheit genutzt haben
als partei der freiheit die gegen einen
übergriff in obrigkeitsstaat kämpft
diese gelegenheit nicht genutzt haben
auch gemäß unseres mottos für die
freiheit für deutschland hier ein
bekenntnis abzulegen zu den helden des
17 juni für mich ist dieser siebzehnter
juni der authentischere feiertag als ed
reed oktober
[Applaus]
per hacke ohne ohne inhaltliche
bewertung aber sie müssen sprechen zur
tagesordnung unseren verfahrens antrag
vielen dank herr versammlungsleiter ich
wollte nur ich wollte nur die debatte
etwas einordnen weil ich gemerkt habe
dass wir uns schon wieder in details
verlieren ich komme auch schon gleich
zum ende und möchte abschließend noch
mal betonen wir brauchen die sachdebatte
vor der personaldebatte wir haben heute
eine große medien aufmerksamkeit und wir
können heute mit unseren
alleinstellungsmerkmalen
punkten und das solchen wehtun ich
beantrage wie das ganz neu auf auch
schon gemacht hat noch einmal zusätzlich
den co2 und theo 3 also die europa
revolution und die friedens resolution
nicht unter top 14 zu subsumieren
sondern unter top 7 und ich beantrage
den top 6 2 6 den theo 6 das ist die
einsetzung einer reform
strukturkommission vor die personalrat
volk nicht personalrat sondern vor die
personal wahlen zu setzen denn liebe
freunde wir müssen nicht nur kennen das
wer geist des aufbruchs verloren haben
wir müssen nicht nur erkennen dass wir
durch
rassisten auch im bundesvorstand in den
letzten jahren ausgebremst worden sind
und in der selbstbeschäftigung modus
hineingetrieben sind sondern wir müssen
auch erkennen dass unsere partei
institution dringend reformiert werden
müssen wir brauchen effektivere
institutionen wir brauchen effektivere
strukturen wir brauchen effektivere
prozesse wir müssen schlagkräftiger
werden nach außen und das gelingt uns
mit einer reformkommission und ich
möchte nicht dass dieses wichtige thema
am ende mangels zeit hinten runterfällt
wir müssen heute den anfang machen und
das hängt bitte ich um zustimmung zu
meinen anträgen vielen dank für eure
aufmerksamkeit
so neu hinzugekommen ist also den antrag
den antrag theo 6 vor top-elf
einzureihen auch dort gilt wie für alle
anderen anträge die dort eingreift
werden sollen von den sachanträgen dass
das unter einem top
antrags
erster zweiter dritter teil der
antragsbearbeitung je nachdem wo wir
dann dort sind
erfolgen würde wenn denn die anträge
angenommen würden wir machen weiter am
blauen saal mikrofon
adelhausen mehr landesverband sachsen
anhalt wir haben es für tagesordnung wir
haben mit dem kreisvorstand ständer
einen antrag eingereicht satzungs und
fristgerecht der die aussetzung der
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht im
gesundheitswesen fordert dieser antrag
liegt bislang nicht vor wir halten den
für wichtig alle pflegebedürftigen alle
patienten auch die beschäftigten im
gesundheitswesen erwarten von uns noch
mal ein klares zeichen denke ich dass
wir da nicht nachlassen dass wir weiter
versuchen diesen unsinn zu stoppen
deswegen der antrag diesen antrag hier
heute auch zu behandeln da liegt der
verwaltung vor und zudem verfahrens
antrag in der fuß vorgestellt hat wir
wurden dann beantragen den im letzten
block im letzten tagesordnungspunkt vor
der hymne zu behandeln danke
einen augenblick bitte
sie müssen doch bitte einmal noch mal
ganz kurz mir die antrags nummer nennen
der antrag ist eben nicht im antrags
hoch gelandet das ist das problem ja das
ist misslich aber ein antrag der nicht
im antrags buch den
verhandlungssaal im vorfeld zugestellt
und kann hier heute nicht behandelt
werden das müssen wir im nachhinein
klären woran das gelegen hat aber der
kann hier dann nicht behandelt werden
das so bleibt
dann machen wir dem roten sand gewonnen
nachdem wird die bewerbungsrede von
herrn hüppe gehört haben würde ich zur
theorie gerne sprechen
[Musik]
ich würde gerne folgende anträge stellen
einmal den theo drei
nicht genau nicht auf die tagesordnung
zu nehmen
hintergrund im antrag steht geschrieben
dass 300.000 euro für diese russland
kampagne aufgewendet werden soll 300.000
euro wir haben in vier monaten
landtagswahl in niedersachsen da ist das
wesentlich besser investiert in
niedersachsen und nicht für irgend so
eine schaufenster kampagne
außerdem stelle ich weiteren antrag den
t5
ebenfalls nicht auf die tagesordnung zu
nehmen
das ist hier
verzeihen sie mir ich bin eigentlich aus
bayern hierhergekommen um inhaltlich zu
arbeiten und eben keine schmunzeln gegen
personen und oder gegen arbeitsgruppen
und diese
untersuchungskommission für die vsg ag
dass die nochmal untersucht werden soll
das ist nicht zielführend
hier wird ja eben auch gesagt wir wollen
hier inhaltlich arbeiten und keine
personaldebatten führen
dann
bestelle ich weiteren
antrag den theo sechs diese partei
strukturreform nicht auf die
tagesordnung zu nehmen das hat einen
ganz einfachen grund wir sind hier ich
habe es gerade gesagt wir haben in
niedersachsen eine landtagswahl wie ich
sehe den mehrwert nicht drin ein
weiteres gremium zu schaffen weiteren
wasserkopf ja der bundesvorstand sollte
dann irgendwie besetzen entschuldigung
das ist eine leider gottes eine
unausgesprochene wahrheit aber wenn wir
wollen dass diese partei funktioniert
dann müssen wir erst mal vor der eigenen
haustür kehren
und das heißt nämlich dass alle
funktionäre am kreisverband auch ihre
hausaufgaben machen dafür brauche keine
parteien strukturreform für diese
erkenntnis
vielen dank herr köhler das sind drei
anträge theo drei absätzen 25 plätzen 26
absetzen wir machen hier vorne weiter am
rednerpult
ich erlebe parteifreunde wir regeln
heute viele dinge in der satzung und ich
möchte vor der personalwahl die hier
zwangsläufig auf diesem parteitag
stattfindet oder gott sei dank hier
stattfindet unbedingt geklärt haben wie
unser verhältnis zu
vorfeldorganisationen ist und hier gibt
es zwei anträge zwei sachen träge das
ist der sache antrag 900 sache antrag 10
die beide die unvereinbarkeit liste in
verbindung mit zentrum automobil
behandeln und ich halte es für wichtig
dass wir hier auf diesem parteitag eine
debatte darüber führen wie wir uns zu
dieser gewerkschaft zu dieser
arbeitnehmervertretung verhalten und wie
wir generell zu solchen organisationen
unter unserer ein paar kites liste
stehen ich plädiere dafür diese beiden
anträge natürlich zusammen aber eben vor
der personalwahl zu behandeln vielen
dank
so das ist dann der antrag passiert ist
top 13 4 vorgesehen also s9 und essenzen
vor den top 11 zu ziehen doch der
spanier richtig
und 10 vor 11 und wir machen weiter an
blauen sein mikrofon
ja
ich will erstens eine gegenrede halten
zu dem antrag von parteifreund vinzenz
der beantragt hat sich mit theo 7
aufhebung der beschlüsse zur
auftrittsverbot von andreas kalbitz
nicht so befassen unabhängig davon ganz
unabhängig davon wie man zur andreas
kalbitz steht und wie man zu diesem
antrag steht ist doch so dass die person
andreas kalbitz sich nicht in luft
aufgelöst hat sie ist da sie wirkt in
der brandenburgische landtagsfraktion
und es entstehen durch diese beschlüsse
zahlreiche unklarheiten
personen haben schon ordnungsmaßnahme
erhalten weil sie bei privaten
veranstaltungen mit andreas kalbitz
gesehen wurden die aber als partei
auftritte gewertet wurden hier hat die
gesamtpartei ein interesse an einer
klärung noch mal unabhängig davon wie
man dazu steht sollte diese frage auf
jeden fall behandelt werden allerdings
erst nach dem personal wahlen also
entsprechend dem vorschlag des
bundesvorstandes aber bitte keine
nichtbefassung
dann machen wir weiter im roten saal
mikrofon
ja ich möchte herrn tillschneider
explizit und ausdrücklich widersprechen
ich bin ich hier aus bayern drei stunden
und zwölf minuten angereist um hier
irgendwelche personaldebatten zu führen
ich bin hierhergekommen um zu arbeiten
und nichts für ungut eine
privatveranstaltung ist es dann nicht
wenn afd wappen oder der gleiche auf
diese veranstaltungen gezeigt werden
da haben gerichte entschieden im fall
von herrn andreas kalbitz und deswegen
nicht befassen
wieso sollten wir die ordentliche
gerichtsbarkeit hier jetzt auch in frage
gestellt da ist doch lächerlich
dann machen wir vorne weiter am
rednerpult
bollinger landesverband rheinland pfalz
liebe parteifreunde meine damen und
herren ich
glaube dass unser land und unsere partei
von uns einen aufbruch erwarten welche
aufbruch tasse ist das hat tino keller
eben zu recht gesagt dass wir eine
bundesvorstand der einigkeit wählen die
unsere partei zusammenführt und das
sollte im mittelpunkt dieses bundes
parteitags stehen und sollte heute im
vordergrund stehen
gleichwohl begrüße ich den ansatz
inhaltliche impulse zu setzen und die
öffentlichkeit zu tragen wer sich aber
auch nur ansatzweise mit
öffentlichkeitsarbeit beschäftigt hat
der weiß dann müssen wir eine klare
botschaft setzen da kann man heute
keinen bunten blumenstrauß aus den
resolutionen anbieten da muss mal ein
thema klar herausgreifen und da bin ich
der auffassung dass da der landesverband
sachsen mit der thematik das wd in die
kernkraft einsteigen den richtigen punkt
gesetzt hat
wir sehen auch im landtag
rheinland-pfalz wo ich für die afg
vertreter bin dass die art partei dort
auf den zug aufspringen dieses thema
müssen wir klar für uns besetzen das
thema das parteiintern nicht umstritten
ist deshalb sollten wir den punkt
vorziehen und beantrage dann aber
zunächst diesen punkt zu setzen dass
werden in großer einheit tun können
damit klar machen dass die ard dieses
thema gesetzt hat und dann den
bundesvorstand zu wählen der die partei
wieder zusammenführen und die partei und
deutschland voranbringen wird vielen
dank
herr bollinger als anträge sind die
schon gestellt richtig dass kein neuer
antrag dabei die kernkraft vorzuziehen
die farbe explizit als einzigen
resolutionstext eben die kernkraft zu
ziehen und die andere dann genau dass
sie ihren vortrag wie im vorschlag des
bundesvorstands nach der vorstandswahl
abzuhalten gut dass ein antrag der
antrag asse ihr habt vielen dank dann
machen weiter am blauen sein mikrofon
vielen dank herr vorsitzender felix
rechner seines vorstand brandenburg ich
möchte beantragen unseren
tagesordnungspunkt jetzt ob
20.14 sn elf zusammen zu behandeln mit
top 20.4 es n8
inhaltlich geht es um dieselbe sache
unser antrag der iss weitergehen aber es
geht um die abwendung der drohenden
internationalen isolation und natürlich
um die im europaparlament beschlossenen
sogenannten transnationalen listen die
wenn wir dieses thema nicht hier auf dem
parteitag behandeln zur folge hätten das
und mandatsverlust im übernächsten jahr
dass wir das erwarten könnten und das
wäre eine katastrophe für uns und ich
bitte das zusammen zu behandeln getrennt
abzustimmen vielen dank noch einmal
einmal der antrag es m8 der aktuell hier
vorgesehen ist unter 20 top 20 4 und was
noch das ist unser antrag landesvorstand
brandenburg die vier abwendung drohender
internationale isolation der ok also
zusammenzufassen 20
top 20 1 und
top 20 4 das sind dann die anträge
theophil
11 und fm
[Musik]
gut
das ist aufgenommen bevor wir jetzt
gleich am roten see mikrofon weiter
machen habe ich hier zwischendurch von
der verwaltung tatsächlich den hinweis
bekommen dass in der tat was sehr
misslich ist die schwarzweiß fassung
offensichtlich etwas anderes ein anderer
antrag fassung hatte als die erfassung
im bund da sind 150 stück von
ausgedruckt worden und nicht mit letzten
antrag stand verteilt worden das heißt
jeder von ihnen möge der nun wieder
einmal kurz schauen wer eine
schwarz-weiß fassen hat einmal kurz mit
der blauen stimmkarte einfach mal kurz
hoch hat das einmal sehen können wir
haben hier schon neue gedruckt oder sie
laufen jedenfalls gerade wer also einen
schwarz weiß druck hat und das nicht
parallel schoss am handy vielleicht in
bunt aufgemacht hat es müssten
eigentlich mehr sein
sind irgendwie offen sich nur einige da
haben wir hier vorne am antrags tisch
neue fassung da können sie also einfach
hingehen und sich das austauschen gerne
schon mal so zwischendurch dass sie
jetzt auch die aktuellen fassung
vielen dank wir sind zurück haben oder
der asd auf dem dreizehnten
bundesparteitag in riesa soweit erstmals
die äußerungen von
von
von der leyen die chefin der eu
kommission aber hier in riesa geht es
jetzt in der frage der afg auf dem 13
bundesparteitag darum der debatte um die
frage was wird was wollen wir zuerst
also dass die afg zuerst über programme
reden über inhalte reden da über
personal entscheiden
interessant war dass die hyper vor
kurzem hier ans rednerpult getreten ist
und sich für die wahl erst über inhalte
und dann und über die wahlen zu
debattieren geäußert hat und aber ich
habe inzwischen 18 oder 19
änderungsanträge zu einem verfahren
gehört dass der bundesvorstand
vorgeschlagen hat und der bundesvorstand
als fazit kann man sagen will zuerst
war allen durchziehen und dann über
programme reden und über inhalte reden
und genau dieses ist derzeit stand der
diskussion über die frage geht es mit
der tagesordnung weiter
ursprünglich war und in welcher
reihenfolge das bleibt ihnen überlassen
bleiben sie ganz kurz anrufen also einen
antrag auf ende der debatte verhindert
nicht dass noch weitere anträge gestellt
werden und zu diesen neuen anträgen auch
eine debatte geführt wird war wird die
wir haben keinen antrag weitere
änderungsanträge zu untersagen das gibt
es nicht
das ist ja
so
mir wird jetzt hier gerade wie das in
teilen das präsidium schon mal
verstanden wurde und auch verstanden
werden kann dass sie die
änderungsanträge
nicht befassen möchten
die es hier gestellt wurden
das dann mögen sie doch wenn dafür
verstehen ist damit einmal danach ganz
klar sagen dass wir sie nicht
fehlinterpretieren ja vielen dank im
grunde setzen sie damit das vom krieg um
weil sich gewünscht habe um das ganze zu
beenden und sich wieder konzentriert der
sache zuzuwenden
ok beantragt ist zur geschäftsordnung
von herrn förster
die änderungsanträge hier die gestellt
wurden die verschiedenen ich würde gern
einmal in schnell formen durch rat an
die nicht zu befassen damit blieben wir
dann beim ursprünglichen verfahren
beantragt des bundesvorstands wenn das
entsprechend angenommen würde das ist
auch gleichzeitig der weitergehende
antrag
jetzt muss ich mich einmal ganz kurz
beraten wie wir das von der reihenfolge
machen bitte warten sie kurz
also das war gerade ein mitglied der
wollte dass die ganzen änderungsanträge
die ihr in der letzten stunde seit
vorstellungen des bundesvorstands wie
das verfahren für diesen parteitag
weitergehen soll behandelt wurden
obsolet sind und der bundesvorstand mit
seinem verfahren hier praktisch
abgestimmt werden soll
würden standardmäßig würde ich das jetzt
abstimmen lassen und dann könnten danach
wieder neue anträge gestellt werden sie
können natürlich auch wenn das ihr als
antragsteller ihr einverständnis findet
sagen wird zurückgestellt dann können
jetzt erst noch die änderungsanträge
gestellt werden und danach wurden wir
nachher wenn wir eben das abstimmen rein
geben zuerst über die anträge auf
nichtbefassung mit den änderungsanträgen
stimmen das aber als antragsteller ihr
recht zu sagen wie sie das
möchten
standardmäßig wo sich ansonsten jetzt
sofort abstimmen mit der folge dass
danach dann weitere änderungsanträge
gestellt werden könnten
erfasst
also die frage sollen diese andere
änderungsanträge jetzt obsolet sein
darüber muss jetzt der parteitag
offensichtlich abstimmen weil es ein
bauantrag von einem mitglied gegeben hat
der sich jetzt aber dazu noch mal klar
äußern ist auf dem weg die weil die
wahre frage doch mal konkret
also die frage ist ob sie ob ihr antrag
sofort abgestimmt werden sollen mit der
folge dass danach auf die
änderungsanträge gestellt werden könnten
oder ob der nachdem alle
änderungsanträge gestellt sind dann dort
als dann weitestgehende antrag in der im
gesamten abstimmungsprozedere dann
folgen soll ich glaube letzteres ist das
sinnvollere weil wir sonst wieder zu
immerhin zu neuen anträgen kommt dann
ist das so aufgenommen antrag von herrn
förster ist ihnen dann auch bekannt dann
haben wir als nächstes hier vorne am
mikrofon herrenlose
heißt jetzt werden erst einmal weiter
änderungsanträge stellen freunde gibt ja
keine zeitbegrenzung aber ganz ehrlich
ich will jetzt keine bewerbungsrede
halten keine angst einmal zum punkt theo
sechs einsetzung einer kommission zur
vorbereitung einer parteistrukturen vor
meine damen und herren das ist nichts
anderes als system von lucke er wollte
eine kooptiert er wollte im grunde ein
zusatz gremium zum bundesvorstand
einschalten deshalb meine damen und
herren sollte dieser punkt idealerweise
von der tagesordnung gestrichen werden
also ich bin für die streichung des teo
sechs meine damen und herren
und ich möchte noch einen kürzlichen
änderungsantrag stellen der herr hilse
hat zu recht gesagt kernenergie ist ein
wichtiges thema wir haben eine massive
blackout gefahr in deutschland deswegen
dürfen das thema aber auch nicht zu kurz
gesprungen denken und deshalb gibt es ja
noch den antrag sn sechs der moment als
top 13.6 hiermit aufgelistet ist
energiesicherheit stadt energiewende und
da gibt es natürlich noch mehr maßnahmen
als einfach nur kernkraftwerke zu bauen
die im moment sowieso nicht gebaut
werden weil es keinen investor gibt denn
dort hat er das machen wir das heißt wir
müssen uns da natürlich andere dinge
auch überlegen weiterlaufen von
kernkraftwerken braunkohletagebaue noch
beibehalten et cetera und deshalb bitte
ich darum oder beantrage ich dass dieser
messe m6 zusammen mit dem sn zwei und t1
und sn 3 also die kenner nötige sachen
zusammen behandelt werden um ein erster
antrag ist dass das entweder jetzt also
mein erster antrag ist das mit 13 1
zusammenzulegen 13 6 und 13 1 es sei
denn dass der antrag fundament hilse der
zuerst gestellt wurde durch kommt dass
nach vorne zu ziehen dann bitte ich das
entsprechend mit dem antrag von deren
hilfe zusammen zu behandeln und dort
dann entsprechend den str6 zusammen dann
vorgezogen mit theo 1 und sn 23 zusammen
zu behandeln das wäre für mich auch das
wünschenswerte hre zu machen dass man
alles was mir energie zusammen hat hält
zusammenhält dann auch darauf zusammen
behandelt dankeschön
vielleicht
mag er hilfe dem ja so zustimmen das ist
mir dann einfach ein gemeinschaftlicher
antrag käse lose
daumen rauf runter oder schnell
ja ganz schnell
gerade bei kernkraft haben wir ein
alleinstellungsmerkmal
wir haben absolutes
alleinstellungsmerkmal was wir bei uns
im grundsatzprogramm drin stehen haben
und was wir in jedem bundestagswahlkampf
programm
hatten also drin stehen hatten und
deswegen würde ich nicht vermischen wir
alle die uns kennen die mit uns arbeiten
die uns verfolgen wissen wir wissen dass
wir kohlekraftwerke weiter betreiben
wollen und so weiter und so fort aber
kernkraft ist entscheidende
alleinstellungsmerkmal
und wir sollten es nicht indem wir
diesen antrag ablehnen oder diese
resolution aufblähen lässt wenig
verwaschen gut viel kraft also ich würd
es nicht vereinen wollen okay war ja
auch nur mal so eine spontane idee an
der stelle dann machen wir weiter am
blauen saal mikrofon
christa cremer nordrhein-westfalen meine
lieben parteifreunde
programm ist wichtig aber personen
stellen allen programm da und jede
partei wird beim wähler über die
personen identifiziert
wenn ihr heute nikolausfest alice weibel
oder kino gowalla oder norbert
kleinwächter oder herrn hüppe wählen ist
das eine fundamentale
programmatische aussage über unsere
programmatische ausrichtung und deswegen
sollten wir diese für den wähler
entscheidende sache hat sie
vielen dank dann machen wir am roten
sein mikrofon
michael fritsch landesverband rheinland
pfalz ich möchte noch mal ausdrücklich
unterstützen was mein kollege dr
wandinger gesagt hat lasst uns vor den
wahlen des bundesvorstands das thema
kernenergie gerne mit beiden anträgen
dazu auch energiesicherheit hier
behandeln dieses thema werden wir
weitgehend im konsens beschließen können
das ist eine klare botschaft nach außen
die anderen anträge bergen alle eine
menge innerparteilichen konflikt stoff
ich fürchte wir werden uns hier heillos
zerstritten und was dann morgen in der
presse steht kann sich jeder selbst
vorstellen insofern bitte ich euch darum
lasst uns dieses eine thema nach vorne
stellen auf wegen der
öffentlichkeitswirkung und lasst uns
dann endlosen vorstand wählen und alles
weitere in folge des parteitags hier
behandeln
vielen dank da machen wir vorn am
rednerpult weiter ich würde ich bitte
außerdem noch einmal herrn krämer noch
mal zurück ans mikrofon ob ich da ist
ein antrag überhört habe war ich mir zu
nachgaben nicht ganz sicher ob da ein
konkreter antrag drin war erst einmal
aber hier vorne herr kuss
ok vielen dank bevor wir nachher zur
abstimmung kommen möchte ich folgendes
zu bedenken geben
es gibt gute gründe
fachfragen vorher zu behandeln und
entsprechend einen punkt zu setzen egal
was die presse dann schreibt es gibt
gute gründe dafür das personal zuerst zu
wählen und dadurch auch natürlich einen
signal zu setzen aber egal was wir
machen jetzt besteht die problematik
dass wenn wir zu viel vorher diskutieren
über fachfragen dass sich einzelne
berufen fühlen ihrer bewerbungsrede
vorweg zu nehmen und das sollten wir
nicht unterschätzen ich möchte überhaupt
niemand irgendetwas unterstellen aber es
ist einfach menschlich und genau so
menschlich ist es auch dass manche
vielleicht aus der befürchtung heraus
wenn sie sich zuseher positionieren und
äußern dass sie dann befürchten nicht
gewählt zu werden und deshalb schweigen
das wäre aus meiner sicht fatal deshalb
lasst uns daher
vernünftig umgehen mit dieser
entscheidung und das in erwägung vielen
vielen dank
joachim kunz scheidende
bundesvorstand entscheidet das
bundesvorstandsmitglied der noch einmal
ja das verfahren für den bundesvorstand
in seinem antrag geklärt wollte damit
sagen dass
personen frage entscheidend für unsere
programmatische ausrichtung ist und dass
ein signal nach außen sind und deswegen
sollten wir dabei bleiben sowie waren
vom bundesvorstand vor
dankeschön dann hatte dann hatte ich das
doch richtig und wir haben einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag
ich bitte dazu die versammlungsleitung
dazu aufzufordern endlich zum
tagesordnungspunkt zurückzugehen der
tagesordnungspunkt ist anträge zur
tagesordnung der tagesordnungspunkt ist
nicht dass sich einzelne leute ohne
andere hier ans mikrofon stelle mir die
zeit clowns und ihre persönliche meinung
zu anträgen der kunst und das können sie
gerne tun wenn der antrag gestellt wird
und abgestimmt wird nicht bitte einfach
darum dass die versammlungsleitung hat
endlich auch durch etwas hier auch der
verantwortung gerade steht
also das ist jetzt kein
geschäftsordnungsantrag
den vollständigen katalog der
geschäftsordnungsantrag können sie der
geschäftsordnung für bundesparteitage
unserer partei entnehmen die lektüre
lohnt immer
und in der tat
befinden wir uns in einer debatte zur
tagesordnung der hinweis ist korrekt
aber an dieser stelle ist es so nächsten
vortrag habe ich dort gesehen bekommt
sofort ran in der tat ist es aber so
dass kommende mehrere
geschäftsordnungsanträge nebenbei alle
sofort daran
dass bis zu einem gewissen grad
natürlich gesagt werden können muss
warum dann einen antrag besonders
wichtig ist was nicht erfolgen darf ist
das schon die begründung und der antrag
in der sache die diskussion hier
vorgezogen wird da versuchen wir darauf
zu achten die grenzen sind fließend das
mögen sie nachsehen wir haben jetzt die
nächsten geschäftsordnungsantrag rote
saal mikrofon bitte
liebe delegierte stelle jetzt den
geschäftsordnungsantrag
schluss der debatte und abstimmung über
den antrag den der bundesvorstand
vorgelegt hatte ich begründe diesen
alltag wie folgt lieberherr klar war das
tun sie nicht weil sie haben in der
debatte schon gesprochen und deshalb
können sie diesen
geschäftsordnungsantrag nicht stellen
ok ich finde einen stellvertreter jawohl
wir haben aber an weiteren
geschäftsordnungsantrag auf der anderen
seite blaue saal mikrofon bitte
ja ich möchte einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag stellen und zwar
als allererstes begrenzung der redezeit
das ist erst mal interessant damit wir
hier keine bewerbungsrede hören von
irgendwelchen kandidaten oder
potenziellen kandidaten und das würde
uns einiges an zeit ersparen herr schulz
einmal kurz wie viel minuten mein
vorschlag wäre eine minute weil das muss
ausreichen weil es soll hier ein antrag
gestellt werden um nichts neues
begründungen in der gleichen rede gut
führt diesen für diesen top habe ich es
richtig war schon für diesen top
beantragen sie einredet begrenzung von
einer minute wir würden ihn nachher für
andere tagesordnungspunkte auch
vorschläge dann direkt auch unterbreiten
zu beginn der diskussion dass man dort
auch das gleichzeitig ein wenig
eingrenzt so dazu frage ich gibt es eine
gegenrede
normales prozedere bezieht sich
sicherlich auf die äußerungen nicht dann
auf unter einer weise von prominenten
wie die stärke der rednerpult damals
schon eine mehrminütige rede gehalten
hat ohne einen direkten antrag also das
verfahren einzuhalten formuliert hatte
sind antrag folgen möchte bitte ich um
die blaue stimmkarte
dankeschön gegenstimmen
vereinzelt enthaltungen noch
vereinzelter dann ist der antrag mit
großer mehrheit angenommen die rede vom
einigungs anträge selbst auf eine minute
redezeit begrenzt
danke kollege flac ich mache mir den
antrag vom kollegen glas zu eigen und
stelle jetzt den antrag ende der debatte
über die tagesordnung und abstimmung
über den eingebrachten vorschlag des
bundesvorstands vielen dank
[Applaus]
einen augenblick das würde nach wie vor
nicht verhindern dass noch
änderungsanträge gestellt werden können
ich habe dazu eine gegend ist dann haben
wir eine gegenwerte bitteschön ja ich
glaube die absicht des bundesvorstandes
mit diesem eigenen antrag war in die
debatte eine struktur zu bringen aber
ich habe den eindruck dass leider genau
das gegenteil damit erreicht wurde und
deswegen halte ich es für sinnvoll
dass wir jetzt nicht über diesen antrag
abstimmen wo wir sowieso nicht mehr ganz
klar sind alle uhr über wir genau mit
den ganzen änderungsanträgen gesprochen
haben und würde das mit einem weiteren
geo antrag dann versuchen aufzuklären in
dem ich meinerseits den antrag stelle
nicht den antrag des bundesvorstandes zu
befassen sondern die tu anträge jetzt
einen nach dem anderen durch zu gehen
dann wissen wir jeder wo wir eigentlich
sind und worüber wir sprechen und kommen
damit glaube ich auch ganz gut
strukturiert durch
dankeschön
das müssen wir einmal kurz wir sortieren
um das würde bedeuten dass auf jeden
fall die programmatischen anträge die
zum thema kernkraft zum thema
waffenlieferungen für die ukraine und
zum thema europa gestellt werden in
denen es unter anderem heißt dass sie
vor dem bundestag
bundessprecher und vor dem
bundesvorstands wahlen stattfinden auf
jeden fall behandelt werden denn das was
der bundesvorstand in seinem papier als
verfahren angeregt hat ist ja genau das
gegenteil
das würde das verfahren zur tagesordnung
natürlich noch mal neu aufdröseln und
völlig neu auf die reset taste drücken
indem sozusagen die elf anträge zur
tagesordnung einzeln behandelt werden
und auch einzeln debattiert und so
einzelne sterne und ja das sind
interessante anträge und ich möchte ich
ihnen einmal ganz kurz muss in ganz kurz
auf einmal einsortieren damit sie gleich
wissen worüber sie dort abstimmen in der
gegenrede hat der kollege noch einen
weitergehenden geschäftsordnungsantrag
gestellt sind gegen rede gehalten und
einen weitergehenden geschäftsordnung
antrag gestellt nämlich den antrag auf
nichtbefassung sofa habe ich das
verstanden wenn sie das anders
verstanden haben wollen dann bitte bitte
nochmal direkt am mikrofon sich melden
aber das war schon glaube ich war schon
gut verständlich neben den antrag auf
nichtbefassung mit dem verfahrens antrag
des bundesvorstands auf denen sich
wiederum
ausnahmslos alle jetzt genannten
änderungsanträge beziehen
wir wären dann in der debatte wieder
aufs antrags buch zurückgeworfen anträge
müssten neu gestellt werden das ist
alles gut möglich ich will ihn nur
aufzeigen was das bedeutet zu diesem
geschäftsordnung der weitergehen ist es
den anderen antrag stellen der
abstimmung kurz zurück weil er sich eher
übrigen würde wenn wir alles hier nicht
befassen zudem geschäftsordnungsantrag
rufe ich jetzt frage ich jetzt ob es
dazu eine gegenrede gibt die gegenrede
zu dem antrag auf nichtbefassung nicht
weiter befassung mit dem antrag des
bundesvorstandes der antragsteller
selbst
also liebe parteifreunde ich würde doch
darum bitten dass wir bei der jetzt
schon vorhandenen konsolidierung der
wenigen anderen nicht alle anträge sind
so einige anträge insgesamt ungefähr 20
dass wir da weitermachen dass jemand
mich schon sehr weit gediehen es gibt ja
einzelne bereiche zb die über die frage
der mitgliederversammlung darüber hat
wohl noch niemand irgendetwas geredet
und das können relativ das ist
zusammengefasst das kann relativ schnell
dann auch verabschiedet werden und ich
glaube wir gehen wirklich wie gerade
eben gesagt wurde einen schritt zurück
wenn wir jetzt das ganze noch mal
aufmachen und aller 50 anträge die es
gibt da noch mal einzeln behandeln dann
sind wir wirklich wahrscheinlich heute
mittag erst fertig also dass deshalb
empfehle ich dass wir hier weiter machen
bei dem bisherigen vorschlag von uns und
dass wir das jetzt noch durchziehen das
ist so schlimm ist das nicht die anträge
sind notiert und dann wird einfach eins
nach dem anderen abgestimmt und dann
haben wir ein ergebnis und dann können
wir zum nächsten tagesordnungspunkt
weitergehen dankeschön vielen dank dann
kommen wir jetzt zuerst zur abstimmung
über den weitestgehenden antrag das ist
der antrag auf nichtbefassung mit dem
gesamten verfahrens antrag
inklusive aller dazu jetzt gestellten
änderungsanträge weil die sind dort
aktiv so risch so nochmal sehen sich zur
klarstellung
es soll die reset taste gedrückt werden
und alles das was das was der
bundesvorstand an gewusst für das
verfahren
wenn man weg legen und soll sich an dem
inhaltsverzeichnis
des antrags buchs orientieren
unmittelbar vorher gestellten
geschäftsordnungsantrag auf ende der
debatte was immer noch beinhalten können
dass danach noch anträge gestellt werden
könnten aber dann haben sie dann haben
sie das so weit in der abstimmungs
reihenfolge jetzt vor sich ich hoffe das
ist alles soweit klar
wir sind jetzt in der abstimmung wenn es
danach kommt die weiter das könnte sie
können jetzt nur an weitergehenden
geschäftsordnung antrag stellen außer
ganz komische sachen habe ich da weniger
dafür aber bitteschön ja also ich glaube
wirklich war ja dabei dass sie diesen
antrag missverstanden haben es wurde
beantragt schluss der debatte und
abstimmung über den antrag des
bundesvorstands das heißt in der sache
nein also wenn sie nicht der
antragsteller sind dort an der stelle
ist es glaube ich deutlich verstanden
worden es gibt einmal ist einmal der
antrag auf schluss der debatte gestellt
worden und dann ist ein weiterer antrag
gestellt worden auf nichtbefassung mit
dem verfahrens antrag der iss
weitergehen wird deshalb zuerst
abgestimmt er hat diese anträge sind
glaube ich so weit gut verstanden
gewesen wenn jetzt der antragsteller
sagt ist weil falsch verstanden worden
dann möge der sich ummelden habe ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher den richtig
verstanden zu haben
gut da ist er wieder gegeben also mein
antrags ziel haben sie absolut korrekt
wiedergegeben das ist die nichtbefassung
mit dem verfahrens antrag
da kommen wir zur abstimmung und zwar
zuerst wegen weitergehender antrag das
ist der auf nichtbefassung mit dem
verfahrens antrag des bundesvorstands
wer dem seine zustimmung erteilen möchte
bitte ich jetzt um die blaue stimmkarte
dann würden wir
gut gegen
stimmenenthaltung das ist mit großer
mehrheit abgelehnt
das heißt also das verfahren ist der
bundesvorstand für den weiteren verlauf
des parteitages vorgelegt hat wird
weiter diskutiert und die ganzen
änderungsanträge lehrerzahlen jetzt 20
ungefähr sind mit eingeführt werden mit
eingebunden in dieses verfahren was wir
zuerst mache noch mal als fazit
abstimmen in diesem verfahren des
bundesvorstandes geht es dann erst um
die satzung ein oder zwei sprecher und
dann lottes nachdem das wort des
landesverbandes direkt zu den
bundesvorstands wahlen gehen
enthaltung dann ist das mit großer
mehrheit beschlossen
wir müssen uns ja einmal kurz gleich
sortieren weitere änderungsanträge
sind nicht mehr da
gut wir sortieren uns einmal kurz bitte
geben sie uns eine minute
so an dieser stelle vermute ich ist dann
logischerweise der nächste antrag den es
in der antragsphase zur tagesordnung
gegeben hat nämlich das ende der debatte
das heißt also
ein ende der anträge die eingereicht
werden um das verfahren des
bundesvorstandes noch zu ändern oder zu
beeinflussen
beendet werden soll soweit ich das
verstanden habe ist diese debatte vom
parteitag jetzt per stimmabgabe
entschieden worden dass sie erst mal
einen stopp machen wollen das verfahren
muss jetzt weitergehen der
versammlungsleiter jochen flach ein
versierter versammlungsleiter hat von
über 100 parteitage und
bezirksversammlungen und so weiter
geleitet also er ist mit sicherheit
derjenige der dann auch weiß wie es
weitergeht obwohl
das präsidium sich jetzt auch erstmal
sammeln muss um zu gucken wie mit der
flut der anträge jetzt umgegangen wird
klar ist nur dass noch nicht
endgültig feststeht an welcher stelle
die inhalte die die partei besprechen
will und sich dafür positionieren will
behandelt werden ist dort in den
änderungsanträgen oder wurde auch
genannt dass einzelne teile als es um
die kernenergie beging einzelne teile
doch vorgezogen werden also dass die
inhalts debatte quasi geteilt wird all
das muss jetzt sortiert werden und muss
in einem schnellverfahren mit in dieses
gerüst muss der bundesvorstand gelegt
hat mit eingebunden werden und da müssen
sich die präsidenten ergie aber erst
sagen haben jetzt kurz eine einwerfen
wir brauchen gleich ihre aufmerksamkeit
so die frage ist halt wie diese
änderungsanträge jetzt in die debatte
einfließen und es gibt ja noch diese
debatte in der ganz am schluss darüber
abgestimmt werden soll das ist
jedenfalls auch noch zur
abstimmung offen ob diese ganzen
änderungsanträge schlussendlich nicht
befasst werden sollen ich denke mal dass
das teil
des köpfe ineinander stecken des
präsidiums und das nachdenken das ist
was sie dort gerade eben sehen derweil
wird im saal weiter diskutiert und klar
ist nochmal ich fasse zusammen dass das
gerüst des verfahrens wie mit der
tagesordnung umgegangen wird vom
bundesvorstand da wurde das gerüst heute
nacht per e mail an die mitglieder
verschickt
verabschiedet wurde das heißt also das
gerüst steht und
das was dann noch geändert werden muss
in diesem gerüst was jetzt heute teil
der debatte war ungefähr in anderthalb
bis zwei stunden
die jetzt schon darüber diskutiert
werden fließt jetzt eben mit einem die
delegierten warten genauso wie hier von
der presse wie es jetzt in irgendeiner
art und weise weitergeht und welche zu
welchen schlüssen das tagungs präsidium
kommt in der frage der weiteren
vorgehensweise klar ist nur dass es nach
diesem ende der debatte 5 auf jeden fall
das grußwort geben wird von urban er ist
ja landesvorsitzender von sachsen und
wird sich mit sicherheit in einem
grußwort auch noch aus sie haben einmal
ihre änderungsanträge
in eine abstimmen fähige reihenfolge
gebracht
ich stelle ihnen jetzt einmal die
abstimmen reihenfolge vor
da gibt es noch ein antrag zur
geschäftsordnung
ja ich darf noch mal darauf hinweisen
dass ich meinen sie ans den
weitestgehenden antraten
herr förster sie
das deshalb steht hier bei ihrem antrag
bei uns eine eins nämlich als der
weitergehend der zuerst ich würde jetzt
gerne einmal die reihenfolge vorstellen
es beginnt mit dem antrag von herrn
förster auf nichtbefassung mit allen
änderungsanträgen der ist am
weitestgehenden durch den würden sich
alle änderungsanträge zum verfahrens
antrag erledigen und dann würden wir nur
noch die abstimmung mit dem verfahrens
antrag ab wenn der antrag aber abgelehnt
wird würden wird dann wie folgt vorgehen
nämlich zuerst die diversen einzelnen
nichtbefassung soder absetzung amt regel
aufrufen das ist zum einen
von herrn vinzenz nichtbefassung mit
theo 7 auftrittsverbote kalbitz als
stichwort dann die drei absetzung
anträge von herrn köhler das ist einmal
der theo
drei.to 3 ist als stichwort für sie
resolutionen waffenlieferungen dann
haben wir theo 5
das ist einsetzung
einsetzung
einer untersuchung
die untersuchungskommission eingesetzt
werden soll die play ag der afg zum
thema verfassungsschutz untersuchen und
bewerten soll je nachdem welche dort
drauf bleiben oder dann nicht drauf sind
würden sich gegebenenfalls abstimmungen
über die verordnung entsprechende
anträge die danach kommen erledigen nach
diesem anträgen kommen wird tatsächlich
zu anträgen die gleichrangig sind und
die deshalb in der reihenfolge wie sie
hergestellt sind zur abstimmung kommen
im wesentlichen zumindest mit einer
ausnahme die ich ihnen gleich auch
vorstellen wir hatten dann zuallererst
den antrag die
satzungsänderungen und die
geschäftsordnung änderungen vorzuziehen
da wo jetzt der top acht ist das
betrifft die top 14 15 16 und 18 der
vorläufigen
tagesordnung
dann kommen die beiden anträge von herrn
neuhoff das ist einmal den das direkt
nach dem top 7 das ist das grußwort des
gastgebenden landesverbandes dass dort
der co2 unter theo drei behandelt werden
mögen das ist einmal die resolution
europa neu denken und einmal die
resolution waffenlieferung stoppen
dialogs daten gesamt europäische
friedensordnung das ist sicher wir haben
dann den antrag von herrn hilse den
themenkomplex kernkraft nach top 7 zu
behandeln das ist dann der top 13.1 mit
den anträgen theo 1 s 2 und s n 3
danach dort anschließend den antrag von
herrn lose den antrag sn 6 in diesem
komplex mit zu behandeln je nachdem wo
der antrag von den heese dann
gegebenenfalls verortet ist danach geht
es weiter den antrag habe ich keinen
namen hier dabei geschrieben aber den
top 20 34 top elf das war das
parteischädigendes verhalten als
stichwort zu behandeln dann der antrag
von herrn röcke den theo 6 das ist
wieder die strukturkommission vor den
top 11 die wahlen zu befassen dann haben
wir doch den antrag von herrn spanien
den top 13 4
mit den anträgen es in neun und zehn
form top-elf zu so und während wir jetzt
noch darauf warten wie der parteitag
sich entscheidet mit diesen
änderungsanträgen ob die überhaupt
behandelt werden oder nicht gebe ich
jetzt erst mal zurück zu alexander
kähler ansetzt
ja liebe zuschauerin die zuschauer
wahrscheinlich mache es mehr sinn wenn
doris müller dann den fortgang der
ereignisse hier zusammen fasst dann ist
es auch leichter verständlich und wir
haben die möglichkeit hier als
lückenbüßer vom dienst weiter über
grundsätzliche fragen der afg zu
sprechen bei mir nach wie vor professor
wolfgang schröder universität kassel
wissenschaftszentrum bei liegen der
schulter als gerade ursula von der leyen
in unserer interview gequetscht ist und
bekannt zu geben dass die ukraine
beitrittskandidat werten wird sprachen
wir bei den verfassungsschutz der die
afg beobachtet auf bundes wie auch auf
einigen landesebene die frage war ja wie
es hier belastet dass die partei manche
sagen ja stört uns nicht hilft und
vielleicht sogar verschärft dass
radikale profil aber ist es nicht auch
so dass viele in der partei das als
belastung empfinden extrem so höher weil
mit dem verfassungsschutz ist eine
deposit in die partei eingekehrt wo ich
mehr klar ist kann man sicher
authentisch sprechen wer hört mit was
sind die folgen unseres tuns also die
partei ist nicht mehr alleine sie ist
nicht mehr unbeobachtet sie ist nicht
mehr im ackern um des authentischen
sondern sie muss sich rechtfertigen und
das führt zur verdächtigung führt zu
einem klima der missgunst und ist eine
aura die für die partei ob sie das sich
selbst eingesteht ob sie das will oder
nicht ist eine dauernde begleitung die
diese partei verändert das hat die fdp
vor einiger zeit den staatsrechtler
dietrich murswiek
beauftragt mal aufzustellen was man
eigentlich alles nicht sagen darf um ins
fadenkreuz des verfassungsschutzes zu
kommen da gibt es ein gutachten das
veröffentlicht worden für jedermann
jeder frau zugänglich da stehen eine
menge drin dinge drin die vermietet
werden sollen aber man hat das gefühl
dass nicht unwesentlich oder soll man
nicht unwichtige
parteimitglieder also aus der spitze und
der weiteren spitze darauf pfeifen und
diese warnungen von herrn musik in den
wind schlagen naja man will eben nicht
anerkennen dass der verfassungsschutz
ein ständiger begleiter ist und dann
kommt er auch hinzu was ist das
erfolgsmodell der afg das erfolgsmodell
ist dass sie tabus brechen dass die
aufmerksamkeit herstellen indem sie die
grenzen des sagbaren überschreiten und
das wollen sie sich nicht nehmen lassen
und dieses erfolgsrezept wollen sie
vorantreiben damit
kann sie aber dem verfassungsschutz der
arbeit sehr leicht weil sie zusätzliche
belege generieren die dann auch das
urteil über sie festigen können was
bringt das der partei wenn sie diese
tabus pflegt die wie gesagt ja zu einem
gewissen erfolg auch beitragen und auch
resonanz erzeugen in teilen der
bevölkerung wenn sie damit gefahr läuft
dann noch mehr ins fadenkreuz zu geraten
das könnte ja auch eines tages bei einem
parteienverbot enden genau das ist die
gratwanderung die sie zu beginn haben
man muss ja sehen wo kommt die afg her
und wie afd ist ja die kartei der
zornigen der nichtwähler und diese
gruppe hat man über diese
grenzüberschreitungen versucht
anzusprechen und bei laune zu halten und
die partei hat sich verändert ist eine
partei der ständigen metamorphosen das
heißt sie muss diese realität des
verfassungsschutzes anerkennen und sich
ein stück weit neu erfinden im korridor
der freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung und das fällt ihr schwer
aber die lust in der partei ist
weitverbreitet ständig die schrauben zu
überdrehen das ist ihr lebenselixier und
das ist ihr erfolgsgeheimnis insofern
bisher auch dieses bündnis zwischen den
sogenannten moderaten und den radikalen
eine komposition die über das hinausgeht
was die rechte in deutschland bisher
geboten hat und dieses erfolgs geheimnis
wollen sie natürlich nicht aufkündigen
sondern es geht weiter ja wie lange das
weitergehen also die moderaten oder die
sogenannten moderaten und die radikalen
die ja in ihren flüssen gefischt haben
hier jede menge fänge an land gezogen
haben da gab es ja enorme zuwächse es
gibt länder mit über 20
zweitstimmenanteil der afg im bund bei
unter zehn prozent damit sie bei weitem
nicht die kleinste partei im bundestag
lange geht das noch gut dieses doppel
spielen aber man kann nur für den
jetzigen politik zyklus sprechen und da
merkt man dass die moderaten sich
zurückziehen dass die radikalen die
oberhand gewinnen und das verändert die
partei so dass sie immer im schatten des
verfassungsschutzes agieren wird und
damit bleibt sie wenig attraktiv wird
wenig attraktiv für die kräfte die eine
heimstatt jenseits der union suchen und
das ist ja auch muss man daran erinnern
dass niedergang szenario aller rechten
parteien in deutschland bisher gewesen
dass sie weniger an der nachfrage
gescheitert sind sondern am angebot das
heißt das angebot was sie machen können
und zum angebot gehört eben auch sind
sie in der lage die inneren widersprüche
zu domestizieren und bei der afg haben
wir den eindruck dass sie nicht in der
lage ist die inneren widersprüche zu
domestizieren und greift die parteien
nach vielen rettungsringen erst war es
der euro dann migration dann klima dann
corona der jetzt möglicherweise die
folgen des ukraine kriegs die allerdings
ja auch auf die korona krise
zurückzuführen ist was was heißt das
jetzt wenn ihr kommt die partei mit
diesen einzelnen krisen die sie
nacheinander so arbeitet als quasi als
ihr politisches programm damit weiter
oder ist sie da gegenüber den anderen
parteien benachteiligt
sie hat zunächst mal ein vorteil indem
sie versucht in all diesen krisen so was
wie ein alleinstellungsmerkmal im
politischen wettbewerb zu erzielen das
gelingt der auch wenn man die korona
krise nimmt oder auch jetzt die ukraine
krise aber immer um den preis dass die
innere festigkeit darunter enorm leidet
also beispielsweise der russland kriegt
führt natürlich dazu dass es hier nicht
nur zuspruch gibt für die putin verstehe
rey sondern enormen gegenwind auch und
vor allen dingen im westen also aufs
ganze betrachtet haben sie kein thema
das fliegt und haben keine klammer die
die unterschiedlichen herkünfte und
perspektiven verbinden wenn wir von
perspektiven reden wir kennen den
schönen satz von franz müntefering
opposition ist mist alexander gauland
hat gestern nochmal gesagt investition
ist toll wir müssen dabei bleiben eine
fundamental opposition zu sein und auch
in zukunft zu bleiben ist das ein weg
der der afg hilft jetzt auf die längere
projektionsfläche die längere timeline
betrachtet zunächst mal kann man sagen
sie können nur fundamental opposition
und da wo sie glauben dass der zuspruch
bei den wahlen ihnen auch das fundament
liefert umgestaltung zu betreiben
scheitern sie das konnten wir vor kurzem
bei den kommunalwahlen in sachsen sehen
wo sie trotz enormen zuspruch es kein
einziges gestaltungs mandat herum haben
so wird es da jetzt hingehen in sachen
anschlussfähigkeit bündnisfähigkeit es
gibt ja immer wieder versuche in
thüringen ist das gleich in den anfängen
gescheitert als die cdu über die
abstände für windräder im thüringer
landtag ein entschließungsantrag
eingebracht hat die afg sofort raus
gesprungen um quasi die energiepolitik
der amt in berlin auch zu unterlaufen
die zahlt man sich doch cdu und die
linkskoalition in erfurt geeinigt auf
kosten der afg und die cdu ganz klar
signalisiert hat mit euch nicht da sind
mir zukommt so ziemlich vielen
kompromissen bereit ist das wieder ein
beispiel dafür dass die afd tatsächlich
auch auf absehbare zeit als
koalitionspartner ausfällt auch für die
union oder für die fdp also erstens
haben wir einen parteienwettbewerb der
in den letzten monaten sich sehr stark
auf die mitte zu bewegt hat das bedeutet
für die mehrheits behinderung sind die
kleineren parteien gar nicht mehr
notwendig zweitens braucht man für
koalition ja auch koalitions willigkeit
und wenn man keine koalitionsfähigkeit
hat dann ist ja der nächste schritt die
koalitionsfähigkeit gar nicht zu
erringen und die afd ist drittens in
einem tal und aus diesem tal sieht man
augenblicklich keine wirkliche nach
vorne bewegung sondern sie mauern sich
hier ein wenig ein für diese ein maurer
diese position gibt es einen zuspruch
der durchaus aufs ganze land berechnet
nach wie vor zwischen sieben und zehn
prozent
liegt also mit ihr ist zu rechnen als
eine kraft die in diesem bereich agieren
kann aber es ist keine kraft die den
parteienwettbewerb die das politische
klima in diesem lande positiv
unterstützen kann und neue möglichkeiten
von gestaltung und koalitionsbildung
offeriert sie reden jetzt von der
bundesebene schauen wir auf sachsen
sachsen anhalt thüringen welche
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten hat die asg
dort liegt sie ja über 20 prozent bei
der bundestagswahl war sie in thüringen
und sachsen sogar stärkste partei vor
der cdu in sachsen zum beispiel zehn der
16 direktmandate sind hier im bundesland
in dem auch in riesa liegt ja erworben
worden gibt es da noch
ausbaumöglichkeiten dass ich da noch
stärker auf diese sind östlichen
bundesländer konzentriert also erstens
mal hängen die weiteren
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten was koalition
und macht beteiligungen im osten geht
von der cdu ab da ist die cdu
verschlüsselung innerhalb der cdu sein
starkes ringen wie soll das weitergehen
wollen wir weiter in den koalitionen mit
den grünen der spd oder mit der fdp
unseren weg machen und da gibt es etwa
ein drittel die durchaus die option auf
der tagesordnung haben das wollen wir
mit der afg weil wir authentisch unsere
position unterbringen können die zweite
frage hinsichtlich der ausstrahlung des
ostens auf den westen da muss man sehr
vorsichtig sein erstens ist die position
im osten selbst nicht gesichert und
zweitens ist die ausstrahlung auf
gesamtdeutschland mit einer alleinigen
starken position in ostdeutschland nicht
zu schaffen und insofern sind sie darauf
angewiesen dass sie eine neue idee haben
wie sie mit ihrer partei sich nützlich
machen können im parteiensystem und das
ist augenblick überhaupt nicht erkennbar
soweit bisher wollten schildert
dankeschön so und jetzt hat sich ja
einiges ereignis beim parteitag und
darüber bringt sie auf den neuesten
stand jetzt doris müller vielen dank
alexander keller und ich geb direkt
das passt ja wunderbar wie die faust
aufs auge wir sind nämlich gerade in der
debatte über die ende anträge sie sehen
das vielleicht oben in der totalen im
saal gibt es eine eingeblendeten screen
in der es heißt nichtbefassung theo
sechs dahinter verbirgt sich das thema
einsetzung einer kommission zur
vorbereitung einer partei strukturreform
also eine extra kommission die dann auch
vom neuen bundesvorstand mit einem
leiter befasst werden soll der parteitag
entscheidet sich gerade darüber in
elektronische abstimmung ob sie sich
überhaupt mit diesem tagesordnungspunkt
befassen wollen oder nicht
die elektronische abstimmung endet jetzt
und das ergebnis wird eingeblendet
das heißt ich
vielleicht einmal waren aber wir sind da
ehrlich das heißt dieser punkt wird
behandelt
den antrag die
satzungsänderungen und die
geschäftsordnung änderung und top 14 15
16 und 18 auf 8 19 11 fortführen wenn
sie diesen antrag ihre zustimmung
erteilen möchten bitte ich sie jetzt um
die blaue stimmkarte
das nicht möchte die rote stimmkarte
enthaltung
dann ist das eine klare mehrheit dagegen
anthrax abgelehnt wir kommen dann vom
antrag 91 dass die resolution
co2 reduktion europa neu denken
nach dem top 7 aufgerufen werden möge
wer diesem
antrag seine zustimmung erteilen möge
bitte ich um das handzeichen
das heißt die partei entscheidet sich
gerade ob sie das thema europa vor dem
grußwortes gastgebende landesverbandes
setzen will
wir sind uns mit einer folie
vorzubereiten das ist also der antrag
das co2 nach top 7
behandelt wird nicht nicht befangen
bitte streichen
nach top 7 ich korrigiere mich nach 72
dahinter verbirgt sich das grußwort des
gastgebenden landesverbandes andern soll
direkt danach über das thema europa
gesprochen werden so wie es einen antrag
vorsieht und so wie es der
änderungsantrag vorsieht weil das im
gerüst des bundesvorstands so nicht
aufgelistet worden war und der parteitag
stimmt jetzt gerade darüber ab
inzwischen befinden sich 4 199
delegierte im saal der
parteitag hat ja ein bisschen schleppend
angefangen weil die delegierten erst
nach und nach gekommen sind aber von den
600 delegierten sind 499 im saal und
auch stimmberechtigt
21 und damit ist die abstimmung
geschlossen wird ein ergebnis einblicken
main
[Applaus]
das heißt knappe entscheidungen und dann
kommt über die frage europa diskutieren
vor dem personal war ein und das tops
abgelehnt worden die nach dem top 7
aufzurufen wer dem seine zustimmung
erteilen möchte ich jetzt um die
baustellen karte
für dagegen ist blau stuttgart nochmal
einmal die bauschutt karte alle wäre
dafür
gegenstimmen mit der roten karte man hat
hier vorne hier vorne ist hier vorne und
die monitore irgendwie ein bisschen
schwierig also noch einmal ganz kurz es
geht um den antrag von herrn neuhoff
dass der antrag theo drei antrag
waffenlieferungen stoppen die resolution
dass die nach top 7 behandelt werden
möge
das thema werden wir vor den wahlen noch
inhalte diskutieren noch einmal ja oder
nein darüber stimmt der parteitag gerade
beim thema waffenlieferungen für die
ukraine ja oder nein in einer resolution
ab und
enthaltungen
so wie ich das sehe ist eine deutliche
mehrheit dafür dass nach den wahlen
zu diskutieren
da haben wir hier alle drei eine gut
erkennbare mehrheit dagegen gesehen
ebenfalls abgelehnt
und wir kommen zum antrag von herrn
hilse den themenkomplex kernkraft das
sind dann
verfahrens antrag der top 13 1 mit den
anträgen theo 1 s s2 und s3 nach dem top
7 zu behandeln wird dem seine zustimmung
erteilen möchte bitte ich jetzt um auch
das ist das letzte thema großes thema
mit dem sich die fdp inhaltlich
beschäftigen wird das thema kernkraft
auch das soll mit diesem antrag nach dem
grußwort behandelt werden auch hier
wieder eine abstimmung darüber soll es
so sein oder soll es eben später nach
den wahlen stattfinden
ich weiß nicht ob frage an die technik
ob man dem bundesvorstand irgendwie in
die lage versetzen kann uns auch zu
hören
also auch der bundesvorstand hat
natürlich ein recht darauf
hier zu hören zu können wir
es kommt gleich jemand von der technik
und versucht das dort zu beheben in der
zwischenzeit versuche ich den antrag
noch einmal
so
langsam und deutlich
vorzutragen dass auch am vorstandstisch
ankommt
so da gibt es offensichtlich technische
kommunikationsschwierigkeiten
im tagungs präsidium und in zusammenhang
mit dem bundesvorstand lässt sich aber
mit sicherheit schnell beheben lassen
wir versuchen es noch einmal
test 23
wir haben hier den antrag von herrn
hilfe der da wünscht dass die
anträge unter top 13 1 das ist der
antrag theo 1 resolution für den bau
neuer atomkraftwerke in deutschland
mid sm 2 das ist der entsprechende
resolutionstext und essent drei
änderungsantrag zur resolution zur
kernenergie das diese dass dieser
themenkomplex gehandelt werden möge nach
dem top 7 ist das
verständlich gewesen ja wer diesem
antrag seine zustimmung erteilen möchten
wir jetzt bittet die blaue stimmkarte
heben
dankeschön gegenstimmen
enthaltung
das ist eine gut erkennbare mehrheit
dafür dass der antrag angenommen
dann heißt es dass nach dem grußwort des
und landesverbandes es erstmal um das
thema
wie positioniert sich die afg in dieser
tage energiewende jetzt
ebenfalls dann dort zusammen mit
behandelt wissen möchte
fährt dem also behandlung des antrags 6
13 6 ebenfalls zusammen mit den gerade
mit mit den amt diesen gerade
verschobenen anträgen zur kernkraft
wer das gemeinsam behandeln möchte bitte
ich jetzt um die blaue stimmkarte
gegenstimmen
das ist noch ein antrag da geht es um
die energiesicherheit stadt energiewende
das ist der titel dieses antrags der
noch spezifiziert wie die
energiesicherheit in den kommenden
jahren und monat zum thema auf windkraft
gesichert werden kann
also die landrats frage abstimmungsfrage
lautet
behandlung
13 6
das ist der sn 6
m6 zusammen mit den
t1 es n2 n3
kernkraft energiesicherheit und
kernkraft zusammen behandeln
dazu wird eine folie vorbereiten
auch das wird jetzt der elektronisch
abgestimmt dieser antrag ist quasi mehr
oder weniger mit thematisch eingebuchtet
in dieses thema kernkraft was ja jetzt
nach dem grußwort behandelt werden soll
und da geht es um die energiesicherheit
da geht es um die windräder geht es in
die erneuerbaren energien
und das soll zusammen mit dem großen
thema kernenergie eben auch danach
erstmal als sachthema heute behandelt
werden das heißt die partei wird sich
dann doch noch auf ein sachthema vor den
wahlen einigen können oder hat sich
geeinigt und das wird das thema
kernkraft seien alle anderen themen sind
nach hinten geschoben worden weil es ja
auch anträge gab das thema europa vor
den wahlen zu behandeln noch und das
thema waffenlieferungen für die ukraine
vorher waren zu wollen das ist ja
abgeschmettert weil ich ein ergebnis
einzublenden das ist dann knapp
abgelehnt
das heißt das thema energiesicherheit
was sich in einem antrag verbindet der
dann
behandelt werden sollte wird zu einem
späteren zeitpunkt aufgerufen ist nicht
weg vom tisch sondern wird nicht mit dem
thema kernkraft zusammengesetzt
ein augenblick bitte
das heißt es
so probiert man nochmal so den top 20
34 top
das ist der antrag zum
parteischädigenden verhaltens da das
stichwort
prüfung des vorliegens von parteichef
alten theo 11 mit es im 18 das zuvor
das vor
top-elf zu
behandeln top elf sind also vor sind die
personal wahlen ja vorstandswahl
der konkret die vorstandswahl über eine
bundes forschung das davor zu behandeln
wäre das werde diesen antrag davor sie
an träger vor behandeln möchte bitte ich
jetzt um die blaue stimmkarte
danke gegenstimmen mit der roten
stimmkarte
enthaltungen dann ist das deutlich
erkennbar abgelehnt
dann kommen wir jetzt zum antrag röcke
das ist der antrag dass der t6 die
strukturkommission vor dem top elf auch
das wieder die neuwahlen des
bundesvorstands behandelt werden mögen
wer also die strukturreform vor dem
bundesvorstand wahlen
behandelt wissen möchte bitte jetzt die
blaue stimmkarte
das ist spannend das ist ein antrag den
wie ein hingestellt hat es gerade in dem
es um diese neue programm kunde haltung
gehen soll die vor den wahlen behandelt
werden soll
immer dann wenn der versammlungsleiter
das unterbricht er sich über das
ergebnis der abstimmung nicht klar
aber wir sehen eine mehrheit das
ergebnis ist abgelehnt worden das heißt
führen ist mit seinem antrag nicht
durchgekommen dass er diese kommission
vor
stattfinden soll da sehe ich aber gerade
wieder ruft die verkündung des
ergebnisses sondern lässt elektronisch
abstimmen das vor top-elf
vorstandsneuwahlen ziehen möchte 1 jahr
2003 enthaltung bitte jetzt für eine
halbe minute
diese partei strukturreformen und diese
kommission die genauso heißt soll eben
wie gesagt ein leiter haben der dann
zehn lebens berufs und politik erfahrene
personen zusammenstellen soll die in
seiner tätigkeit im bundesvorstand
angedockt werden soll
das aber sie sehen das elektronische
abstimmungsergebnis sodass so muss
stattfinden wird dass dieses vor den
wahlen debattiert war hoffen dass über
das wochenende aufrechterhalten zu
können
so das waren die
änderungsanträge
da kommen zwei kommen noch im augenblick
ist hier sind störgeräusche das geht so
nicht
zwei stunden hat die partei ist dass es
über diese tagesordnung bis jetzt vom
debattiert war aber klar weil es
zahlreiche dann kommt jetzt anträge
zweier gab den top 13 4 mit den
sachanträgen sn 9 und 10 da geht es um
das zentrum automobil vor dem top elf
die
vorstandsneuwahlen zu ziehen als er neun
und zehn vor die vorstandsneuwahlen wird
dem seine zustimmung erteilen möchte
bitte ich jetzt um die blaue stimmkarte
sind anträge in den riester und der
kleinen gewerkschaft zentrum von der
unvereinbarkeit liste streichen und
entfernen soll das und zwei anträge
dieser stamm mehrheit dagegen erfassen
aber auch das wird nicht vor den wahlen
behandelt und wir kommen dann auch zum
antrag teichner
das sind
er ist die gemeinsame behandlung der
anträge 20 21 4 das sind die
internationalen geschichten abwendung
drohen internationale isolation t4 mit
sn 11 und
die der top 20 48 beitritt europapartei
für den seine zwischen rat einig dass
die beiden zusammen behandelt werden
dann bitte ich jetzt um die blaue
stimmkarte
das sind zwei anträge in denen es zum
einen unter dem stichwort abwendung
drohender
internationaler isolation der afd und
gleichzeitig dem beitritt zur
europapartei agent et und demokratie
gehen soll die bar sollen beide
zusammen behandelt werden darüber stimmt
der parteitag gerade auch das gerne
elektronisch haben
gemeinsam behandelt werden
1 jahr
haben sie 21 4 nur die beiden dass diese
beiden die
europapartei geschichte behandeln jetzt
abstimmen bitte 30 sekunden zeit
kleiner seitenhieb an die disziplin
glaube ich des parteitages wenn er sagt
das ist eine mauer beteiligung die
aufforderung auch weiterhin bei den
änderungsanträgen über die tagesordnung
bei der sache zu bleiben
das kennt man von ihm von früheren
parteitagen bereits an entsprechender
stelle
fünf sekunden haben sie noch zeit
bitte ich ein ergebnis einzublenden
so dass es dann doch jetzt deutlicher
als das eben sich ursprünglich andeutete
dann ist der antrag angenommen dann
werden diese beiden themenkomplexe in
einem behandelt das ist das ergebnis
dieser abstimmung
damit haben wir die änderungsanträge zum
verfahrens antrag
abgearbeitet angenommen wurde
in der reihenfolge wie es abgestimmt
haben nichtbefassung theo 7
auftrittsverbot kalbitz
dann antrag hilfe kernkraft nach vorne
ziehen tam trucks komplex dann
also theo 5
setzen das war
die
untersuchungskommission für die
arbeitsgemeinschaft verfassungsschutz in
der afg der antrag teichner 20 21 4
gemeinsam zu behandeln alle anderen
änderungsanträge wurden
abgelehnt
mit diesen änderungen die dann den
verfahrens antrag abgeändert haben gehen
wir in die schlussabstimmung über den
verfahrens antrag wenn sie den derartig
danach wird auf die tagesordnung noch
final beschlossen werden aber erst mal
der verfahrens antrag
wer den verfahrens antrag in der so
abgeänderten form seine zustimmung
erteilen möchte bitte ich jetzt um die
blaue stimmkarte
somit den genannten änderungen in den
vergangenen zwei stunden versuch der
parteitag sich jetzt eine struktur zu
geben und das was der bundesvorstand als
gerüst angeboten hat dann dann auch
abzustimmen lage bis angenommen wurden
dann gibt es zumindest noch einen ersten
rahmen für die tagesordnung in der auf
jeden fall das thema bis auf die
kernenergie in der thematik in einem
thematischen politischen inhalte nicht
vor den wahlen der
handelsbanken und an die opfer zu
erinnern
wir haben vor zwei jahren im stuttgarter
landtag anlässlich dieses tages der an
einem plan auf einen bildungs tag fiel
eine gedenk minute eingefordert sie
wurde abgelehnt deshalb stelle ich heute
den antrag auf erweiterung der
tagesordnung um diese einige denkt
minute um diesen tag zu würdigen
siebzehnter juni
ddr aufstand der dann lerne kann ich
dazu auch wieder geschlagen wurde wollte
einleiten aber ich stelle mir die paar
minuten sollten wir uns neben vielen
dank vielen dank
[Applaus]
so erwerben da zwei möglichkeiten und
die wir damit umgehen können es wäre zum
einen in der tat möglich hier die
tagesordnung entsprechend zu erweitern
zwei drittel mehrheit die wir dafür
bräuchten darunter können keine
beschlüsse gefasst werden das ist aber
naturgemäß hier auch gar nicht notwendig
die zweite möglichkeit wäre dass wir
natürlich auch ad hoc hier einfach eine
zum verfahren sogar ein
geschäftsordnungsantrag aber zum
verfahren dort sagen wir unterbrechen an
dieser stelle und nehmen uns die zeit
einfach jetzt das stelle ich ihnen an
heim wie sie dass wir um sie das haben
möchten dann
das zweitere entnehme ich dem wenn sie
einmal guten daumen hoch geben mögen
frau baum
das heißt der parteitag entscheidet sich
gerade wie in welcher form er dem
aufstand vom 17 juni 1953 in der ddr
gedenken will
ob es in einer gedenk minute sofort ist
oder an einem späteren zeitpunkt
die idee aber ich bitte doch darum dass
wir jetzt keine einleitenden worten hier
dazu führen sondern bitte nur die
schweigeminute durchführen
würde dass ich würde das auch
unterstützen dass wir eben wirklich nur
die schweigeminute machen und es ist
angebracht und das angemessene und ich
danke christina genfer antrag gestellt
hat danke
das war auch nur ein angebot nicht teil
des antrages
dann
müssen wir das glaube ich als hat
deutsche partei hier nicht
abstimmen ich habe keine gegenrede
gehört dann bitte ich sie sich zu
erheben
so jetzt erhebt sich der parteitag auf
antrag eines mitglieds zum gedenken an
den 17 juni 1953 dem ddr aufstand von
demonstranten und der politisch von der
sowjetunion niedergeschlagen wurde und
zwar gewaltsam
vielen dank viele von uns erinnern sich
vielleicht in der bundesrepublik
deutschland war dies bis zum ein- bis
zur deutschen einheit sich ebenfalls ein
gedenktag
juni 1953
vielen dank
so verkehren dann zurück in die
im vergleich in historische vergleiche
dann profanen tiefen des parteitags
alltagsgeschäft ist
ich sehe keine weiteren anträge zur
tagesordnung und bekommen dann zur
schlussabstimmung über die tagesordnung
entsprechend dem verfahrens antrag wie
eben
beschlossen
wir
haben
dann darüber noch einmal in der
schlussabstimmung durchzuführen wenn sie
die tagesordnung in der form wie wir sie
gerade ausführlich besprochen haben mit
dem verfahrens antrag bitte
ok dass das es wird gebeten darum dass
das angezeigt wird das dauert eine
sekunde weil das erst noch
umgemodelt umgebaut wird dort gerade das
überprüfen wir dann hier einmal kurz
das heißt dies
mit sicherheit jetzt auch noch
elektronisch damit da
gegebenenfalls knappe mehrheiten
eindeutig
sich abzeichnen und eindeutig aufgezeigt
werden mit sicherheit auch elektronisch
abgestimmt die formulierung wird jetzt
wahrscheinlich nochmal überprüft und
dann auf dem screen der allen
delegierten jahr
zugänglich ist zu sehen sein um dann
elektronisch final über den über die
tagesordnung abzustimmen damit ist
sozusagen der erste wäre der erste
kernpunkt der kfd in der parteitagsregie
abgearbeitet sie haben sich einen gerüst
gegeben und einen rahmen in dem sie
weiterarbeiten können und dieser wird
auf jeden fall so sein dass wir ein
sachthema hören bevor es zu den wahlen
kommt nämlich die frage wie halten es
die afg mit dem thema kernenergie
und dann wird es zu den satzungsfragen
gehen um die frage mit wieviel
bundessprecher will die partei
von diesem parteitag
in die wahlkreise und in die länder und
in den bundestag wieder zurück kinder
gibt es bundessatzung anträge die
jeweils immer eine zwei drittel mehrheit
brauchen um überhaupt angenommen zu
werden nicht zu vergessen wir haben 500
delegierte oder 4 199 delegierte im saal
da müssen wir dann mal schnell
ausrechnen wieviel delegierten dass
kollegen muss
noch nehmen das tun wir
und das möge sich dann schon einmal
bereit halten gleich die mandats
kommission für einen bericht
da geht es dann darum ob die mandate
alle ordentlich aufgelistet sind ob sie
juristisch haltbar sind ob da keine
unregelmäßigkeiten oder sonstigen fragen
aufgetaucht sind
und dann wird es in die weitere
tagesordnung gehen wir haben jetzt mal
durchgerechnet hier am set unter rechnen
damit dass mit den bundes
satzungsänderungen es debatten es gegen
frühen abend oder früher abend ist ja
immer relativ aber ich würde mal sagen
so gegen 16.17 uhr zu den ersten wahlen
über die dann festgelegte anzahl der
bundessprecher kommen wird
nach reichen möchte ich ihnen bei den
änderungsanträgen
solange da noch nach formulierungen und
nach dem elektronischen verfahren
gesucht wird dass das thema andreas
kalbitz hier auf dem parteitag nicht
behandelt wird es gab ja einen antrag
der
forderte dass
der parteiaustritt von andreas kalbitz
nicht rückgängig gemacht wird aber dass
er auf afd veranstaltungen reden darf
das war ein antrag der wurde eingebracht
und sollte auch hier behandelt werden
doch die partei hatte dann im zuge ihrer
änderungsverfahren beschlossen diesen
antrag überhaupt nicht mehr zu behandeln
das kam vom landesvorstand brandenburg
wir haben dann auch weil dieser antrag
nicht behandelt wurde auch keine
begründung mehr gegeben warum er
sozusagen auf die tagesordnung gekommen
ist aber das thema andreas kalbitz ist
jetzt hier erstmal kein thema mehr das
wollte ich ihnen bei der geschichte noch
nachreichen und ansonsten wird das so
angenommen dass jetzt verabschiedet
wurde mit dem gerüst dass sich die
partei jetzt hier auf diesem parteitag
gegeben hat
ich habe neulich habe ich daheim
das dauert insofern ein bisschen als
dass diese änderungsanträge die jetzt
dieses gerüst noch ein bisschen
korrigiert haben noch formuliert werden
müssen wahrscheinlich auf dem screen für
alle sichtbar
thematisiert und auch schriftlich
fixiert werden müssen und das dauert
halt ein wenig
er denkt
ja
die stille
gibt mir die gelegenheit
zu alexander keller nein ich höre gerade
kopfschüttel noch nicht nein aber gibt
mir die gelegenheit vielleicht noch mal
über die liste oder über das team
zukunft zu reden das kino propeller in
seiner rede heute vor mit einer
eröffnungsrede vorgestellt hat er hat ja
von diesem team zukunft geredet gestern
abend bei dem presse empfang den er für
die presse gegeben hat also für uns
medienvertreter hat er in dem
hintergrundgespräch davon geredet dass
er diese liste mit allen
landesvorständen und mit etlichen
personen die in der afd sozusagen mehr
oder weniger persönlichkeiten sind und
auch macht und einfluss haben
abgesprochen hat
wenn man sich die liste anguckt sind da
einige mitglieder des deutschen
bundestages dabei wie zum beispiel herr
brandner frau bei
gottschalk die neue
bundestagsabgeordnete gerrit fey oder
auch marc jungen der als chefideologe
der afd gehandelt wird bei vielen
experten und auch so
tituliert wird auch martin reichert ist
dabei
bundestagsabgeordnete und gleichzeitig
landesvorsitzende von sachsen anhalt und
die anderen teilnehmer sind etwas
weniger bekannt mit dieser liste ich
bemerke aber als weibliche person dass
die teilnahme der frauen auf dieser
liste
ja doch
unterrepräsentiert ist ich entdecke
bisher nur zwei frauen nämlich
die muss er dann nicht auch block
abstimmen das gibt es gar nicht sondern
da muss er für jedes amt kämpfen wenn er
dieses team was er gerne hätte im
einzelnen in den wahlen durchsetzen
möchte und da wird es mit sicherheit
etliche gegenkandidaten geben wie man
hört ist beatrix von storch noch
unsicher ob sie kandidieren will
weiterhin vor dem bundesvorstand oder
auch nicht andere personen zusammen
gehört joachim kurs hört auf wird sich
nicht mehr zur wahl stellen wir hörten
auch dass joana portal heute morgen im
interview mit alexander kähler sich
zurücklehnt und sich auf ihre arbeit in
der fraktion im bundestag in berlin für
die afg konzentriert und auch nicht mehr
kandidieren wird
neue namen werden genannt vielleicht
wird es auch den einen oder anderen
überraschungskandidaten noch geben das
werden wir weiteren verlaufe des tages
sehen aber soweit erstmals zur liste
oder zu dem team zukunft das air kino
gruppe heute auch in seiner rede so
formuliert hat so ich denke mal dass wir
jetzt langsam zum schluss kommen mit der
formulierung mit der neufassung der
tagesordnung die dann für alle weiteren
termine und für alle weiteren debatten
den takt vorgibt
bitte haben
noch sind die delegierten in gesprächen
in kleinen gruppen zusammen zu sehen die
sich noch nicht final wieder darauf
konzentrieren
den parteitag weiter laufen zu lassen
und
das hat aber glaube ich die längste zeit
gedauert weil es mit sicherheit jetzt
schon bewegung gibt im tagungs präsidium
da werden schon die ersten neuen
tagesordnungen in papierform
durchgereicht und nochmal kontrolliert
und in soweit denke ich mal dass es mit
sicherheit weiter gehen wir deshalb denn
es ergibt sich noch irgendein problem
was wir bisher von unserer position am
set wir sind ungefähr
luftlinie würde ich mal sagen 15 meter
20 meter entfernt von der bühne so sehen
können was ich
nicht sicher sagen lässt ob es so ist
oder nicht
so meine damen und herren ist wird dann
jetzt eingeblendet
die durch den verfahrens antrag
abgeänderte
tage forderung die gleiche noch
abgestimmt werden muss
das kommt in kürze auf den bildschirm
bitte nehmen sie ihre plätze ein lassen
sie die ruhe einkehren
ja
so
in rot sehen sie dort änderungen top
acht ist dann neu die resolutionen dann
bitte etwas runter scrollen
[Musik]
da ist alles unverändert und dann kommt
der erste teil der antragsbearbeitung
das sind
einmal
[Musik]
ganz ruhig meine damen und herren
das gewünscht lief die frage die
gestellt ist ob es möglich ist dass der
text zu kleines sie wissen wie ich
aussehe ob nicht ausgeblendet werden
kann der text groß eingeblendet werden
kann
parteitag live mit allen immobilien der
hürden der unvorbereiteten wendungen
es gibt wohl offensichtlich doch ein
paar schwierigkeiten diese änderungen in
das gerüst mit einzupflegen aber daher
flac jetzt einen etwas entspannteren
gesichtsausdruck hat gehe ich mal davon
aus dass das keine größeren
schwierigkeiten mehr nacht gemacht wird
und da wird schon groß gezogen dass es
gleich alles gut läuft und für jedermann
gut erkennbar ist
fest steht noch mal zur erinnerung zu
rufen dass das thema kernenergie als
eines der sachthemen es dann doch
geschafft hat vor den wahlen behandelt
zu werden und diskutiert zu werden
so und jetzt das ganze noch mal von
vorne bitte einmal nach oben scrollen
können das jetzt ich weiß ja nicht um
die ecke gucken kann hinten können sie
jetzt alle haben sie alle die der
tagesordnung so weit dass sie sie sehen
können
nein
technik kommt und guckt
ich verließ das sonst auch gleich gar
kein problem
[Musik]
das muss natürlich gewehr ist
gewährleistet sein dass alle diesen
neuen text social wir sehen ob auch
verstehen und lesen überein dass man es
irgendwie lesen kann
[Musik]
ja wir fangen jetzt noch mal von vorne
an wird gleich hoch ist aber solange die
parteitagsdelegierten eben sich noch mit
der neufassung der tagesordnung befassen
gebe ich jetzt noch mal ans set zu
alexander kähler ja danke doris ja der
parteitag in riesa dessen nähe ja die
elbe relativ zäh und langsam vorbei
fließt der hat diese geschwindigkeit im
moment auch angenommen das sind
grundsätzliche fragen zeigen auch dass
in der partei gerungen wird um inhalte
wie auch um zukünftige ausrichtung bei
uns ist immer noch professor wolfgang
schröder uni kassel und
wissenschaftszentrum berlin schöner wenn
man das jetzt zieht was hier gerade
passiert ja die partei
ringt er sehen versuchte zu überlegen
wie sie diesen parteitag nach außen hin
auch besonders gut über die bühne klicks
haben selbst schon mal gesagt ist die
partei der nichtwähler die partei des
zorns wie fließt das jetzt gerade alles
zusammen was wir hier erlebt haben und
was ja zu man ja auch durchaus
sitzfleisch oder ein gutes standing
braucht und dem zu folgen tja das was
wir hier beim parteitag erleben ist
vermutlich bildhaft metaphorisch für die
schwierigkeiten die die afg insgesamt
hat also es gibt keine idee eines
befreiungsschlages es gibt keinen
erlöser von außen sondern die partei
kann sich nur selbst erlösen und das ist
ein sehr hartes ringen wie wir hier
sehen können das fängt schon bei den
tagesordnungspunkten an wir haben eine
wilde komposition zwischen dem suchen
nach einem angemessen ich sage jetzt mal
in anführungsstrichen führer wir haben
das ringen nach der alleinstellung der
programmatik die fliegt und wir haben
das ringen darum wie stellt man eine
effiziente partei aus die gut
funktioniert die mobilisierungsfähigkeit
und damit eben auch eine verbindung
herstellt zwischen den parlamenten und
der straße blockiert sich die partei da
im moment etwas selbst die partei hat
sich stark verändert in den letzten zwei
drei jahren wir sind ja eine zeit lang
davon ausgegangen dass es so eine etwa
gleichwertigkeit des schreckens zwischen
den beiden flügeln gibt dem
programmatisch pragmatischen flügel und
dem programmatisch radikalen flügel die
entwicklung der letzten jahre ist doch
etwas stärker in richtung der radikalen
gegangen mit der möglichen konsequenz
dass doch erhebliche teile des
sogenannten gemäßigten flügels den
rückzug antreten und das verändert diese
partei grundsätzlich und wie das eben
bei parteien ist die müssen sich in
regelmäßigen abständen auf den prüfstand
stellen insofern sind parteitage für sie
außerordentlich wichtig weil da fliesst
die öffentlichkeit und die interne
befindlichkeit zusammen und das
versuchen sie hier zu machen indem sie
die frage der programmatik der
personalität und der strukturreform
parallel diskutieren und alles hängt
natürlich immer mit personal zusammen
weil man kann die tollste strukturreform
machen wenn dafür kein personal zur
verfügung steht das personal wiederum
keine idee hat wie sie diese partei
angemessen im wettbewerb platzieren kann
dann nützt auch die beste parteireform
nichts immer wenn er ans rednerpult geht
dann richten sich praktisch reflexartig
kameras und fotoapparate und handys auf
böcke vor ungefähr einer stunde hier zum
ersten mal aufgetreten parteitag es ging
um die um den den antrag die diskussion
über die parteistruktur
kommission oder partie eine partei
strukturreform einleiten soll unter
seinem vorsitz vor die personalwahl also
zum bundesvorstand vorzuziehen über die
hintergründe dieses dieses tausches und
dieses trainings nicht reden sondern die
frage
parteistruktur form professionalisierung
eine
verstärkte oder eine sinnvolle form der
außendarstellung aber auch der
inhaltlichen arbeit wo er die defizite
der asd muss vielleicht noch mal auf
röcke eingehen weil das finde ich
vollkommen richtig dass das erwähnen
weil das ist der einzigste höhepunkt den
wir bisher hatten dass alle augen und
ohren auf röcke gerichtet waren und dass
auch ein stück zu recht weil die
delegierten suche nach sinn die suche
nach einer identität und nachlassende
wir müssen das oder brechen und gehen
ganz kurz vorne zum rednerpult
er ehrenvorsitzender dr alexander
gauland sehr geehrte medienvertreter
liebe parteifreunde liebe gäste
nach diesem marathon der abstimmung der
tagesordnung erkläre ich mich bereit das
grußwort was eigentlich für zweieinhalb
stunden geplant war jetzt auf zwei
stunden beschränken
viele parteifreunde es ist mir eine
große ehre dass unser landesverband die
afg sachsen heute und hier
diesen parteitag in der sport- und stahl
stadt riesa veranstalten kann es ist
eine besondere ehre dass dieser
parteitag der hoffentlich ein
richtungsweisender parteitag werden wird
in unserem schönen freistaat sachsen
stattfindet der beginn
der beginn unseres parteitag ist der
heutige freitag fällt auf ein
historisches datum den 17 juni 1953
ein datum das in deutschland und
besonders in den neuen bundesländern
unser modernes verständnis vom wert der
freiheit und unsere ablehnung von
willkürherrschaft geprägt hat heute vor
69 jahren auf fast ein volksaufstand
über eineinhalb millionen menschen ein
volksaufstand gegen die diktatur der
sozialistischen einheitspartei
ein volksaufstand für die
wiedervereinigung und für die freiheit
dieser aufstand
[Applaus]
dieser abstand wurde blutig
niedergeschlagen einigkeit und recht und
freiheit blieben für lange zeit
unerreicht der sed-staat propagandist
karl-eduard von schnitzler im volksmund
auch sou de lede genannt so in dem
aufbegehren der menschen einen zitat von
bezahlten provokateuren vom gekauften
abschaum der berliner west berliner
unterwelt versuchten anschlag auf die
freiheit einen anschlag auf die
arbeitsplätze auf die familien unserer
werktätigen zitat ende
und wenn wir heute hören wie amtierende
politiker demonstranten beschimpften die
für den erhalt ihrer grundrechte auf die
straßen gehen als querdenker als
gefährder als leugner als
rechtsextremisten oder staatsfeinde dann
hören wir darin den sound der arroganz
der macht dann hören wir darin das echo
des 17 juni
[Applaus]
und mit der erfahrung von 44 jahren ddr
diktatur antworten wie heute darauf nie
wieder parteienherrschaft nie wieder
sozialismus
liebe parteifreunde liebe gäste während
1953 im osten
diktatorisch die arbeitsform erhöht
wurde stiegen im freien westen die löhne
und es wuchs der wohlstand
während die freie marktwirtschaft den
westen deutschlands zur stärksten
wirtschaftskraft in europa wachsen ließ
quälte sich der sozialismus
planwirtschaftlich bis zu seinem
letztendlichen zusammenbruch 1989
heute ist das anders heute trifft uns
der wirtschaftliche niedergang
deutschlands in ost und west
gleichermaßen
mit den grünen öko kommunisten und ihrer
ideologie von gesellschaftsgestaltung
und welten rettung die von allen anderen
altparteien nachgeahmt wird feiern
planwirtschaft bevormundung und
unfreiheit nun fröhliche urständ zum
schaden von uns allen in ost und west
heute sitzen wir im selben boot die
galoppierenden energiepreise treffen die
menschen in dortmund und münchen ebenso
hart wie in erfurt oder in schwerin die
von der ezb und den regierungen
verursachte inflation entwertet die
aussprache sind rentner in freiburg und
kassel genauso wie die der rentner in
halle oder cottbus
während hunderttausende berufstätige
hochqualifizierte produktive menschen
deutschland den rücken kehren belasten
immer mehr größtenteils unqualifizierte
illegale migranten unsere sozialsysteme
und unsere innere sicherheit in kiel in
rostock in bochum in leipzig
viele parteifreunde diebe gäste dieses
land hat besseres verdient unsere
menschen haben besseres verdient da aber
alle anderen politischen kräfte in
deutschland nicht gewillt sind die
wachsenden probleme auch noch an zu
erkennen geschweige denn etwas zu ihrer
lösung beizutragen braucht es eine
starke alternative es braucht eine
glaubwürdige alternative für den erhalt
der deutschen wirtschaft für den erhalt
der deutschen wissenschaft für den
erhalt unseres sozialstaates für unsere
deutsche kultur für unsere sprache für
unsere traditionen die alternative für
deutschland wird gebraucht mehr als
jemals zuvor
[Applaus]
liebe parteifreunde die letzten jahre
haben nicht nur unser land verändert
auch wir selbst unsere partei hat sich
verändert
nach der wilden euphorie der
anfangsjahre nach dem siegeszug durch
die parlamente sind wir nun in den mühen
der ebene angekommen
wir sind schon lange keine reine
protestpartei mehr wir sind opposition
und die menschen messen uns immer mehr
an unserer sacharbeit an unserer
tatsächlichen und praktizierte
bürgernähe an unseren medialen auftritt
erfolge müssen hart erarbeitet werden
und auch niederlagen und rückschläge
gehören für politischen arbeit das
wussten wir lernen
mit den mühen der ebene begannen auch
die parteiinternen diskussionen darüber
was die
erfolgsversprechendsten themen unserer
aus unserem parteiprogramm sind darüber
was die besten stilmittel unserer
repräsentanten sind wer unsere besten
repräsentanten sind aus meiner sicht
sind alle diese fragen berechtigt
berechtigt diese fragen müssen
diskutiert werden und selbstverständlich
darf es dabei keine denkverbote geben
keine tabus und auch keinen amtsbonus
das resultat dieser diskussionen sollte
aber immer zum nutzen für die afg sein
und nicht zu ihrem schaden was nicht
passieren sollte ist dass der jedoch
nicht mehr klar das sind wir doch nicht
mehr klar ist wofür die afg eigentlich
steht das nicht mehr klar ist was ist
die mehrheitsmeinung der partei und was
ist eine minderheitsmeinung
was nicht passieren sollte und was
leider viel zu oft passiert ist dass
unser außenbild von zerstrittenheit von
persönlichen machtkämpfen und von sich
widersprechenden aussagen geprägt ist
ein solches außenbild richtet mehr
schaden an der afg an als es eine
unpopuläre politische forderung wie zum
beispiel das cannabis verbot anrichten
könnte ich wünsche mir von diesem
parteitag nicht nur die wahl eines neuen
bundesvorstandes der willens ist
gemeinsam und harmonisch zu arbeiten und
unsere partei vorbildlich zu führen als
vorbild für alle mitglieder und für alle
landes und kreisverbände was ich mir
ebenfalls von diesem parteitag wünsche
ist ein großer und bewusst geführter
schritt hin zur professionalisierung
unserer partei
ich wünsche mir eine lebendige
innerparteiliche streitkultur aber ein
geschlossenes auftreten nach außen
ich wünsche mir die erarbeitung einer
mittel- und langfristigen strategie zur
weiterentwicklung unserer partei ich
wünsche mir die evaluierung und
gegebenenfalls erneuerung unserer partei
institutionen und ich wünsche mir den
aufbau einer wirklich professionellen
medienarbeit und die schaffung neuer
eigener medien
viele dieser impulse finden sich in den
vorliegenden anträgen die wir den
nächsten tagen behandeln werden und
deshalb bin ich sehr optimistisch dass
uns dieser große schritt hin zu mehr
professionalität gemeinsam gelingen wird
ihre
parteifreunde mitunter wird die
verschiedenheit unserer mitglieder als
handicap bezeichnet der verschiedene
stil unserer protagonisten die
programmatische schwerpunktsetzung
liberal sozial konservativ
die verschiedenen beruflichen sozialen
oder auch politischen hintergründe
unserer mitglieder
einer unserer ehemaligen
bundesvorsitzenden dachte deshalb sogar
an die aufspaltung der afd ich halte das
für falsch diese programmatische und
menschliche vielfalt ist unser reichtum
es ist unsere ressource die es möglich
macht dass wir eine echte volkspartei
werden
von marie von ebner-eschenbach stammt
der satz wirklich gute freunde sind
menschen die sich ganz gut kennen und
trotzdem zu einnahmen behalten
lasst uns wirklich gute parteifreunde
seien gerade weil wir unsere
verschiedenheit unsere stärken unsere
schwächen und auch unsere macken kennen
was uns alle eint ist ein fantastisches
parteiprogramm die afg ist wissenschafts
freundlich die afd ist technologie
begeistert die afg ist
wirtschaftsfreundlich die ard will einen
schlanken staat und starke unabhängige
bürger die afg ist weltoffen einheitlich
und zukunft optimistisch
lasst uns deshalb einig professionell
und freundschaftlich für die zukunft
dieses landes kämpfen dann ist die afg
das beste was deutschland passieren kann
ich wünsche dem parteitag maximale
erfolge herzlich willkommen
vielen dank herr orban
wir freuen uns auch mal wieder hier im
river zu sein
[Applaus]
ausschnitt von ihren fans noch einmal
aufnehmen und ihnen ja der ferien
hingelegt hat
des vormittages da kommt jemand der die
sehnsucht der delegierten bedient nach
sinnsuche er stellt nicht irgendwas ins
zentrum sondern das große ideal der
freiheit der verbindet das ideal der
freiheit mit dem 17 juni was bisher hier
niemand gemacht hat und damit auch
gleichsam so etwas wie eine partei
identität der afg nämlich wir hier unten
das volk gegen die da oben dann geht er
weiter und sagt also normalerweise sind
die großen parteien die altparteien wie
er sagt immer geneigt zu sagen erst das
land dann die partei und da die person
und bei ihm weiß man ja die person steht
im zentrum alle sind auf ihn fixiert und
er sagt nein wir sind die eigentlichen
realisieren dieses anspruches land
partei und person deshalb haben wir das
recht hier stärker gehört zu werden und
die eigentlich moderne partei zu sein
und da gab es großen großem beifall er
hat durchaus eine charismatische art für
seine anhängerschaft hier ist in der
lage den raum zu strukturieren und er
ist in der lage
zuspruch und beifall zu bekommen wie
kein anderer und das lässt natürlich
auch erwartungen aufkommen für den
weiteren parteitag hier und das ganze
hat immer ein bisschen auch eine
dämonische komponente bei ihm weil er
dann doch stärker als führer spricht und
damit das auch realisiert und anspricht
was an unheiligen allianzen und
geschichten in diesem land bereits mit
der parteiführung verbunden worden da
ist wenig von kooperation sondern sehr
stark zentriert sehr stark in macht
politischen dimensionen denkt und vor
allen dingen er ist der sinn dieser
partei und damit ist soll in der tat
zumindestens was diese kategorie an geht
augenblicklich
alleinstehend das heißt wir werden mit
ziemlichen einfluss noch ausüben auf den
parteitag auf die personalentscheidungen
auch auf sachentscheidungen
wahrscheinlich auch noch eine ganz
wichtige rolle spielen bis dahin
wolfgang schröder wir werden nach der
weiter hinten liebe zuschauer jetzt geht
es weiter mit den debatten mit den
anträgen der diskussion nach dem
parteitag doris müller vielen dank
alexander keller thema sachdebatte und
sachthemen in der tat sind wir jetzt da
an dem punkt angelangt an dem die
parteien über das thema kernkraft
diskutieren über den bau neuer
atomkraftwerke in deutschland einer
resolution und über das thema energie
schlichtweg
das ist jetzt das thema nach dem
grußwort des landesverbandes verbandes
und der antrag wird jetzt gegründet
ich würde anfangen
und dann erst die seite laufen lassen
die redezeit für diese beiträgt beiträge
wird auf 200 begrenzt diese freunde hat
sie ein bisschen gelichtet hier der sal
aber es sind wichtige dinge
die nutzung von kernkraft
weiterentwicklung der forschung
kernkraft usw ist von anfang an teil des
grundsatzprogramms wir haben im
bundestag seit vier jahren mehrere
anträge gestellt zum weiterbetrieb zur
erforschung und so weiter und so fort es
wurde alles wegen grenzenlose weisheit
durch die altparteien also abgelehnt
in den landesparlamenten wurde auch
wurden auch anträge gestellt die
landtagsfraktion in sachsen hat sogar
eine extra kampagne gefahren kernkraft
ja bitte wir haben
eine desolate
energieversorgung in der zwischenzeit
durch die grünen öko kommunisten wie es
mein vorgänger gerade sagte wir brauchen
kernenergie wir brauchen energie
energie
ständig zur verfügung stehende und
kostengünstige energie ist der schlüssel
zu allem ist der schlüssel zu wohlstand
ist der schlüssel für wirtschaftliche
entwicklung und deswegen brauchen wir
kernenergie das ausland macht es uns vor
bisher waren es vor allem die führenden
industrienationen die kernkraft genutzt
haben in der zwischenzeit sind es fast
zwei drittel der erde die also auf
kernkraft setzen wir so hat es die
ehemalige kanzlerin ja gesagt wir machen
uns lächerlich wenn wir also
die stromversorgung aus verschiedenen
energieträgern abschalten und uns dann
aus dem ausland von denselben
energieträgern als strom importieren wir
machen uns nicht nur abhängig von
energierohstoffen in der zukunft sondern
eben auch von stromimporten und das ist
einer industrienationen unwürdig und
deswegen haben wir also diesen diese
resolution eingebracht und ich bin sehr
froh dass die alle die meisten zumindest
also mehrheitlich dafür gestimmt haben
das ist also jetzt vor den wahlen vor
den vorstandswahlen an exponierter
stelle beschlossen wird sie alle haben
den antrag bekommen es wurden
verschiedene änderungen vorgenommen so
wurde also einer der redner in der
tagesordnung steht watte hat es
richtigerweise erkannt haben wir also
grundsätzlich atomkraftwerke durch
kernkraftwerke ist auch schon leider zum
schluss wichtigere begriff wir haben
jedes mal wenn erneuerbare energien in
der resolution erscheint sogenannte
erneuerbare energien erneuerbare
energien gibt es nicht man kann energie
nicht erneuern man kann energie immer
nur umwandeln und er ist fachlich
richtig es sachlich richtig und ich
bitte um zustimmung zu dieser reduktion
vielen dank
dann rufe ich jetzt auf den antrag sm-3
antragsteller ist der
bundesfachausschusses 10 wünscht ein
antragsteller aus dem bundesausschuss
zehners bord
ist jemand vom das ist ein
ersatz antrag oder ein weitergehender
antrag der den grundgedanken der
kernenergie ein bisschen rezensiert
ja also der antrag ist teilweise
hinfällig geworden dass wir zehn 2 die
verbesserungen von herrn hilse durchaus
in die richtige richtung gehen
allerdings ist da noch ein fachlicher
fehler drin und er ist ein relevanter
fachlicher fehler das geht darum dass
jetzt begründet wird dass es ein
endlager obsolet sei dass es fachlich
falsch ein endlager ist auf also ist in
ihr ist für 1000 jahre sichern nicht
natürlich bin ich in die millionen jahre
gehen wenn man die millionen aktive und
spalten würde aber so wie das das r
steht ist das nicht ist das falsch
einfach also müsste man das abändern und
auch die begründung da steht noch als
begründung drin dass durch die
energetische nutzung der reststoffe kein
endlager nötig ist
die nutzung der reststoffe erlaubt und
dass wir über
hunderttausende von jahren eine sichere
energieversorgung haben aber ein
endlager für 1000 jahre um die 1000
jahre brauchen wir halt noch ich würde
da gleich gerne weil das jetzt nicht
überrollt hat zeitlich kurz schriftlich
eine um formulierungsvorschlag einbringt
und vielleicht akzeptiert den ja auch
herr hilse und wir sind vollkommen einig
sonst gut dann nehmen wir das so zur
kenntnis und
ja da gibt es offensichtlich
einen kurzen disput über das korrigieren
oder das einfügen dessen was der
vorredner gerade auf dem parteitag
berichtet hat und dieses soll jetzt mit
in den antrag rein da ging es um die
frage soll es ein endlager geben ja oder
nein
gut dann bekommt er ist normal das boot
das formulieren
also es geht um den satz der los geht's
für den machen diese kraftwerkstypen
durch die nutzung des bisher
angefallenen hochenergie hoch
energetischen rest brennstoff ein
endlager obsolet da in den forderungen
beziehungsweise den einzelnen punkten
die weiter unten kommen dieses endlager
noch einmal
behandelt wird dort gibt es aber eine
andere formulierung und die würde ich
ihnen falls ihr das nicht lesen können
vortragen
moderne kenne er kernenergie braucht so
zeigen dass mehrere wissenschaftliche
studien keine endlager in geologischen
zeiträumen für hoch radioaktive
reststoffe und so weiter und so fort
hier geht es darum dass wir also diesen
begriff benutzt haben geologischen
zeiträumen und geologische zeiträume für
geologen sind für gewöhnlich
hunderttausend jahre und demzufolge
würden wir dann glaube ich an blacks
auch genüge tun dort kann es raus hier
unten steht es noch mal drin mit dem
endlager wenn der herr blacks damit
einverstanden wäre dann müsste er mal
ein zeichen geben
so vielen dank gleichwohl brauchen wir
das jetzt schriftlich
und die zeit können wir nutzen um eine
debatte um die resolution insgesamt zu
führen ich öffne die aussprache zu den
beiden vorliegenden anträgen wird das
wort gewünscht
genau
so liegen wir denn weitere
änderungsanträge vor
ich schaue zur technik
also derzeit keine weiteren
wortmeldungen aus der mitte des
parteitages
zum thema kernenergie und ausbau von
neun
weiteren änderungsantrag von herrn
richard s m days unglücklicherweise auch
die nummer es in 2.1 trägt aber dann
bitte ich den antrag sn damit also dann
bitte ich als erstes mal eine richtige
antrags version zu geben
das ist halt in die formal debatte die
jung und eigentlich mal sagen dass alles
regelgerecht zu machen das wort zur
begründung gewinnt ständig hat bitte
andreas lickert mdl aus hessen und einer
von zwei landessprecherin und ich
spreche hier für den landesvorstand
hessen wer über die zukunft der
deutschen energiepolitik spricht darf
zum kohleausstieg nicht schweigen und
insofern ist
leider unser antrag nicht zu sehen aber
der kern des antrages ist diese
kohleausstieg muss gestoppt werden und
das möchte ich kurz begründen
aus gutem grund glaubt die afd nicht
daran dass der klimawandel
menschengemacht ist und die menschen
gemachten co2 emissionen der kauf solle
auslöser des klimawandels sind aber
selbst wenn man quasi als klima apostel
diesem glauben anhängt muss man trotzdem
kohleausstieg entgegentreten denn
richtig ist die direkten emissionen bei
der verfeuerung von kohle zur
stromerzeugung sind geringer als bei
erdgas aber die indirekten emissionen
also alles das was bei der förderung
beim transport bei der lagerung von
erdgas anfällt ist deutlich höher als
bei kohle der co2 vorteil schrumpft
bereits deutlich und vollends
klimapolitisch sinnlos wird der
kohleausstieg durch die unvermeidlichen
mccarten methan leckagen methan ist der
hauptbestandteil von erdgas insgesamt
führt das dazu dass das viel besungene
katarische flüssiggas einen deutlich
höheren co2 fußabdruck hat als die
lausitzer braunkohle und diese dieser
zusammenhang illustriert einfach nur die
ideologische verblendung der altparteien
in diesem komplex dem müssen wir
entgegentreten ich bitte daher diesen
einen artikel zum kohleausstieg dem sgs2
der sachsen hinzuzufügen und bedanke
mich für diese wichtige initiative soll
man einmal vielen
vielen dank herr richard
es weitere wortmeldungen in dieser
debatte
ja am roten saal mikrofon bitteschön
ja da zwei minuten redezeit carsten
hilfe ist nicht möglich gemacht haben
den kernenergie antrag auch aus
umweltpolitischer sicht zu begründen tue
ich das als umweltpolitischer sprecher
unserer bundestagsfraktion gerne und
möchte noch mal deutlich machen dass
kernenergie nicht nur eine
energiewirtschaftliche lösung ist
sondern auch eine umweltpolitische denn
aus gründen der umweltpolitik wird ja
unsere landschaft zurzeit verschandelt
mit windkraftanlagen um mit photovoltaik
und das hat einen enorm hohen
flächenverbrauch und ist ein massiver
eingriff in unsere umwelt und vor allem
ein massiver eingriff in den artenschutz
und als konservative partei haben wir
uns den erhalt der schöpfung als auch in
unserer stammbuch geschrieben und
deswegen ist es klar und deutlich zu
machen dass kernenergie einen viel
geringeren flächenverbrauch hat einen
viel geringeren flächenverbrauch hat und
dementsprechend eine alternative
darstellt zu den
flächenverbrauchs erzeugungs energien
das muss man deutlich machen
gleichzeitig das ist mir aber auch
wichtig hier nochmal zum änderungsantrag
des bafa zu sprechen weil es ist korrekt
dass selbst mit technologien wie
transmutation und partitionierung immer
noch ein rest teilt übrig bleibt der
endlager werden muss also müssen wir
tatsächlich auch die endlagerung
zumindest thematisieren nur ist das eine
ganz andere größenordnung als jetzt und
ich plädiere auch wenn ich herrlich hat
argumentation gut verstehen kann trotz
sind da für uns hier nicht zum
kohleausstieg zu positionieren weil der
charme dieses antrags ist ja gewesen
dass wir hier mit einem
alleinstellungsmerkmal hat zur
kernenergie ein ganz klares und
deutliches bekenntnis in einem thema
setzen das medial gut aufgegriffen wird
und deswegen würde ich das lieber nicht
einfügen auch wenn das inhaltlich
korrekt ist danke
vielen dank wird weiter das wort
gewünscht
ich muss dazu sagen die mikrofone sind
von hier aus sehr schlecht zu erkennen
zeigen sie also auch bitte gerne auf
genau vielen dank dann machen wir weiter
am blauen mikrofon
nichts hören okay ich bin zwar nicht zu
sehen ich finde den änderungsantrag des
bfh wichtig weil der klarstellung macht
und die korrektur von dem herrn hilse
mit den geologischen zeiträumen ist für
die einfache bevölkerung einfach
überhaupt nicht verständlich und klar
genug was damit gemeint ist das heißt
wir sollten klarstellen natürlich
brauchen wenn endlager auch wenn wir
kernkraftwerke der vierten oder fünften
generation habe ich nicht kenne ich bin
ein energiepolitischer sprecher in nrw
also auch für energiepolitik zuständig
innovatoren kernkraftwerke zuständig und
habe bei rwe gearbeitet und natürlich
einblick bei den kernkraftwerken im
übrigen ist das reine ja wirklich eine
resolution ein bekenntnis was wir haben
weil die nächsten 20 jahre wird keiner
in deutschland geld in die hand nehmen
und kernkraftwerke bauen trotzdem
sollten wir das so stellen mit den
änderungen des bfs deswegen werbe ich
dafür den sn 3 entsprechend anzunehmen
um die änderung anzunehmen zum punkt von
dem er liefert wir haben ja den sn 6 der
sich generell mit energiesicherheit
stadt energiewende beschäftigt und da
wird natürlich auch in einen der punkte
top-5 gefordert dass wir unsere kohle
kraftwerke weiter betreiben wollen und
natürlich auch unsere
braunkohle-tagebau weiter betreiben
wollen wenn ihren fokus die kohle auch
herkommen um uns unabhängiger zu machen
und da haben wir eben entschieden dass
wir das nicht zusammen behandeln das
muss ich akzeptieren
das ist halt so aber sind zwei getrennte
bereiche und da sollten wir jetzt nicht
anfangen wieder ein teilbereich nämlich
den kohleausstieg wieder in kernenergie
bereich zu nehmen deshalb bin ich für
die reine lehre diesem fall das heißt es
n3 annehmen und dann mit den änderungen
entsprechend insgesamt den antrag
annehmen danke
gibt es weitere wortmeldungen ja am
roten saal mikrofon
vielen dank ich möchte mich auch dafür
aussprechen dass der änderungsantrag das
müsste möglichst dann ein stelldichein
gearbeitet wird und im übrigen dass wir
diesen antrag wirklich auf die
kernenergie beschränken job hier
herrscht eine ganz große einigkeit was
zur kohle gesagt wo ist teilweise
angreifbar das sollten wir nicht damit
vermischen auch wegen des schon
genannten alleinstellungsmerkmal so muss
eine klare politische aussage sein die
sich auf die kernkraft beschränkt vielen
dank
möchten sie noch sagen wünschen sie das
wort
sodann hat noch mal herr hase das wort
also ich hab das signal vom bfh 10
bekommen wenn wir das so umformulieren
dass wir also schreiben
das kein endlager in geologischen
zeiträumen benötigt wird würden sie auf
ihren änderungen nicht bestehen und es
gibt aber einen weiteren änderungsantrag
dem wir dann als zusätzlicher punkt bei
denen habe ich gesprochen mit christian
blacks können wir einfügen
[Musik]
müssen mal gucken an welcher stelle wird
das einfügen
alles klar also es wäre dann so dass der
das von herrn blacks wenn es denn dann
da ist
eingefügt werden kann und zwar
nach dem punkt 4
gibt
ok also ich würde jetzt herrn blacks
änderungsantrag den ich mir zu eigen
mache kurz vor lesen ist wäre dann quasi
der neue punkt 5 und alle anderen punkte
würden nach unten rutschen
die brut technologie erlaubt die
energetische verwendung bisher nicht
nutzbare rohstoffe die die
energieversorgung für hunderttausende
jahre sicherstellen würde
ruth technologie findest du noch was
anderes
moderne was sie sich ja ja ok alles klar
moderne kernenergie man muss wieder als
moderne kernenergie bezeichnen ok alles
klar
ist der auch schon eingeblendet
das würde ich dann bitten zu tun
so da geht es um die frage ob der
kohleausstieg gestoppt werden muss und
um die grundsatzfrage die gerade
diskutiert wurde das thema kohle in dem
in das thema kernkraft auch einfließen
soll
liebe vertagt worden ich hatte mich ja
eben schon bei der tagesordnung
diskussionen dafür ausgesprochen dass
wir klare botschaften senden und deshalb
würde ich auch dafür plädieren bei aller
wertschätzung für die arbeit von herrn
andreas lickert den ich sehr schätze in
diesem fall aber war der resolution
atomkraftausstieg auch genau bei diesem
thema zu bleiben das thema nicht zu
vermischen mit dem thema kohlekraft denn
das thema atomkraft hat ja den einen
vorteil des ort der grund aus dem
diverse altparteien es gerade übernehmen
dass es auch nach der logik des
mainstreams klimawandel eine
energiequelle ist die förderungswürdig
ist und die deshalb von diesem nicht
abgelehnt werden keiner ihrer eigenen
logik und das schlagen uns ein stück
weit aus der hand wenn wir das jetzt
vermischen das thema kommt ja auch noch
einmal separat deshalb meine dringende
bitte in der hinsicht beim
kernkraftausstieg zu bleiben sagen sie
gibt es weitere wortmeldungen ja am
roten sein mikrofon bitteschön
ja vielen dank liebe parteifreunde
ich möchte auch hier dafür werben den
antrag zur kernenergie nicht doch eine
hinzunahme von kohle die sehr wichtig
ist die gerade im jetzigen zeit der
energetischen knapper die ihren platz
hat aber dennoch in der kernkraft anfang
nicht hineingehört zu bleiben ich möchte
aber darauf hinweisen dass dieser antrag
dringend der änderungen des
änderungsantrages des bfa 10 bedarf viel
anders denn leider ist es so wir
brauchen am ende von tag 1 doch für
nicht nutzbare stoff ein endlager und
stoffe isotope wie cäsium 135 10 93
haben halbwertszeiten von eineinhalb bzw
2,3 millionen jahre wenn wir den weg in
der aufgezeigt ist können wir die menge
und das volumen der nuklearen rechte für
massiv reduzieren und wir müssen extrem
geringe mengen einlagern und nur in dem
vergleich heranzuziehen in deutschland
und der der schweren zweieinhalb
millionen tonnen toxischer und giftiger
stoffe wie quecksilber arsen dioxin et
cetera eingelagert ganz ohne
halbwertszeit und darüber redet niemand
das heißt wenn wir erschaffen modernen
methoden ein endlager das immer noch ein
sehr lange dauert aber so ein zusammen
dass wir nur wenige kubikmeter reden
dann haben wir schon einen gigantischen
erfolg erreicht aber wir dazu brauchen
wir die änderung des bv 10
änderungsantrag
es gibt einen antrag zur
geschäftsordnung am roten see mikrofon
bitteschön
hallo ich möchte den antrag stellen die
behandlung zu diesen beiden anträgen
diesem moment zu unterbrechen mit der
maßgabe dass vertreter der beiden
anträge also bfa und sachsen sich kurz
zusammensetzen und eine
konsensfähige version ausformulieren die
wir dann nach der behandlung der
satzungsänderungen mit großer mehrheit
und begeisterung hier beschließen werden
ich erlaube mal für einen hinweis
oder also bei mir gegen bei mir wurde
der eindruck erweckt als ob eine
einigung ja bereits gefunden sei also
bitte wollen sie die noch mal kurz vor
jahren
also es ist doch eine einigung erreicht
worden mit dem bfc will sagt doch jetzt
den einsatz entsprechend abgeändert dass
er von geologischen zeiträumen spricht
das ist vollkommen richtig dass ganze
die anderen sachen des kleinkram was
dann da gibt es noch an strahlenden
stoffen über bleibt letzten endes an
minen aquino iden also sie hatte nach
einigen stattgefunden die wir haben den
satz um formuliert oder herr hilse mit
mir jetzt zusammen und das würde jetzt
laut noch entsprechend moderne
kerntechnologie erlaubt die energetische
verwendung bisher nicht nutzbare
rohstoffe und dann die die
energieversorgung für hunderttausende
jahre sicherstellen würde punkt und
damit sind also bfa und jetzt per hilse
doch einig und ich bitte sie dann diesen
wertvollen antrag dem zuzustimmen herr
blacks bleiben sie noch kurz am mikrofon
dann hätte ich jetzt noch zwei fragen an
sie die erste frage ist ob dann jetzt
der antrag
sn 3ds hinfällig der wird von ihnen
zurückgezogen er ist hinfällig weil
keine einigung kam
also klar ist dass sie offensichtlich
nicht das thema kohle und kernkraft ein
teil meiner vermischen
und jetzt geht es noch um die frage wie
wird die formulierung um das thema
endlager definiert und wie gestaltet
sich da die politische forderung nach
einem solchen entweder aus oder auch
nicht das ist jetzt noch eine der fragen
die zum thema kernenergie und in der
debatte
final in irgendeiner art und weise
entschieden werden muss
so meine damen und herren dann muss ich
dann doch nur mal kurz etwas steuernd in
die debatte eingreifen denn mir ist
mitgeteilt worden dass der leiter des
bfa 10 der für diesen antrag sn 3
verantwortlich ist diesen antrag nach
wie vor vertreten möchte ich hatte ja
eingangs gefragt ob ein vertreter des
bfa 10 ihn begründet das hat dann herr
blacks übernommen von dem ich ausgehe
dass auch den bfa ziehen angehört
gleichwohl würde ich dann jetzt nochmal
dem leiter des bfa 10 zur begründung des
antrages sm-3 das wort erteilen er
müsste dann nur hineingelassen werden
als nicht delegierter und entsprechend
das wort zu ergreifen
ein moment
so zwei minuten sehr schön also zuerst
einmal vielen dank dass ich hier
sprechen darf väter wären es kennen wenn
kinder sagen trägt ein rosa t-shirt dann
trägst du das rosa 100 deswegen ist es
heute ja so da
der antrag des landesverbandes sachsen
ist großartig
denn und das ist auch mal ein signal an
die geschäftsführungen und vorstände von
enbw und areva und frahm atom und
siemens und ge die fdp ist die einzige
partei die sich seit vielen jahren
konsequent nicht nur für den
weiterbetrieb von kernenergie sondern
auch für die wiedererrichtung von neuen
kann energieanlagen einsetzt aber
der antrag krankte und krankt leider an
zwei themen und die bietet der bfh 10 zu
korrigieren und dann wollen wir den
antrag gern unterstützen das eine ist
wir möchten die formulierungen zum thema
co2 rausnehmen das ist nämlich der punkt
wo auf der zweiten seite des antrages
denn während die kernkraft durchaus co2
neutral ist fast ist es konsens in der
ard dass wir über co2 nicht reden weil
das für uns kein problem darstellt und
da müssen wir einfach konsistent beim
programm sein und der zweite punkt ist
dass sich formulierungen zum thema eines
endlagers finden ich möchte sie nicht
mit langen technischen ausführungen
belasten aber diese formulierungen sind
leider physikalisch und ich bin physiker
nicht haltbar und darum müssen die
entfernt werden und das wäre der punkt
punkt diese begründung findet sich auch
im antrags buch und ich möchte sie
bitten den antrag des lv sachsen zu
stützen aber ohne die formulierungen zum
endlager und ohne die formulierungen zum
co2 und das ist der antrag des bva 10
vielen dank vielen dank
dann bevor wir in der debatte fortfahren
würde ich nochmal in blacks ans mikrofon
und bitte noch mal den antrag von den
blacks einblenden
ja das ist jetzt feinarbeit denn der
delegierte der kein delegierter ist
sondern ein fachpolitiker aus dem
landesverband sachsen hat auf ein paar
sätze hingewiesen die haben ihn als
fachmann als physiker
regiert ebenso wenig hat das nur
aufgeschrieben damit man nicht im
luftleeren raum das boot ist deswegen
frage ich ja genau das heißt das hat er
hilfe etwas abgeändert jetzt aufgenommen
und erbitte ich dafür auch den antrag
von der nähe so in der abgeänderten form
zu unterstützen
also mir liegt keine abgeänderte antrags
fassung von erlöse vor mir liegt nur ihr
änderungsantrag vor
er hatte doch gesagt dass er das
übernimmt und hat noch eine abgeänderte
gut dann frage ich jetzt die technik
noch mal ob eine aktualisierte antrags
fassung vorliegt
es wurde bei uns keine aktualisierte
antrags fassung eingereicht den zufolge
bleibt es bei ihrem änderungsantrag herr
blacks sie haben das wort sie können
auch gerne replizieren also wir können
jetzt darüber abstimmen ob wir den satz
hinter den abgeänderten satz zur
endlagerung den er hilfe machen wollte
aber jetzt wohl irgendwie noch nicht
schriftlich vorliegen hat wir können
doch alles dreimal schriftlich
einreichen und dann verzerrt man sich
doch einfach sagen wo der satz hin soja
kommt direkt nach der
endlagerproblematik die herren hilfe
dann angesprochen hat herr hilfe zeigt
ihnen das jetzt mal und dann bitte
ersetzen dass es eben auch konsens
gewesen die brutto look wie ersetzen
durch moderne kerntechnologie und dann
haben wir das ganze durch
der hilfe zeigt dass gerade jetzt
im moment möchte ich möchte da
ja das ist jetzt sozusagen routinierte
parteitags dynamik da wird umsätze um
begrifflichkeiten und um inhalte in
präziser form der schritt eine
aktualisierte antragsphase und da geht
es jetzt darum ob das thema kernenergie
und vor allen dingen das thema endlager
in welcher form ist präzise mit
aufgenommen werden soll und
verabschiedet werden soll in der
endgültigen fassung
dann blenden wir jetzt gleich die
aktualisierte antrags fassung ein wir
haben das jetzt mein service mäßig
gemacht den antragstext von herrn blacks
1 zu pflegen ich weiß halt eben darauf
hin dass es schon sinnvoll wäre wenn von
anfang an korrekt formulierte anträge
gestellt werden
das dauert jetzt noch einen moment
sie haben einen geschäftsordnungsantrag
ich hatte bereits den
geschäftsordnungsantrag gestellt dass
wir die behandlung unterbrechen damit
genau das was jetzt hier öffentlich und
zeitraubend stattfindet die
entsprechenden fachleute kurz hinter
verschlossenen türen machen und uns dann
in schnellster zeit eine vollständige
version aus einem guss präsentiert und
dann können wir das beschließen
naja wurde leider nicht abgestimmt das
sollten wir jetzt tun einen moment
ja es muss ja formal alles seine
richtigkeit haben dass wir zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt übergehen diesen
tagesordnungspunkt in dem wir uns
befinden gleichwohl nicht schließen
dieser könnte dann durch einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag
zurückgeholt werden ist das in ihrem
sinne ja
ich hätte es als unterbrechung
bezeichnet aber ich denke dem sinne ist
also ja sie können den parteitag
unterbrechen sich aber ein
tagesordnungspunkt okay dann entweder
sich ihre formulierung die geschäfte des
parteitages müssen ja nämlich immer
weiter laufen ja verstehen sie deswegen
ja ist das okay dann wird die gegenrede
zu diesem antrag gewünscht
das kann ich nicht erkennen dann ist der
antrag so angenommen
so damit verschwindet jetzt die debatte
in der tat ein podium
halt stopp da gibt es dann doch noch
eine generelle
hennig siegen wittgenstein ich weiß
nicht ob das korrekte gegenrede jetzt
ist aber ich möchte bevor die beratung
dazu und die verbesserung losgeht
empfehlen dass die veränderung zu b die
finde ich auch gut und richtig ich würde
aber da oben drauf das co2 unbedingt
noch mit rein nehmen wir sind
richtigerweise schuldigen see herz dass
sie reden nichts zur sache wir sprechen
jetzt da gerade darüber ob wir in der
tagesordnung weiter voran freien war das
keine gegenrede also dann frage ich noch
mal ob es jetzt eine gegenrede dazu gibt
das wir in der tagesordnung fortfahren
formal höher ich
dann lasse ich darüber abstimmen wer
dafür ist dass wir in der tagesordnung
weiter fortfahren diesen
tagesordnungspunkt aber noch offen
lassen den bitte ich um das karten
zeichen
dankeschön wer ist dagegen
wer enthält sich dann ist dies mit
großer mehrheit beschlossen dann sind
wir vorerst
fahren wir vorerst hier nicht fort an
dieser stelle und dann kommen wir zum
nächsten tagesordnungspunkt
der da wäre lassen sie mich kurz auch
noch mal die tagesordnung finden
die frage der bundessprecher und damit
der satzungsänderungen der partei und
der bundesrat nach punkt 9 beratung und
beschlussfassung über änderungen an der
satzung und den ordnungen des
bundesverbandes mit bezug auf wahlen
insbesondere der amtszeit der richter
des bundes schiedsgerichtes unter diesem
tagesordnungspunkt
haben wir vier anträge zu behandeln das
ist zunächst einmal der antrag sg1 der
sich um mit der schiedsgerichtsordnung
befasst und dann würden wir in einer
gemeinsamen verbundenen debatte die
tages die anträge zur frage der struktur
der parteispitze behandeln also die
anträge t8 ps1 und ps2
ich darf ihn auch hier noch einmal
vorschlagen eine redezeit begrenzung von
zwei minuten für diesen
tagesordnungspunkt
einzuhalten gibt es hierzu eine
gegenrede
das kann ich nicht erkennen dann ist der
antrag so angenommen dann darf ich darum
bitten dass der antrag sg1 eingeblendet
wird
so bestandteil und inhalt dieses ersten
antrags in dem es um satzungsänderungen
in der partei geht bezieht sich auf die
am 2 das wort zurück schiedsrichter und
ersatz schiedsrichtern in der partei
der satzung ausschuss hat sich ja schon
verschiedentlich und auch schon an
dieser stelle dafür eingesetzt die
amtszeiten der schiedsrichter des
bundesschiedsgerichts zu synchronisieren
warum ist das wichtig
wir haben parteitage zu
unterschiedlichsten zeiten im jahr und
das führt zu recht absurden
situationen ganz konkret sind die
während die amtszeiten wenn sie nicht
jetzt verlängert gewesen wären weil
keine nachrücker mehr da waren von
schiedsrichtern die im jahr 2009 10
gewählt wurden zu ende da würden wir
dann im laufe dieses wochenendes also
heute idealerweise noch neue richter für
wählen in wenigen monaten bereits im
november wo aktuell kein neuer parteitag
geplant ist nach meinem kenntnisstand
würden die nächsten beiden richter
ausscheiden und dann würde die nächsten
amtszeiten auslaufen im april 23 einfach
zufälle je nachdem wann man gerade mal
ein parteitag im april oder im november
durchgeführt hat und ob dort
schiedsrichter gewählt wurden uns
schwebt also vor und fürbitten dringlich
um ihre unterstützung die amtszeiten zu
synchronisieren dass die immer auf das
kalenderjahr sich beziehen unabhängig
davon wann ein parteitag stattfindet wir
haben darüber hinaus dort eine
übergangsregelung eingeführt die auch
dazu führt dass man nicht alle
schiedsrichter jetzt aktuell auf einmal
wählen muss sondern ist tatsächlich
ungefähr die hälfte des schiedsgerichts
ist jetzt zu wählen sind und die anderen
dann im kommenden jahr ein parteitag hat
man im jahr und auf einem parteitag vier
oder fünf je nachdem in welchem jahr
mann ist richter zu wählen das ist gut
schaffbar gut ablesbar man hat dafür
einen gewissen turnus drin einen
gewissen rhythmus drin wir bitten um
zustimmung zu diesem antrag vielen dank
vielen dank
zu diesem antrag eröffne ich die
aussprache wird das wort gewünscht
das kann ich nicht erkennen dass jemand
das wort wünscht dann schließt sich die
aussprache und dann kommen wir zur
abstimmung über den antrag ist die
einzig weise darauf hin dass die
gerichtsordnung satzungs rang hat und
für die annahme dieses antrag ist eine
zwei-drittel-mehrheit erforderlich ist
wer dem antrag sg1 seine zustimmung
erteilen möchte den bitte ich um das
garten zeichen also jetzt noch mal zur
wiederholung die amtszeit von den
schiedsrichtern und den ersatz
schiedsrichtern drei bundes und landes
schiedsgerichten soll gleichzeitig
anfangen ohne am ersten januar jeweils
beginnen und auf zwei jahre
zementiert werden über die struktur
unserer parteispitze hierzu liegen drei
anträge vor t8 änderung anzahl möglicher
bundessprecher gs1 anzahl bundessprecher
senken auf ein oder zwei ps 2 anzahl
bundessprecher auf ein bis drei
festlegen die anträge wie ich sie gerade
vorgelesen habe sind gerade auch in der
reihenfolge vorgelesen
im hinblick darauf welcher antrag der
weitergehen sste ist wir beginnen also
mit dem antrag zu acht hören uns dazu
die begründung anhören danach die
begründung zu bse 1 daran die begründung
zu bse 2 führen dann eine verbundene
ausbau und stimmen dann über die anträge
ab als erstes darf ich dann dem
antragsteller des antrages t8 das wort
in dem es da zugeht dass der
bundesvorstand künftig auf bis zu 3
bundes sprechen also von 1 bis 3 ist
dann alles drin bestehen soll und im
falle einer einzel spitze soll dann der
bundesvorstand einen generalsekretär
ernennen der vorschlagsberechtigt ist
alleine vom bundessprecher von der
alle
potenziellen kandidaten für das amt des
bundes sprecher das haben gesagt dass
unsere partei
bestimmten reformbedarf hat um in die
zukunft zu gehen oder auch zukunftsfest
zu sein müssen wir deshalb auch unsere
strukturen zumindest vielleicht nicht
für diesen vorstand aber für die
nachfolgenden vorstände neu ordnen und
deshalb ergeht aus unserem bezirk
arnsberg der antrag die möglichkeit zu
eröffnen für die basis bis zu drei
sprecher zu wählen das heißt aber auch
dass nur die wahl eines bundessprecher
es möglich ist der sodann an seiner
seite durch uns als mitgliedschaft ein
generalsekretär bestellt kriegt der dann
programmatisch unsere unsere
programmatik in die öffentlichkeit
tragen kann und vielleicht auch fernab
von streitigkeiten innerhalb eines
vorstandes politisch wirken kann
ich werde auf jeden fall um ihre stimme
für diesen antrag für die möglichkeit
einer einzel spitze samt generalsekretär
vielen dank
vielen dank ich weiß daraufhin den
antrag gestellt hat und im grunde tax
bitte nicht bis zur begründung sondern
genau noch ein bisschen hochgenau
hervorragend dann kann auch jeder noch
in aller pracht die formulierungen zum
generalsekretär lesen und dafür gebe ich
ihnen jetzt auch noch einen moment zeit
interessant bei diesem antrag ist auch
noch die information dass wenn der
bundessprecher wenn es eine einzellösung
gibt vor vollendung seiner amtszeit aus
dem amt ausscheidet dann endet auch
automatisch die amtszeit des
generalsekretärs
ja liebe freunde ein klares plädoyer
grundsätzlich für die einer spitze das
möchte ich vorab betonen ja thüringen
funktioniert anders da haben wir eine
zweite spitze seit acht jahren und
führung funktioniert wie ihr alle wisst
sehr sehr gut das sind seltene glücks
konstellationen dies manchmal auch in
der partei gibt aber grundsätzlich sind
zweier spitzen konfliktträchtige aber
auch das ist die geschichte unserer
partei
wir haben immer wieder bundessprecher
gehabt mit denen der nazis durchgegangen
ist die irgendwann auf eine egoistische
linie über geschwenkt und umgeschwenkt
sind und da war es gut dass wir einen
zweiten bundessprecher hatten der
korrigierend eingreifen konnte also im
sinne der machtarithmetik im sinne des
ausgleich der macht kann es auch
durchaus sinnvoll seine zweier spitze zu
haben aber ich denke wir kommen langsam
in eine phase der konsolidierung wir
sind dazu eine bürgerlich konservative
partei und ich bekenne mich zur einzel
spitze das bedeutet führung in freiheit
und verantwortung auf zeit
1 möchte ich jedoch betonen der antrag
der heute vorsieht ein generalsekretär
auch schon in die satzung zu
implementieren wäre meiner nach meiner
meinung nach verfrüht gestellt wir haben
in bremen 2015 die diskussion um den
generalsekretär abgebrochen wir müssen
uns erst mal klar machen was ist dieser
generalsekretär welche
kompetenzbereiche hdmi ist er eingefügt
in die vorstandsstruktur da müssen wir
noch darüber diskutieren bevor wir das
in die satzung implementieren soll also
mein petitum zum schluss mein credo zum
schluss wir beschließen heute das
umstellen unserer satzung wir streichen
die dreierspitze die glaube ich wirklich
nicht mehr zeitgemäß ist und wir setzen
da für die wahl zwischen einer und
zweier spitze wir machen das jetzt fix
für die satzung wir machen in diesen
durchlauf nochmal eine zweier spitze
weil wir eben noch nicht die erfahrung
gemacht haben dass der politische
prozess kommt ich komme zum schluss sehr
geehrter versammlungsleiter weil wir
leider als partei bisher noch nicht den
die erfahrungen machen konnten dass der
bundesvorstand als neutrale instanz
geführt wurden ein dieser bundesvorstand
ist immer wieder macht politisch
missbraucht worden deswegen hätte ich
gerne erstmal das erlebnis dass eine
instanz nur tragegefühl letzter tag
unseres vorstand neutral geführt wird
und deswegen bitte einer oder zweier
spitze in die satzung einfügen und dann
wählen wir dieses mal noch eine zwei
spitzen beim nächsten mal eine einer
spitze sowie in vielen dank
damit hat gern hätte ja auch sozusagen
auf dem parteitag eine weitere tendenz
mit auf den weg gegeben also das war der
antrag entweder ein oder zwei aber auf
keinen fall mehr der nächste antrag
beschäftigt sich mit dem zweier oder
dreier bundessprecher
vorstand hat uns jetzt begründet ja ich
möchte das noch mal ausdrücklich
unterstützen was eben gesagt wurde es
ist tatsächlich so dass eine zweite
spitze dem gedanken des ausgleichs in
sich trägt es ist aber uns hat sich auch
eine vergangenheit gezeigt dass genau
dieser ausgleich zu missstimmungen
geführt hat zu unterschiedlichen
aussagen und dass meine persönliche
überzeugung eine einer spitze viel er
für die integration und für die
einheitliche meinung einer partei stehen
kann und auch identitätsstiftend sein
kann sein muss und genau das ist ja das
was unserer partei fehlt wenn wir uns
die abstimmungsergebnisse heute alle
angucken stellen wir fest fast alles ist
halbe halbe das kann ja wohl nicht das
langfristige ziel unserer partei sein
wir müssen eine integrative figur finden
die tatsächlich die partei hinter sich
vereint und ganz abgesehen davon
wir sind eine konservative partei und
die linke doppelspitzen struktur sind
wir doch mal ehrlich die findet man doch
nicht in konservativen parteien sondern
eher im links grünen milieu das heißt
also main gebiet um wäre hier an dieser
stelle ganz klar zu sagen wir sollten
uns als partei die möglichkeit in der
satzung ermöglichen eine einer spitze zu
machen und der parteitag kann man anhand
der aktuellen gegebenheiten immer noch
entscheiden ob er eine einer zwei oder
auch drei spitze machen will und das
haben wir hier minimalinvasiv einfach
aufgenommen mit einfacher mehrheit kann
ein parteitag dann immer noch
entscheiden ob ich ein zwei oder drei
bundessprecher haben will nur die
möglichkeit dass sich einen wähle die
ist mit annahme dieses antrages gegeben
und damit hat dieser partei darf
eigentlich mehr macht in der hand und
genau deshalb haben wir diesen antrag
zugestellt vielen dank
vielen dank das war der dritte antrag
zum thema 1 2 oder 3 bundessprecher der
letzte antrag wollte auch zwei oder drei
hat aber auch die einer formulierung mit
dem antrag zwei minuten sagte wird die
geile wird beweist benachteilung liebe
freunde werde delegierte in dem antrag
henrich und kollegin steht im falle
einer einer spitze er nennt der
bundesvorstand einen generalsekretär
vorschlagsberechtigt ist allein der
bundessprecher der generalsekretär
unterstützt den bundessprecher bei der
erfüllung seiner aufgaben er führt im
einvernehmen mit dem bundessprecher die
politischen geschäfte der partei dem
generalsekretär obliegt die koordination
der parteiarbeit aller gebiets verbinde
liebe freunde das hatten wir vor sieben
jahren in der auseinandersetzung mit
bernd lücke ich zitiere den damaligen
luftangriff besteht aus dem
bundessprecher und stellvertreter der
bundesvorstand der bundessprecher hat
das recht dem bundesparteitag einen
generalsekretär zur wahl vorzuschlagen
der generalsekretär unterstützt sind
bundessprecher und wenn sie die satzung
von alpha lesen finden sie das ebenfalls
wieder liebe freunde diese partei als
radikal demokratische partei braucht
nicht dass ein mann oder eine frau
prinzip was ein sehr altes und
überliefertes prinzip von autorität
parteistrukturen ist das brauchen wir in
dieser partei nicht
und ich kann ihnen nur sagen wenn sie
sich vorstellen dass ein generalsekretär
die partei sortiert der ist mehr general
als sekretär davon können sie ausgehen
über die frage ob er besoldet wird und
wie und was das kosten soll sind auch
nichts denn wir haben kein problem der
offiziere wir haben ein problem der
mannschaften und der unteroffizier in
dieser partei und deshalb brauchen wir
keine neuen gefäß befehlsgeber meine
dringende bitte alle die drei anträge
ablehnen das ist die n a der asd und
sagen sie nicht da war aber gestern
zweier die nicht funktioniert haben
unsere doppelspitze in der fraktion im
bundestag funktioniert hervorragend und
die in der letzten periode hat auch
hervorragend produziert bitte konsens
kollegial zwei figuren oder auch drei
nicht einigen können dann ist das ein
problem des charakters solcher personen
und tauben wir auch nicht für die
oberste bundesspitze ich bitte sie
dringend den antrag alle drei absoluten
vielen dank
wir gehen im uhrzeigersinn weiter wird
am blauen saal mikrofon das wort
gewünscht bitteschön ja doch der glaser
ich glaube ich bin unverdächtig ein blog
ist zu sein oder anhänger von alpha ich
habe die formulierung aus der
sächsischen landes und ich kann als
nordrhein-westfale eins sagen von
sachsen lernen heißt siegen lernen und
dort gibt es schon lange dies ist
generalsekretärs konzept und wir haben
natürlich ein problem in unserer partei
mit führung und ich bin nicht in die afg
eingetreten um irgendwann der
führungsstrukturen der grün abzukupfern
soll unsere partei giert nach
orientierung nach führung und auch ein
hoffnungsschimmer an der spitze und dem
ende eines schädlichen lager dualismus
und ich glaube nicht dass wir da kann
ich für alle in nrw sprechen noch die
zeit haben abzuwarten wir sollten heute
entweder antrag röcke oder helfrich
unterstützen um die möglichkeit für die
zukunft zu schaffen unsere partei auch
durch eine person
wirken zu lassen danke
vielen dank es geht weiter im roten saal
mikrofon
vielen dank mein name ist folgerichtig
vom landesverband hessen man möge an das
jahr 2013 zurück denken wenn man uns
jetzt vorwürfe würden linke oder grüne
strukturen hier einführen dem es
garantiert nicht so wir haben damals mit
guten bedacht zwei sprecher gewählt weil
wir nicht so sein wollten wie die
anderen nämlich nicht zu sein wollten
wie angela merkel wir wollten keine
alternativlosigkeit in unserer partei
und wir wollten integrative und integre
menschen innerhalb des vorstandes und
das ist auch von allen delegierten zu
erwarten dass der vorstand miteinander
anständig und integer umgehen und wer
jetzt ihr glaubt dass eine einer spitze
in irgendeiner form weiter hilft der hat
nicht verstanden auf welchem problem vor
welchen problemen wir stehen und wo um
es überhaupt in unserem land geht
nämlich darum demokratie wieder zu
lernen und wir schaffen demokratie in
unserer partei mit so etwas ab es gibt
nicht diesen einen heilsbringer für
unsere partei erhöhte mag sich gerne so
sehen aber er ist es definitiv nicht und
somit brauchen wir mehrere menschen in
unserer partei die die partei führen und
deswegen muss alles so bleiben wie es
ist denn das kommt aus 2013 und mit
verlaub von einem bundesvorstand erwarte
ich dass er ordentlich und anständig
miteinander umgeht und nicht die dinge
nach außen bringt wo man sich mal
streitet das ist einheit aber nichts
dass ein sprecher oben steht und für uns
den vortänzer spielt den will mit
sicherheit hier bei uns keiner danke
vielen dank für fahren fort am
rednerpult herr lohse
liebe freunde zwei sprecher bedeutet
nicht nur dass wir zwei strömungen
abbilden können das bedeutet nicht nur
dass wir ost und west abbilden können
das bedeutet auch dass wir das ganze auf
zwei schultern verteilen können dass die
beiden sich ergänzen können dass die
beiden zb überlegen können wer geht in
die eine talkshow wer geht in die andere
talkshow wer geht zum bürger raus wer
geht zum unternehmer raus und das geht
natürlich mit einer zweier spitze sehr
gut und die alleinherrschaft
allüren kennen wir ja aus konservativen
parteien ehemals konservative parteien
wie die cdu mit dem merkel system und da
sollten wir bitte nicht wieder zurück in
sondern lasst uns die an die dna der afg
weiterleben mit einer zweier spitze
meine damen und herren und deswegen alle
drei anträge ablehnen vielen dank vielen
dank am blauen see soll ein mikrofon
wird es gibt einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag
es wurde schluss der debatte beantragt
gibt es hier zu einer gegenrede
ja bitte am roten saal mikrofon
ja also es stehen hier eigentlich noch
leute an die sich in der sache noch
äußern möchten und ich halte schon für
zielführend wir haben die zeit wir
sollten uns die zeit nehmen auch diese
debatte zu führen
dass wir genau jetzt ich würde es
modifizieren ende der rednerliste und
dann können wir darüber abstimmen
aber jetzt ende der debatte halte ich
nicht für zielführend die debatte muss
geführt werden gut das war dann
irgendwie möglich sind einflüsse die
und kann vom design mikrofone und deren
äußerungen von den delegierten
danke schön wer ist dagegen
die frage ist jetzt ob die parteien
aktive sack reis debatte um die frage
der sprecherposten beenden möchte oder
nicht
die stimmkarte mal wurden rat hat in die
höhe gehoben hat kein eindeutiges
ergebnis
ergeben und darum geht es jetzt
elektronisch weiter weil das ein
präzises ergebnis einfach liefert noch
mal zur erinnerung die debatte in der
etliche
delegierte auch an den saal mikrofon
stand halten ich sollte unter beraten
werden oder soll unterbrochen werden und
abgebrochen und beendet werden und dann
über diese drei anträge direkt
abgestimmt werden man wird sehen ob
jetzt diese satzungsdebatte in der
partei weitergeführt wird oder ob sie
mit diesem geo antrag mit dem
geschäftsordnungsantrag der jederzeit
gestellt werden kann beendet wird
das ergebnis dürfte in einigen sekunden
da sein und dann wird man sehen wie hier
weiter verfahren wird noch zehn sekunden
ich habe jedenfalls an beiden sein
mikrofon noch etliche redebeiträge
beziehungsweise dekorierte gesehen die
noch zu dem thema äußern wollten 0 die
abstimmung ausgeschlossen und der antrag
ist abgelehnt wir haben dann noch den
antrag auf ende der rednerliste wird
hierzu die gegenrede gewünscht
formal inhaltlich
kann ich auch keine inhaltliche ich kann
keine innerlich gegenrede erkennen lässt
sich darüber abstimmen nachdem wir
festgestellt haben wer alles sich auf
der rednerliste befindet da guckt er
weil ich jetzt in den saal richtung
weisen mikrofone und
dort schauen wer dort an den mikrofonen
steht es sind ja an beiden seiten des
saales mikrofone aufgebaut für die
delegierten und er ist gehalten laut
satzung und ordnung des parteitages
immer jeweils an einem der saal
mikrofone rot und blau
abwechselnd die delegierten zu wort
kommen zu lassen der wahlleitung und
zwar würde ich darum bitten dass der
wahlleiter sich am roten sein mikrofon
hinstellt und der stellvertretende
wahlleiter im blauen saal mikrofon um
die rednerliste dann für den fall dass
der antrag angenommen ist auch klar
dicht zu machen
das heißt das wird jetzt quasi mehr oder
weniger händisch und real gemacht dass
ich jemand dort an die mikrofone stellt
und sagt sie sind der letzte in der
rednerliste des jeweiligen saal
mikrofons und danach ist dann schluss
der vertretene wahlleiter am roten sein
mikrofon angelangt
die halle ist sehr groß ich sagte ja
vorhin zu beginn 9000 sitzplätze können
hier normalerweise ein mann hat auch die
reihen etwas gelichtet weil man dann
doch wahrscheinlich aufgrund des
großzügigen umgangs mit platz da nun
etwas weiter auseinander gebaut hatte
heißt aber dass auch das tagungs
präsidium von der bühne aus
schwierigkeiten hat alles genau zu sehen
weil es doch mal weiter weg
also gehe ich mal von aus seien sie
drängen sich vor aber das wäre ja noch
angehörige so dann lasse ich jetzt über
den antrag auf ende der rednerliste
abstimmen wer es dafür
dankeschön ist dagegen
dankeschön enthält sich
dann ist der antrag mit mehrheit
angenommen wurden und dann fahren wir
mit der debatte fort am roten sein
mikrofon
martina böswald kreisverband breisgau
hochschwarzwald sprecherin guten tag es
geht hier nicht um die frage ob wir ein
zwei oder drei sprecher haben es geht um
die frage ob verantwortung teilbar ist
und wie sie wahrgenommen wird und zwar
so dass man nicht den anderen im regen
stehen lässt und abtaucht bis man dann
wieder eine günstige möglichkeit hat
presse technisch schön aufzuschlagen das
ist die eigentliche kritik die hier im
raum steht und dabei hängt es gar nicht
davon ab ob wir ein zwei oder drei
sprecher haben die frage mit dem
generalsekretär
die regelt man sowieso auf der zweiten
ebene und zwar mit partei
ordnungsmaßnahmen spricht jemand aus
erfahrung danke
vielen dank wir fahren fort am blauen
saal mikrofon ja ich bin an der stelle
sehr dankbar dass die debatte hier nicht
mehrheitlich abgewürgt wurde denn dafür
ist die thematik ob wir so etwas in die
satzung aufnehmen viel zu gravierend und
auch wichtig für die zukunft unserer
partei ich bin ein großer freund da
führen dass wir dem bundesparteitag die
möglichkeit geben eine sprecher lösung
zu implementieren deswegen werbe ich für
die unterstützung sage aber gleichzeitig
nach meiner festen überzeugung
das stichwort viel gerade die
integrative figur die ist zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt nach meiner festen überzeugung
in der form nicht erkennbar dass sie 90
prozent der delegierten und der partei
abdeckt und deswegen brauchen wir bei
diesem parteitag noch die doppelspitze
also ja um den bundesparteitag die
möglichkeit zu geben darüber in zukunft
zu entscheiden
nein wenn es darum geht es jetzt bei
diesem bundesparteitag zu nutzen vielen
dank
es geht weiter am blauen saal mikrofon
also was wollen wir wir wollen erfolge
ramelow kretschmann kohl die waren alle
und sind alle erfolgreich weil die
menschen eine person sehen in der sie
sich fokussieren können und die sie auch
verstehen drei sprecher bram auf gar
keinen fall 2 da bin ich schon deshalb
dagegen weil das kommt von den grünen
und von denen kam noch nie was gutes
deshalb ein sprecher ist die beste
lösung da weiß man wo es langgeht danke
vielen dank es geht weiter im roten saal
mikrofon
liebe parteifreunde mein name ist robert
lambro ich bin einer von zwei
landessprecher der afg hessen und da
sind wir auch schon beim thema in hessen
hatten wir noch nie 'ne einer spitze wir
waren immer gezwungen dass die mehreren
landessprecher auf gleicher höhe sich
untereinander verständigen das klappt in
hessen auch seit einigen jahren sehr gut
und ich möchte betonen wir haben
mittlerweile in hessen sogar eine
wirklich klassische doppelspitze mit dem
andreas lickert aus dem einen flügel und
mir aus dem anderen und es funktioniert
sehr gut weil wenn wir mal nicht einer
meinung sind dann diskutieren wir das
auf augenhöhe aus mit der einer spitze
ist das nicht wirklich einigkeit
entsteht nicht durch eine einer spitze
sollen dass man auf augenhöhe so lange
miteinander redet bis man einigkeit hat
ich plädiere für die beibehaltung der
doppelspitze dankeschön
die debatte wird fortgesetzt am blauen
saal mikrofon vorhin hat vorher jemand
gesagt man könne dann schön ost und west
abbilden liebe freunde wir wollen nicht
ost und west abbilden wir wollen
deutschland abbilden
[Applaus]
und deutschland ist ein land die
alternative für deutschland ist eine
partei und dann darf sich das in der
struktur auch widerspiegeln ich bin für
eine person aus spitzen personen wir
brauchen auch keine gewöhnungsphase wir
können das jetzt hier beschließen danke
vielen dank
und am roten saal mikrofon geht es
weiter ja weil hier immer die rede von
führung ist
ich bin nicht davon überzeugt dass
führung durch eine satzungsänderung
kommt sondern führung kommt durch
kompetenz und da muss man einfach mal
sagen das sind wir an uns selbst zum
teil gescheitert das ist das eine und
das andere ist nun mal da müssen wir uns
selbst auch mal im stück weit ehrlich
machen solange wir in persönlicher
umgang von bettnässen oder zelt pink
land reden solange sind wir auch nicht
erwachsen genug um mit einer spitze eine
geeinte partei zu führen ja wir sollten
hier konstruktiv miteinander arbeiten
und das können sehr wohl zwei und auch
drei leute dafür brauche ich keinen
einen zampano
haben wir noch eine wortmeldung am
blauen sein mikrofon ja eine die letzte
bitte schön oder die vorletzte packung 1
bitte
liebe parteifreunde
martin reichert ich bin
landesvorsitzender von sachsen anhalt
und wir haben dort eine einer spitze und
das was hier so an horrorszenarien zu
einer spitze gezeichnet worden ist da
kann ich aus erfahrung sprechen das ist
falsch und ich möchte euch eins sagen
wir haben doch hier eine ganz nüchterne
und sachliche diskussion ob wir unsere
partei für die zukunft die möglichkeit
eröffnen wollen eine einer spitze zu
wählen hierzu ist zu sagen dass die
masse unserer landesverbände heute
bereits eine einer spitze hat es ist
also machbar und man muss dafür auch
keine angst haben das ist doch auch ein
zeichen des reifens und der einheit
unserer partei
[Applaus]
und eins möchte ich auch noch an euch
alle hier richten und ich weiß wir sind
da alle einer meinung hier den merkel
ismus für uns herauf zu beschwören wir
sind die alternative für deutschland und
wir begreifen uns als deutschlands
zukunft keiner von uns hier im saal wird
jemals eine struktur ermöglichen und
erlauben die eine person wie frau merkel
an die parteispitze führt vielen dank
vielen dank
es geht weiter am roten sein mikrofon
ja ich möchte mich hier gleich
anschließend ich habe mir alle satzungen
der landesverbände durch geguckt 14 von
16 landesverbänden ermöglichen eine
einzel spitze zwölf davon machen
gebrauch also muss man doch mal fragen
die kritiker sollten dann so war es
erstmal in ihrem eigenen landesverband
anstoßen bevor sie hier kritisch sich
äußern und deswegen muss ich sagen ich
bin für eine einzel spitze dass man die
ermöglichen genauso wie ist der
überwältigende teil der landesverbände
vorsieht in ihren satzungen warum dann
nicht auch auf bundesebene
vielen dank und dann haben wir noch eine
letzte wortmeldung am blauen saal
mikrofon
ja wird sie in unseren antrag eine
einzel spitze die auch ein
generalsekretär ermöglicht zurück und
ich hoffe dass sich dr spanien und herr
höcker einigen können so dass wir über
eine version sprechen können die dann
eben auch für die zukunft eine einer
spitze ermöglicht vielen dank vielen
dank für vermerken im protokoll dass der
antrag von den elf gericht zurückgezogen
wurde und dann kommen wir jetzt zu den
verbleibenden rednern im roten saal
mikrofon bitteschön vielen dank so viele
redner sind es ja nicht mehr fort
matthias einsatz von sachsen lernen
heißt siegen lernen der ging runter wie
honig hat uns gefreut wenn du das
nächste mal nach zwickau kommen willst
bist du herzlich willkommen
zu der sachfrage
wir in sachsen haben eine einer spitze
die jetzt gehört fast alle andere
landesverbände auch wenn man sich das
ganze jetzt mal nüchtern anschaut die
möglichkeit zwei oder drei sprechers
haben halte ich nach wie oft nach wie
vor für verrückt 12 spitzen ist das
normales oft für die wähler am klarsten
verständlich wer das sagen hat wer die
partei anführt und deswegen unterstütze
ich den antrag dass wir auf die eine
oder zwei aus spitze umgehen danke
vielen dank dann die debatte wird dann
am roten sein mikrofon fortgeführt ja
vielen dank herr vorsitzender grüße
meine habe landesverband sachsen ich
hoffe das ist richtig verstanden zu
haben dass das thema generalsekretär vom
tisch sollte das nicht der fall sein
würde ich das gerne extra abstimmen
lassen weil der serie vom tisch
wunderbar da freue ich mich und für die
zukunft sollten wir als partei und die
möglichkeit eröffnen auch mit einem sehr
guten spitzenmann spitzenfrau die partei
führen zu lassen deswegen würde ich auch
heute dafür plädieren dass wir die
satzung in dem bereich ändern aber ich
hoffe auch auf die weisheit der
versammlung dass man so von dem zustand
der partei sich gegebenenfalls für die
heutige versammlung für dieses
wochenende noch mal für eine mär
sprecher lösung einsetzt vielen dank
vielen dank es geht dann weiter am roten
sein mikrofon
ja ich möchte gerne den antrag
modifikation auf einer zweier oder
dreier spitze zurückziehen ich unter den
nicht unterstütze den antrag einer oder
zweier spitze von blöcken
das nehmen wir auch so zu protokoll es
bleibt dann nur noch der antrag von
einer übrig zudem gleichwohl die debatte
weiter geht am roten sunny
portal vorne ich bin hier als
landesvorsitzender rheinland pfalz
alleiniger landesvorsitzender und das
funktioniert bei uns auch sehr gut hat
auch gut funktioniert gleichwohl muss
man die strukturen den realitäten
anpassen und ich denke da haben wir auf
bundesebene doch eine etwas andere
situation die partei wächst zusammen
aber wir haben noch ost und west mit
unterschiedlichen verhältnissen und ich
glaube deshalb dass wir zunächst bei
dieser bewährten struktur bleiben
sollten das willkommen in der zukunft
vielleicht ändern aber aus meiner sicht
sollten wir jetzt bei der mehrfach
spitze bleiben und plädieren daher dafür
den antrag abzuweisen vielen dank
vielen dank dann sind wir fertig meine
damen und herren wir haben eine debatte
geführt zwei der drei anträge sind
zurückgezogen worden ich darf darum doch
bitten dass dann der korrekte antrag der
antrag gs1 eingeblendet wird ja wohl das
lesen sie hier der bundesparteitag möge
beschließen § 13a der bundessatzung wie
folgt zu ändern der bundesvorstand
besteht aus einem oder zwei bundes
sprechern bisher sieht die satzung vor
dass es zwei oder drei und sprecher sind
es handelt sich um einen antrag der
unsere satzung geändert zur annahme des
antrages ist eine zwei-drittel-mehrheit
erforderlich
wir kommen zur abstimmung wer dem antrag
gs1 seine zustimmung erteilen möchte den
bitte ich um das karten zeichen
so das ist ja ganz schön eklig frage
gibt es eine zweidrittelmehrheit ist
darf er nicht mit einfacher mehrheit
abgestimmt werden
aber die frage ob das mit
zweidrittelmehrheit ist wage ich mal zu
behaupten wird elektronisch abgestimmt
da das verhältnis glaube ich zu unklar
ist erreicht wurde daher werden wir
jetzt elektronisch darüber abstimmen
lassen ich darf darum bitten eine
abstimmung vor zu bereiten und für diese
abstimmung würde ich auch darum bitten
dass die türen in zwei minuten
geschlossen werden
damit auch alle reinkommen können zu
dieser ja doch nur
erinnerungen zwei delegierte die
unterschiedliche anträge zum einen gab
es das thema mit dem generalsekretär
zur abstimmung hier vorgelegt hatten
haben ihre anträge zurück gelegt damit
bleibt die frage folgt die partei und
der parteitag dem antrag dessen rechten
rechtsaußen bieren höcke dessen
einbringung hier ja mit dem antrag auch
einen verbalen
akzent gesetzt hat oder aber stimmt sie
dem nicht ab und wird das alte
bundessatzung
den bundessatzung paragrafen noch weiter
produzieren und realisieren spannend
bleibt es allemal 23 wie ist das quorum
nicht ganz klar hängt auch davon ab wie
viel menschen abgestimmt haben vom tisch
ist aber auf jeden fall die frage
generalsekretär oder nicht vor fünf
jahren der bei uns gab es schon mal den
versuch von dem damaligen
landesvorsitzenden von sachsen-anhalt
andre poggenburg inzwischen auch aus der
partei
ausgeschlossen und hat die partei
verlassen den versuch einer einer oder
zweier spitze als maximale
bundessprecher anzahl zu installieren
der antrag wurde dann aber aufgrund der
parteitags und dynamik damals in
hannover wieder zurückgezogen das ist
also jetzt fünf jahre danach der zweite
versuch und es bleibt die frage ob
dieses mal der parteitag dieser reform
die blöcke mit seinem antrag ins leben
gerufen hat realisieren dort und folgen
wird
3210 es wird bitte niemand mehr rein
oder rausgelassen meine damen und herren
wir stimmen jetzt elektronisch über den
antrag gs1 ab der darauf abzielt dass
der bundesvorstand in zukunft einen oder
zwei bundessprecher haben soll wenn sie
dafür sind drücken sie die eins wenn sie
dagegen sind drücken sie die 2 wenn sie
sich der stimme enthalten möchten
drücken sie die 3 ich öffne die
abstimmung eine minute
also wenn ich davon ausgehe dass
499 oder
521 ich glaube die zahl wurde noch
einmal erhöht der delegierten die dabei
sind
519 ich korrigiere mich delegierte mit
abstimmen können und das bei einer zwei
drittel mehrheit
entscheidend sein soll und dass der
break even punkt bei diesen delegierten
liegen soll ich habe jetzt gerade nicht
ausgerechnet wie viele delegierte damit
abstimmen müssen um diese
satzungsänderungen die ja eben nicht nur
einfache mehr bedeutet sondern
genau danke meine kollegin hat das
gerade ausgerechnet
342 müssen ja stimmen um diese
zweidrittelmehrheit bei 519 abgeordneten
ich habe aber jetzt gesehen es sind nur
500 sechs abgeordnete also wird es ein
bisschen weniger sein
gucken wir mal hin
69 19 prozent haben für diesen antrag
gestimmt
das sind 300 und 48
ist der angenommen
ein sieg von gehirn höcker auf diesem
parteitag und wie das zu bewerten ist
das kann uns jetzt alexander keller im
gespräch mit einem gast am set erklären
wie doris wir werden mit diesem gespräch
noch etwas warten wir wollen noch etwas
dazwischen schieben worüber wir heute
auch schon gesprochen haben wird die
beobachtung der afd durch den
verfassungsschutz ist es ja üblich dass
der präsident des bundesamtes für
verfassungsschutz thomas halten kontakt
auch vertraulichen kontakt hält zu
parteien und fraktionen in deutschland
einzige ausnahme die afg aber da gibt es
wiederum eine ausnahme mit einem afd
politiker hat er offensichtlich noch
kontakt regelmäßig in kontakt der noch
zugang zu thomas halten waren zum
präsidenten des bundesamtes für
verfassungsschutz und das ist
romantisch afd politiker in der letzten
legislaturperiode mitglied im deutschen
bundestag mitglied im
geheimdienstausschuss und von beruf
oberstaatsanwalt und mit dem hatte ich
gelegenheit vor kurzem zu sprechen über
das thema wie gerechtfertigt ist diese
beobachtung des verfassungsschutzes als
er gesagt wie gerechtfertigt ist der
dass die afg vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet wird
wenn ich den
präsidentin des bundesamtes für
verfassungsschutz thomas halten banken
richtig verstanden habe dann haben die
mitarbeiter des pv des bfv an diesem
wochenende urlaubssperre weil sie genau
den parteitag der afg beobachten wollen
das ist auch so angekündigt hatten der
sei jetzt genau unter beobachtung dieses
interesse des verfassungsschutzes sie
sind ja verdachtsfall inzwischen auch
für die bundes partei überrascht sie das
nein das steht ganz oben weiter auf der
politischen agenda derer die in diesem
land was sagen haben unsere partei so
schnell wie möglich und so nachhaltig
wie möglich fertig zu machen das folgt
der blaupause die man erfolgreich bei
den republikanern
durchgezogen hat und nach diesem muster
wollen sie auch uns politisch erlege
aber hat sich da die afg nicht auch
selbst einiges zuzuschreiben äußerungen
von mitgliedern der partei die durchaus
hat am rande der verfassung oder darüber
hinaus zu verstehen sind ja also dobel
äußerungen gibt es immer die frage ist
wie man damit umgeht wir hatten
vor dem
verwaltungsgericht köln war letztens
termin zur mündlichen verhandlung
wo es um unsere die frage unserer
beobachtung geht also
prozessbevollmächtigter zitate von cdu
und csu politikern führungen gebracht
auch vom ehemaligen bundesinnenminister
seehofer mit sprüchen die man
bei fdp politikern sofort als ausweis
also aber von so was von
rechtsextremistischer gesinnung sehen
würde und bei cdu und csu politikern
lösen dieselben sprüche nur achselzucken
aus wie kann das sein das ist ganz
einfach zu beantworten der politik der
verfassungsschutz wird leider politisch
instrumentalisiert es wird einseitig
gewichtet es wird nur belastendes
gesehen entlastendes wird geflissentlich
übersehen ja die frage ist ja jetzt was
da tatsächlich als belastend für die
partei gesehen und personenschutz
ergebnis auch mal ein beispiel die
vergleiche von corona impfungen mit den
menschen versuchen des ns-regimes aber
auch äußerungen zum beispiel über
migranten pauschal bezeichnungen als
kriminelle all das was ja gegen
verschiedene grundrechts prinzipien des
verfassungsgerichtes verstößt so weit
hergeholt ist sind diese vorwürfe gegen
die ice t ja nicht also
der eingangs zitierte
vergleich fehlt unter die absolut dummen
äußerungen
ist völlig unhaltbar aber ich weiß nicht
was daran verfassungsfeindliche
bestrebungen sein soll welche
verfassungsfeindliche bestrebungen soll
darin zum ausdruck kommen dass einer
eine richtig blöde bemerkung macht
[Musik]
wir müssen sie müssen durch dürfen
nachdem wir setzen nur beobachten wenn
eine partei im verdacht steht
verfassungsfeindliche bestrebungen zu
wollen welches verfassungsfeindliche
ziele soll der mit einer solchen
äußerung verfolgt werden das ist doch
einen haaren aber der war gut wir sind
ja jetzt habe ich zwei beispiele genannt
das waren aber viele gewesen der
bundesverfassungsschutz listet ja auch
sie haben ja selbst ein staatsrechtler
engagiert für ein gutachten der ihnen
vorgehalten hat was da alles eigentlich
jeder vermeiden sollte daran halten sich
allerdings auch prominente fdp
politikerinnen und politiker nicht
deswegen eigentlich kein wunder dass
jetzt beobachtet werden ja also das ist
damit liefern hat liefern wir natürlich
nach freiheit dreihausen munition das
ist völlig richtig wenn sie aber jetzt
zum beispiel zu der frage war ihr
zweites beispiel pauschale forum gehen
form von ausländern als kriminelle
niemand bei uns vor umkämpft pauschal
ausländer als kriminelle es gibt
äußerungen die manch ein bisschen
unscharf sind die wählen dann immer
gerne das wort dann hinein interpretiert
was man hören will wenn ich sagte es ja
schon was beide verwaltungsgerichts
termin
welche zitate von anderen parteien w
gesammelt haben die alle von uns hätten
sein können sie waren es aber nicht bei
dem csu menschen erregt dass keine
verdacht bei uns erregt es verdacht
warum wird hier so intensiv mit
zweierlei maß gemessen warum geht nicht
auch zum beispiel die presse mal dieser
spur nach und sagt was sie ihnen sagen
denn andere warum ist das bei der afg
verfassungsfeindlich oder zumindest
verdächtig und bei dem dieselben
äußerungen völlig in ordnung
mutmaßlicher daran dass bei der afg
diese äußerung sehr häufig vorkommen und
bei den anderen möglicherweise viel
seltener noch eine ich habe meinen hier
gefällt der csu-mann wahlabend aber ich
glaube es ist nicht nur das sieht man
trotzdem eine qualitätsunterschiede in
der äußerung wie sich die haltung ihrer
partei so trotzig zu sagen jetzt erst
recht jetzt fordern wir den
verfassungsschutz raus also wir haben
uns eingehend mit der geschichte
republikaner befasst
und zwar nachdem wir das getan haben
klar was auf uns zukommt und genau so
kommt es auch bei der republikaner nicht
empfehle jedem immer nur das urteil des
oberverwaltungsgerichts berlin
brandenburg vom mai 2006 befasst sich
mit der beobachtende republikanern ist
ein geschildert was da alles für sprüche
klopft wurden und das sprücheklopfen ist
allenfalls ein indiz unterm strich muss
dabei rauskommen dass das ein beleg
dafür ist dass diese partei wirklich
verfassungsfeindliche ziele verfolgt und
wenn sie das mal lesen da waren wirklich
schlimme entgleisungen dabei dagegen
sind hier waisenknaben den gast fast
ihre musik anna alles erzählt haben dies
und gleich und dann kam das
oberverwaltungsgericht
berlin-brandenburg mai 2006 ein ergebnis
das die beobachten republikaner von
anfang an
rechtswidrig war von anfang an
rechtswidrig gut jetzt ist es
möglicherweise geschmackssache wer da
als waisenknabe ausgetreten ist und wer
nicht sie haben ja auf jeden fall noch
die möglichkeit immer wieder auch den
rechtsweg einzuschlagen dagegen
vorzugehen soweit man rasch von der afg
hier zum thema beobachten und möglichen
verfassungsschutz bedanke mich für das
gespräch
ja man muss auch ergänzen roman roche
hat ja auch den vorwurf erhoben bisher
gesagt er hat darauf hingewiesen dass
die republikaner durch den
verfassungsschutz damals regelrecht
demokraten sind und dass das jetzt eben
auch absicht des bundesamtes für
verfassungsschutz sei professor wolfgang
schröder also was jetzt was jetzt gerade
gehört haben der verfassungsschutz wird
von der etablierten politik
instrumentalisiert ungerechtfertigter
weise gegen die afc
jetzt mit zweierlei maß angelegt afd
oder zum beispiel csu und das was er afd
politikerinnen und politiker sagen ist
entweder dummes zeug oder nicht
verfassungsfeindlich was ist von dieser
argumentation zu halten das vorgehen des
verfassungsschutzes ist ja nicht aus der
hüfte geschossen sondern der
verfassungsschutz muss dann eintreten
muss sich kümmern wenn indizien
vorliegen dass hier deutlich widerstände
gegen die freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung vorliegen und der
verfassungsschutz kann sich das nicht
einfach machen sondern der muss material
vorliegen dann muss das systematisch
entwickeln über einen längeren zeitraum
hinweg und das hat der verfassungsschutz
unter der ägide von alten man ja auch
gemacht hat zwei
materialsammlungen vorgelegt von jeweils
etwa 1000 seiten material
veröffentlichte art aber auch zugänglich
über social media gesammelt worden ist
also dass der vorwurf da wird einfach
irgendwas nur aneinander gereiht sehr
schwierig aufrecht zu erhalten ist weil
hier ja wirklich auch kontexte angegeben
werden weil hier über längere zeiträume
die ausführungen abgebildet werden und
weil eine bandbreite von ganz
unterschiedlichen personen herangezogen
werden und diesem urteil muss man sich
dann widmen und das hat das gericht auch
gemacht also hier kommt noch mal eine
zusätzliche instanz ist nicht einfach
nur der verfassungsschutz und es war das
verwaltungsgericht das
verwaltungsgericht hat gewisse zweifel
aufgebaut daraufhin hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht geurteilt und
hier haben wir doch im recht eindeutigen
befund dass die zweifel sehr massiv sind
und dazu gehören der nicht nur
äußerungen die man öffentlich und nicht
öffentlich vernehmen kann sondern ihre
intensität ihrer häufigkeit ihrer
systematik und die dahinterstehenden
grundrechtsverletzungen dann kommt noch
hinzu dass die afg eine ganze reihe von
personen hinter der bühne beschäftigt
hat die zweifelsfrei im bereich
rechtsextremistische vernetzungen aktiv
sind so dass ein bild entstanden ist was
sich nicht einfach so mit den
begründungen von herrn reusch zur seite
legen lässt wenn der abend resümee zieht
ist nach ihrer einschätzung das was der
verfassungsschutz gesammelt hat gegen
die afg so substanziell auch so
juristisch wasserdicht das auch bei
klagen der afg gegen die beobachtung es
bei dieser beobachtung bleiben wird dass
der verfassungsschutz tatsächlich jetzt
die afd als verdachtsfall führt und
genau beobachtet was die partei macht
also der verfassungsschutz ist ja keine
stasi sonst ein demokratisch
legitimiertes organ und der
verfassungsschutz hat mit seinem
vorgehen viel aufs spiel gesetzt das
heißt wenn herauskommen würde das wären
alles nur fake die er da aneinander
reiht dann setzt er ja nicht nur seine
reputation aufs spiel sondern auch die
legitimation die er durch die regierung
und durch das politische system der
bundesrepublik erhalten hat insofern
muss er das sehr zweifelsfrei entwickeln
und er weiß auch es muss am ende
wasserdicht sein muss von den gerichten
entsprechend behandelt werden können und
das hat alles stattgefunden und vor
diesem hintergrund kann man sagen ob 8
und insofern ist das auch für die afg
ein klares signal entweder ihr
orientiert euch daran oder ihr habt nur
eine geringe halbwertszeit unter diesen
bedingungen weiter agieren zu können
nochmal zurück gehen auf einen aspekt
den wir vorhin schon kurz angesprochen
haben die erste rede von ihrem hüpfer
hier als er ja sich stark gemacht hat
für eine partei strukturreformen form
einer parteistruktur kommission deren
vorsitz er wohl ganz gerne übernehmen
würde das wird jetzt zwar allerdings
erst nach den wahlen zum bundesvorstand
stattfinden hätte wollte es ja davor
haben aber jetzt zum zur sache zur sache
einer partei strukturreform das klingt
nach professionalisierung nach
konkretisierung von politischen vorgaben
politischen zielen hat die afg da ein
defizit und welche rolle spielt haben
wir eine hecke die afg hat insofern ein
defizit weil sie ja selbst darunter
leidet es immer wieder feststellt und
möglicherweise ist das auch das
eigentliche anliegen dieses parteitages
einheit herzustellen das heißt die
kakophonie die allen teilen
die öffentliche kommunikation der afg
projekt ist etwas worunter sie ein stück
weit leid ich sage ausdrücklich ein
stückweit teilweise ist es auch zu ihrem
vorteil gewesen weil man sich immer
aussuchen konnte was man besser fand
aber aufs ganze betrachtet wenn man die
partei weiter entwickeln will im
heutigen sinne dann gehts ihm und so
kann man den antrag auch lesen um eine
professionalisierte kaderpartei und
insofern ist es auch nicht von ungefähr
dass er selbst der vorsitzende dieser
struktur reform kommission sein will die
ihr auf drei komponenten aufbaut
einerseits will er die parteitage
professionalisieren dann den gesamten
parteiaufbau und nicht zuletzt dann auch
die rekrutierung aufbau der kader
derjenigen die diese partei vertreten
sondern das ist schon starker stein also
wenn am ende diese kommission mit seiner
federführung hier verabschiedet werden
würde könnte man das schon als einen
baustein in der weiteren fokussierung
der afg begreift die sicherung der afg
weiterer baustein da könnte ja auch dazu
gehören dass er sich jetzt auch mit
seinem vorschlag durchgesetzt dass in
dieser partei festgelegt wird entweder 2
oder 1 bundessprecher dieses mal hat er
ja auch ganz klar gesagt ist noch für
eine doppelspitze aber beim nächsten mal
dann für eine einer spitze wenn ich
jetzt das zusammen was ich gerade gesagt
haben dann haben wir in zwei jahren
einen bundessprecher van hecke genau
also grob aller soll auf keinen fall
alleine losgelassen werden aber wenn das
jemand anders wäre und vermutlich wäre
es dann aus seiner sicht er selbst dann
wäre das durchaus akzeptabel weil
dadurch die partei ein besseres standing
hätte so seine lesart der dinge hat er
denn die mehrheit des parteitags dann
auch hin dass sich an der muss ja auch
gewählt werde man hat ja bisher immer
das gefühl gehabt er ist hat gekniffen
er ist nicht angetreten weil er angst
hatte nicht gewählt zu werden genau
geregelt und galt als risikoavers das
hat sich aber etwas geändert muss man
klar sagen er hat schon den dresdner
parteitag gedreht hier übernimmt er auch
eine sehr aktive rolle und er ist ja
keiner der so richtig vor brecht sondern
man hat schon den eindruck dass er da
sehr behutsam vorgeht dass er eine
gewisse strategische begabung hat und in
diesem sinne wäre auch dieser beschluss
einer der in seinem sinne die partei der
hockey sierung vorantreibt haben ihm
auch strategische klugheit attestieren
also jetzt in seinem sinne denn
eigentlich man vermutete also etwa ein
drittel der delegierten sie ja
tatsächlich hätte anhänger sind ein
dritter gegner ein drittel
unentschlossene da muss man ja einiges
dafür tun um die unentschlossenen auf
seine seite zu ziehen ja und das kann er
weil er eine stimme für das wir
entwickelt hat das heißt er hat nicht
nur sein eigenes partial interesse als
börnecke hier artikuliert sondern schon
die sehnsucht delegierten ein stückweit
befriedet diese partei zu einen diese
partei mit einer stimme auszustatten und
damit auch so eine gewisse mächtigkeit
zu suggerieren dass
sogenannten lage das bisher den
bundesvorstand der dominiert hat das
soll jetzt lahm gelegt werden ist eher
so eine art vorstufe auch bezirke
versuchen in den nächsten zwei jahren
auch wenn er gar nicht im bundesvorstand
ist schon die voraus voraussetzungen zu
schaffen dafür dass er dann in zwei
jahren ganz übernehmen kann das sind
schon wichtige fragen von ihnen weil wir
sind ja in der vergangenheit immer davon
ausgegangen dass das kräfteverhältnis
innerhalb der afg so 70 prozent eher
radikal gemäßigte und 30 prozent eher
radikal
zupackende und da haben wir mittlerweile
den eindruck seit dem dresdner parteitag
spätestens die kräfteverhältnisse haben
sich grundlegend verändert dh die er
moderateren sind doch stärker
zurückgewiesen und es ist apple gelungen
die unentschlossenen auf seine seite zu
ziehen bzw
viele von ihnen haben sich auch
zurückgezogen das muss man ganz klar
sehen insofern hat aus der sicht der
koalitions willigen also die partei als
koalitionspartner für die anderen
anzubieten hat sich ein rückzug
offenbart und die position der
fundamental opposition mit all ihren
konnotationen des nationalismus des
amtes rassismus usw das ist doch stärker
geworden kann man sagen sie haben jetzt
von kaderpartei gesprochen also die die
sie auch professionalisiert die straße
geführt wird das ist sich radikalisiert
und dass sie auch ostdeutsche wird also
dachte was ja manche vermuten an der
ostdeutsche regional und volkspartei das
im wesentlichen auf diese bundesländer
bezogen bleibt am leben kann politisch
überlegen wird sich auch bei den
bundestag bewegen aber sie die
ausbreitung für ganz deutschland ist
damit vom tisch damit wären einkapselung
in den ostdeutschen horizont am ehesten
nachvollziehbar aber muss natürlich
sehen die partei ist im osten durchaus
kompakt weil sie es in den landtagen
vertreten sie hat eine starke position
sie hat innerhalb der union und das ist
ja ein entscheidender punkt worüber man
sprechen muss wenn man über die zukunft
der afc im osten spricht unglaubliche
turbulenzen erzeugt weil hier doch
teilweise in den einzelnen landes fanden
bis zu ein drittel sind die sich
durchaus eine konstruktive
zusammenarbeit mit der afg vorstellen
können und insofern ist hier eine
unheilige milos entstanden für dieses
ostdeutsche parteiensystem und dann
kommt hinzu dieser denkt denkt der
ostdeutschen afd mit kubitschek der hat
natürlich auch eine wirkkraft die über
seminare rekrutierung hinausgeht oder
werden natürlich die leute dann auch zur
verfügung gestellt die in dem hinter
stuben der parlamente und des
parteiapparates wirken und das muss man
mit ins bild nehmen wenn man das ganze
bild für die afg entwickelt kubitschek
ist der ideologische büchsenspanner der
partei der hier im hintergrund wird
wachsen die bäume der afg vielleicht im
osten auch in den himmel dieser
partielle misserfolg beim ersten
wahlgang der kommunalwahlen wo die fdp
sich sehr viel mehr erhofft hat wenn es
um exekutive macht geht schrecken dann
auch als die wähler zurück absolut das
haben wir jetzt bei den landratswahlen
gesehen selbst dort wo sie eigentlich so
stimmungs gefühlsmäßig eine mehrheit für
sich reklamieren könnten bringen sie
nicht durch weil die leute am ende dann
doch überlegen sind sie wirklich in der
lage verantwortlich mit macht umzugehen
und dann kommt ein anderer punkt über
den wir auch nachdenken müssen die
stärke der afg ist gewachsen ich sag mal
zyklus der
soziokulturellen positionierung dieses
landes also basis nation was ist europa
wie wollen wir leben wie homogen oder
hetero gehend auf unsere gesellschaft
sein wo wir jetzt hinkommen es stärker
der sozioökonomische zug also
verteilungsfrage pore fragen wie kann
ich morgen mein leben organisieren wie
sind die energiekosten und da hat die
afg nichts beizutragen selbst wenn sie
hier große sprüche macht da es
letztendlich eine ganz andere
vorgehensweise verlangt und wir haben
das ja auch beim parteitag in kalkar
gesehen wo sie versucht haben die
soziale dimension dieses landes durch zu
buchstabieren und sie sind da eigentlich
nicht über eine pro seminar arbeit
hinaus gekommen das heißt es sind weit
entfernt von der frage wie kann man den
zusammenhalt in diesem lande ermöglichen
die kammern sozialer ausgleich
herstellen wie kann man die
wertschöpfung in diesem land so
organisieren dass sie innovative ist
dass die produktive sind dass sie
gerecht ist und das sind die fragen der
näheren zukunft und da ist die kfd
bestenfalls auf der zuschauertribüne
wolfgang schröder bis hierhin vielen
dank liebe zum student live zuschauer
der parteitag läuft weiter und wie es
jetzt weitergeht das sagt in dem boris
müller
vielen dank alexander ja wir sind mitten
in den wahlen aber achtung achtung es
geht noch nicht um die wahlen zum
bundesvorstand sondern zunächst runde
wahlen zum bundesschiedsgericht das
heißt es werden neue banner
schiedsrichter gewählt das ist auch
wieder ein verfahren in dem die
schiedsrichter kandidaten sich
vorstellen aus dem juristen sein und
rechter und werden dann gefragt auf der
bühne steht derzeit der nur wir martin
brauckmann vom landesverband sachsen er
ist bereits in der ersten kammer des
schiedsgerichts der afg und bewirbt sich
als erster bundes schied richter jetzt
für das an und ist gerade in seiner
bewerbungsrede oder einfach nur
schweigen dann erklären sie dass sie
jeden positiven fortschritt ablehnen und
einander wird da ja gar nicht mehr
diskutiert nicht mehr über den wichtigen
richtigen weg gestritten es wird mit
teuro wissenschaften die auch in die
richtung als alternativlos begründet so
soll es bei uns natürlich nicht sein wir
brauchen in deutschland eine
streitkultur das heißt zu hören ausreden
lassen verstehen nachdenken und erst
dann erwidern das lässt eine positive
frucht wachsen die bibel fordert auf der
eine achte den anderen höher als sich
selbst
das würde auch bei uns vieles verbessern
ich fordere zuvor zwei andere zur auf
streitigkeiten nicht nach außen zu
tragen und damit wir als einheit
dastehen können und glaubwürdigkeit
ausstrahlen leider haben sich da manche
protagonisten nicht daran gehalten
sondern oppositionsgruppen auch noch
gleich unterstellt sie könnten nicht
gerade ausdenken das ist das gegenteil
von achtung freunde unser fund ist die
glaubwürdigkeit die altparteien haben
hier weitestgehend verspielt man sieht
es an der wahlbeteiligung das ist unsere
chance nutzen wie sie besser als zuletzt
oder konnten wir die nichtwähler
motiviert wie zuvor mut zur wahrheit war
ein gutes motto unsere glaubwürdigkeit
beginnt bei uns selbst nur müssen wir
das auch konsequent leben und
transparent nach außen tragen
niemals darf es geschehen dass anspruch
und wirklichkeit so sehr auseinander
fallen wie ist das bei frau merkel
festgestellt hat im rahmen der tätigkeit
als schiedsrichter möchte ich auch so
weiter agieren
und
wenn ihr denkt das war glaubwürdig was
ich gesagt habe dann gebt mir eure
stimme doch kurz zu meiner person ich
bin 34 jahren mit ein und derselben frau
verheiratet habe zwei erwachsene kinder
und wohne in sachsen und das betrachte
ich aus tiefem herzen in meiner heimat
von beruf bin ich rechtsanwalt vor allem
im bereich bau und arbeitsreichen
zwischen ist nun beschlossene sache dazu
gekommen und jetzt stehe ich auch gerne
für fragen zur verfügung
vielen dank herr brauckmann
gibt es fragen an den kandidaten
bisher nicht möchte noch irgendjemand
eine karte einwerfen
ja
dann bitte bei lung
so wenn jetzt niemand mehr eine frage
einwerfen haben wir nur genau eine
oder gibt es mehr als eine
dann beende ich jetzt die möglichkeit
fragen anzumelden und der entsprechende
fragesteller darf dann auch ins mikrofon
30 sekunden braucht man als richter
sollte man ja auch immer flexibel sein
wenn ich vermisse bei ihrer vorbereitung
sind rede die antwort auf die pflicht
frage die wir zuvor erörtert haben
nämlich über den stand ihres dezernats
vielen dank dann hat jetzt der kandidat
wider das wort eine minute also zunächst
einmal die rede war eigentlich auf knapp
sechs minuten geteilt und das ist
durchgegangen also zurückliegende
verfahren ich hab's nicht exakt im kopf
ich glaube ich habe sieben offene
verfahren aber ganz sicher bin ich mir
nicht aber
man hat also weit mehr im jahr es ist
jetzt nicht der hit des jahres pensum
das liegt deutlich höher
vielen dank dann herr brockmann sind sie
mit dank entlassen meine damen und
herren wir kommen dann gleich zur wahl
in zwei minuten werden wir die türen
schließen bitte nehmen sie ihre plätze
ein wir werden dann gleich mit den
elektronischen stimmen geräten in
geheimer wahl abstimmen
so noch eine halbe minute
bis wir die türen schließen
so dann machen wir die türen jetzt bitte
zu es wird niemand mehr rein oder
rausgelassen und
die abstimmungs folie kann gerne
eingeblendet werden
wir wählen den ersten bundesrichter ich
weise sie übrigens darauf hin dass hatte
ich gerade falsch gesagt es sind nicht
vier bundes schiedsrichter zu wählen
sondern fünf das nochmals zu ihrer
information die wir auch in die erste
wahl antreten und sie haben bei der wahl
des ersten bundes schiedsrichters
folgende abstimmungs möglichkeiten sie
können herrn braucht man wählen dafür
drücken sie die eins sie können ihn
nicht wählen dafür drücken sie die 2
oder sie können sich der stimme
enthalten dafür drücken sie die 3 die
abstimmung ist eröffnet 40 sekunden
3210 die abstimmung ist geschlossen und
damit hat der kandidat die erforderliche
einfache mehrheit erreicht
herr brockmann nehmen sie ihre wahl an
erklärt ja herzlichen glückwunsch wir
fahren dann fort mit der wahl des
zweiten bundes schiedsrichters hierfür
nehme ich vorschläge an den saal
mikrofon entgegen
bitteschön am roten saal mikrofon
nicht schlager gereon goldmann vor
gibt es weitere vorschläge
so wenn es keine weiteren vorschläge
gibt
das kann ich jedenfalls nicht erkennen
derzeit
würde ich dann jetzt mit ihrer
zustimmung die kandidaten müsste
schließen wer ist für den schluss der
kandidatenliste
bitte
danke schön wer ist dagegen
er enthält sich dann ist die kandidaten
liste geschlossen herr baumann stehen
sie zur verfügung
war das ein jahr
ich gehe mal davon aus dass das hier ist
ein java okay dann herr bollmann darf
ich sie nach vorne bitten
vier minuten
so erfreuen dann darf ich sie fragen ob
sie die befähigung zum richteramt
besitzen ja die besitze ich und da sie
dem bundesschiedsgericht nicht angehören
erübrigen sich auch ausführungen zum
arbeitsstand im bundesschiedsgericht
unter ihrem dezernat sie haben dann
jetzt also vier minuten zeit um sich
vorzustellen bitteschön das habe ich
noch nicht ganz verstanden halten sie
über nochmal bitte an ich bin ja mit dem
schiedsgericht dann muss ich die frage
nicht beantworten deswegen kann er sagte
ich ja gerade das war das halt hier so
sehr frauen alles klar
meine damen und herren liebe
parteifreunde
viele von ihnen kenne ich noch nicht und
deshalb mal kurz eine vorstellung so am
rand ich war ja noch nicht im
bundesgericht
ich war 43 jahre im richterlichen dienst
in schleswig holstein tätig zuletzt 20
jahre am oberlandesgericht
bin jetzt seit zweieinhalb jahren im
wohlstand 20 16 in die partei
eingetreten
und ein halbes jahr später habe ich dann
schon das schicksal ereilt ich bin zum
vorsitzenden des landes schiedsgerichts
schleswig holstein gewählt worden was
sie für den fall meiner wahl heute
natürlich im stich lassen muss aber sei
es drum das ist halt so
ja
ich bin vater verheiratet vater von fünf
kindern dreifacher großvater das auch so
am rande
und sie wird sicherlich die frage
interessieren warum ich mich um eine
stelle im bunde schied krieg bewerbe
das ist eigentlich sehr schnell
beantwortet wir sind alle menschen in
dieser partei und ich glaube insoweit
kann ich hier einigkeit erzielen dass
unsere partei insgesamt
da besteht einigkeit momentan nicht nur
momentan sondern seit längerem an diesen
innerparteilichen konflikten leidet die
es in anderen parteien auch gibt aber
die eben immer wieder nach draußen
dringen und von daher schädlich sind
weil die presse natürlich nur die
negativen punkte aufgreifen
das liegt an uns selbst als menschen
jedes parteimitglied ist ein mensch wo
menschen miteinander handeln gibt es
konflikte die konflikte sind zu
schlichten was bietet sich am besten
dafür an als das recht das ist meine
devise
wir sind ja nicht wir sind kein
kaninchenzüchterverein sondern eine
politische partei und haben uns eine
satzung gegeben
und demnach ist in allererster linie
immer ein herausragendes
konfliktpotenzial die unterschiedliche
politische meinung
wenn dieser konflikt nicht gelöst werden
kann wird er natürlich zur verhärtung
führen dafür gibt es die schiedsgerichte
übrigen die uhr läuft hier nicht nur
also dann gibt's die schiedsgerichte
dafür
die das meine ich nicht mehr wie bis
dahin bis zur entstehung oder verhärtung
des konfliktes auf politischer ebene
lösen können dieses instrumentarium hat
versagt man braucht ein neues
instrumentarium ist momentan ist das
recht und wir haben eben in unserer
innerparteilichen verfassung gleichsam
das demokratieprinzip auch verankert
wenn sie so wollen ist der
bundesvorstand ist also die exekutive
wir alle wir sind im grunde das wahlvolk
wenn man so will und dann als dritter
tat das bundesschiedsgericht und auf
landesebene die landesschiedsgericht die
möglichst voneinander unabhängig sein
müssen und um diese unabhängigkeit
sicherzustellen muss man sich an das
recht wenden so habe ich mein bisheriges
amt verstanden die schleswig-holsteiner
kollegen kennen das auch was die arbeit
angeht ich habe also bei meinem antritt
vor fünfeinhalb jahren 80 verfahren
vorgefunden die mittlerweile auf einen
aktuellen bestand von fünf verfahren
zurückgeführt
ja ich finde hier nicht um komplimente
aber danke für die beifahrer das ist
natürlich ich habe das auch schon die
ersten vier jahre parallel zu meinem am
oberlandesgericht in schleswig gemacht
aber das ist eigentlich eine arbeit die
keinesfalls bedarf weil es natürlich als
früherer richter ein schneller von der
hand geht als anderen kollegen die man
nicht wegen als rechtsanwalt oder eben
noch nicht juristen unterwegs sind
zur inhaltlichen positionierung
vielleicht ich habe natürlich in den
fünf jahren auch gemerkt wieder
bundesvorstand noch unter führung seiner
zeit auch einige sachen politisiert hat
er hat also das bundesschiedsgericht
dann immer in zweiter instanz auch für
seine belange dienstbar gemacht und
dafür gesorgt dass unliebsame mitglieder
die partei verlassen mussten was immer
erforderlich ist wenn es die
satzungsbestimmung konnte sie bitte zum
schluss aber eben nur dann und nichts
sonst
vielen dank
gibt es fragen an herrn bäumer bisher
nicht nur irgend jemand eine frage
anmelden
das kann ich auch nicht erkennen herr
baumann sie sind dann mit dank entlassen
und dann meine damen und herren muss ich
noch etwas nachholen ich musste mich
fragen ob es noch fünf unterstützer für
ein boymann gibt
das ist der fall gut wunderbar
damit sie auch rechtskonformen
schiedsgericht kommen dann eventuell
wollmann ist das ja ganz gut und
insofern darf ich ihnen ankündigen dass
wir in zwei minuten die türen schließen
und dann über die zweite bundesrichter
position abstimmen werden
[Musik]
in zehn sekunden machen die die türen zu
3210 die türen werden bitte geschlossen
wunderbar die folie wird bitte
eingeblendet wir kommen jetzt zur wahl
der zweiten bundesrichter position sie
haben folgende abstimmungs möglichkeiten
1 gehören bollmann
293 enthaltung die abstimmung ist
eröffnet sie haben 40 sekunden
3210 die abstimmung ist geschlossen und
damit hat herr bollmann die einfache
mehrheit erreicht
herr baumann nehmen sie ihre wahl an
wo sind sie
sie nehmen ihre wahl an herzlichen
glückwunsch
so dann kommen wir zur wahl des dritten
bandes schiedsrichters hierfür nehme ich
ihre vorschläge an den seilen mikrofonen
entgegen
bitteschön
ja liebe versammlungsleitung ich habe
einen geschäftsordnungsantrag hab dann
bitte danke
möchte ganz gern das verfahren
beschleunigen mir erschließt sich nicht
warum wir vor jedem wahlgang zwei
minuten pause machen und dann die türen
erst schließen ich finde es auch
befremdlich und alle wissen dass wir
jetzt gerade den wahlgängen sind dass
man sich eine rede nicht anhört eines
kandidaten und dann rein stürmt und dann
seine stimme abgibt also ich denke das
ist nicht rund und beantrage hiermit
dass man nach 30 sekunden pause dann die
türen schließt und wie in den wahlgang
antreten können vielen dank
[Applaus]
gut also ich weiss nur darauf hin der
parteitag hatte zwei minuten am anfang
beschlossen wir halten es gleich wofür
zulässig das ist auf 30 sekunden gemäß
ihres antrages zu reduzieren wird hierzu
das wort gewünscht das kann ich nicht
erkennen doch bitte
die parteifreunde ungern widerspreche
ich dem freund
blöcke allerdings ich warne aufgrund
böse erfahrungen in sachsen davor das
wahlverfahren auch wenn es solch ein
detail betrifft innerhalb des verfahrens
zu ändern es sind jetzt zwei gewählt
worden und jetzt wird das geändert ich
empfehle daher zur vermeidung von
anfechtbarkeit das nicht zu machen
dankeschön
vielen dank dann lasse ich wenn es keine
weiteren wortmeldungen gibt über den
antrag abstimmen wer dafür ist dass die
zeit zum hereinkommen in den saal vor
einem wahlgang auf 30 sekunden reduziert
führt den bitte ich um das karten
zeichen
dankeschön wer ist dagegen
dafür oder
gut dann machen wir das bitte noch mal
wer ist dafür
danke schön wäre es dagegen
das machen wir mal bitte elektronisch
1 jahr 2013 enthaltung die abstimmung
ist eröffnet sie haben 30 sekunden
zehn sekunden
3210 die abstimmung ist geschlossen und
der antrag ist damit abgelehnt
wir kommen dann jetzt zur
kandidatenvorstellung für den
dritten bundesrichter meine damen und
herren und dementsprechend
darf ich sie darum bitten vorschläge zu
machen
im roten saal mikrofon möchte durch
jemand einen vorschlag machen
oder am blauen pardon
ich schlage annegret hama vor
frau heimischer wurde vorgeschlagen wird
dieser vorschlag von fünf
stimmberechtigten teilnehmern
unterstützt
das ist der fall gut gibt es weitere
vorschläge
das kann ich nicht erkennen dann meine
damen und herren würde ich mit ihrer
zustimmung die kandidatenliste schließen
wer ist für den schluss der
kandidatenliste
danke schön wer ist dagegen
wer enthält sich dann ist dies mit sehr
großer mehrheit so beschlossen also dann
frage ich die bereitschaft der
kandidaten zur kandidatur frau habe ich
aus stehen sie zur verfügung
ich höre nichts
sie stehen zur verfügung
wunderbar dann frau habe mich da darf
ich sie nach vorne bitten
frau habe ich ja ich muss sie zunächst
fragen ob sie die befähigung zum
richteramt besitzen
die habe ich ausdrücklich nicht weil ich
in der ddr nicht jura studieren durfte
und ich war ich war zwei jahre im
landesgericht niedersachsen bereit wir
haben nicht die befähigung zum
richteramt und dann
gehören sie ja derzeit der
bundesschiedsgericht an das ist richtig
ja dann dürfen sie sich auch gerne zum
arbeitsstand in ihrem entsprechenden
dezernat dann im rahmen ihrer rede
äußern kre minuten zeit bitteschön
tatsächlich habe ich
das jetzt nicht richtig im blick ich
weiß nur dass ich die ganze zeit
kontinuierlich arbeiten und habe das mir
auch noch von der leiterin der
geschäftsstelle bestätigen lassen also
ich bin fleißig und wie fleißig haben
wir jetzt umsetzen in dieser woche
gesehen denke ich
also ihre vorstellungs zeit läuft
soll ich noch sagen wirklich in einer
partei war
nein das müssen sie nicht sagen also es
können sie sagen es müssen sie aber
nicht sagen
sehr geehrte mitglieder des präsidiums
liebe delegierte und liebe gäste dieses
bundes parteitages liebe freunde ja und
die habe ich in dieser partei
tatsächlich gefunden ich habe hier echte
freunde gefunden das mag verwunderlich
sein aber bei den christen in der afc
bei der kraft
und besonders möchte ich die
medienvertreter begrüßen und ihnen
wünschen dass ihnen an diesem wochenende
weisheit und gelingen zu ihrer wichtigen
arbeit geschenkt wird und sie objektiv
berichten können
wenig aber zuerst ansprechen möchte das
bist du da vor dem bildschirm
bei web de la sich gestern die
überschrift ex kanzlerin angela merkel
war mit ihrem kommentar zur wahl tür und
so weiter mit stimmen rechtsextremen
partei zu weit gegangen es hat keine
konsequenzen
dieses rechtsextrem das ist mein punkt
ich möchte dir am fernseher am pc sagen
wer ich bin und ich kann sagen dass ich
aufgeben und orte der urteile dann
selbst ob ich rechtsextrem oder nazi bin
ich bin 1958 in der ddr geboren heute
ist das sachsen anhalt wegen eines
persönlich wegen meines persönlichen
glaubens an jesus christus wurde ich mit
17 jahren in einer festen marktgemeinde
getauft ich erkannte dass ich nicht
länger in der fdj der jugendorganisation
der sed und so meint der vor gut der
partei bleiben konnte und trat aus das
hatte zur folge dass ich trotz meiner
sehr guten schulischen leistungen wieder
pädagogik noch medizin und schon
garnicht tura studieren konnte bin ich
rechtsextrem
es gibt eine geschichte die mir zu
denken gibt und die daher passt wirft
man einen frosch in einen topf mit
heißem wasser
so versucht er sofort sich zu retten
wirft man das tier in lauwarmes wasser
wasser und er ist es langsam dann wollte
sich nicht und bleibt einfach sitzen bis
es schließlich verendet die begründung
der frosch hat die langsame erhitzung
nicht gemerkt und genau das ist es wie
ins heiße wasser geworfen werden und so
fühlen sich auch viele leute im osten
die jetzt als pak und nazi und
rechtsextreme bezeichnet werden es gibt
noch einen besonderen personenkreis auf
denen ich hinweisen möchte
ich kann leider nicht reden wenn sich
dazu ab gelähmt
das sind die menschen die nicht als
goldgräber nach der wende in den osten
kamen sondern beruflich oder der liebe
wegen und geblieben sind sie haben die
langsame erwärmung des wassers nun auch
hier mitbekommen
sie haben den zusammenhalt der menschen
im osten noch kennengelernt gespürt sind
aufgenommen werden und wollen nun auf
keinen fall dass diese entwicklung die
sie in ihrer alten heimat mit entsetzen
beobachten auch hier wirkt deshalb
treten afd mitglieder in den ost
bundesländern so vehement auf sie sind
sind sie deshalb rechtsextrem
nein es ist ganz einfach so dass sie den
unterschied kennen und wollen diese
entwicklung nicht und das will ich auch
nicht binnig rechtsextrem bin ich nah zu
sein und die die sich für ein normales
deutschland einsetzen sind es auch nicht
und an wie vor den fernsehern zeige ich
ihnen gehen sie in ihrem ort zu ihr zu
einem ansprechpartner und lesen und die
christen legen
jetzt für euch ihr lieben delegierten
ich stehe weiterhin zur verfügung
in die fdp spiele 2016 gekommen
letzteres letzter satz
wir wollen und werden ein positives
deutschlandbild vermitteln und das
werden wir deutschland aber normal
vielen dank
gibt es fragen an frau heimischer
es gibt eine frage möchte noch
irgendjemand eine frage anmelden das
kann ich nicht erkennen dann nehmen wir
die eine frage am roten saal mikrofon
entgegen bitteschön
ja hallo
haben sie am vergangenen
samstag in hannover zwei jahren wild
gesorgt dass die berliner delegierten
nicht zugelassen werden und dass dieses
urteil am donnerstag fallen wird
antwort
hat nicht gehört noch mal
haben sie bereits am vergangenen samstag
in hannover zu hören wild gesorgt dass
die berliner delegierten nicht
zugelassen werden und dass das urteil am
donnerstag gefällt wird kein handgeld
und auch nicht in hannover
vielen dank wenn das hier ist ihre
antwort war oder möchten sie weiter
ausführen
da okay gut dann sind sie mit duncan
lassen vorhaben nicht so dann
kündige ich ihnen an dass wir in zwei
minuten die türen schließen
noch eine halbe minute
und wir machen die tür zu den 10 9 8 7 6
5 4
3 2 1 0 die tür wird bitte geschlossen
sie ist noch nicht zu
jetzt gleich
ist sie zu und dann kommen wir jetzt zur
abstimmung meine damen und herren
stopp wird mir bedeutet ok kommen wir
noch nicht zur abstimmung
jetzt wunderbar dann kommen wir jetzt
zur abstimmung meine damen und herren
sie haben folgende abstimmungs
möglichkeiten für die wahl des dritten
bandes schiedsrichters 1 amerikanischer
293 enthaltung der wahlgang ist eröffnet
sie haben 40 sekunden
könnte bitte die abstimmungs folie
eingeblendet werden vielen dank
sie bekommen dann natürlich auch etwas
mehr zeit zur abstimmung die mich zehn
sekunden mehr
kannst du
fünf vier drei zwei eins null die
abstimmung ist geschlossen und
frau habe ich ja
hat die erforderliche einfache mehrheit
erreicht frau habe ich ja ich darf sie
fragen ob sie ihre wahl annehmen
daumen nach oben vielleicht
wunderbar herzlichen glückwunsch
so dann kommen wir jetzt zur wahl eines
vierten bundes schiedsrichters hierfür
nehme ich ihre vorschläge an den saal
mikrofonen entgegen
landsberg landesverband sachsen und die
schlage den roland ulbrich vor
sodann also nur zur erklärung mir würde
wurde gerade erklärt das irgendwie die
ukrainische flagge eingeblendet sei wenn
man mich sieht ich habe keinen einfluss
auf die dekoration die hinter mir ist
das nur zur klarstellung ich habe damit
nichts zu tun
nur dass sie das richtig einzuschätzen
wissen
dann hören wir frage ich es aber als
erstes ob es fünf unterstützer für ein
übrig gibt
so das ist der fall es gibt fünf
vorschläge so dann gibt es einen
weiteren vorschlag am rednerpult
ich schlage als schiedsrichter herrn dr
dickes aus bayern vor
vielen dank wird dieser vorschlag von
fünf stimmberechtigten delegierten
unterstützt
so das ist der fall dann kommt es auf
die kandidatenliste
gibt es weitere vorschläge
das scheint nicht der fall zu sein mit
ihrer zustimmung würde ich dann die
kandidatenliste schließen wir jetzt für
den schluss der kandidatenliste
danke schön wer ist dagegen
wer enthält sich dann ist dies mit
mehrheit so beschlossen und dann frage
ich die bereitschaft der kandidaten zur
kandidatur ab herr ulbrich stehen sie
zur verfügung steht zur verfügung herr
doktor titel stehen sie zur verfügung
steht auch zur verfügung dann würden wir
jetzt eine münze werfen um die
vorstellungs reihenfolge zu bestimmen
herr ulbrich ist kopf und headis ist
zahl
und die zahl ist gefallen also stellt
sich als erstes erdiges vor und dann
brechen ich darf ndr wichtiges nach
vorne bitten
so hätte sich darf sie fragen ob sie die
befähigung zum richteramt besitzen ja
die besitze ich haben sie bisher dem und
schiedsgericht angehört die
bundesgericht habe ich nicht angehört
dann müssen sie auch entsprechend nichts
zur arbeit ihres dezernats
bundesschiedsgericht berichten und haben
dann jetzt vier minuten zeit um sich
vorzustellen bitteschön
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
parteifreunde
hiermit bewerbe ich mich um einen platz
als richter im schiedsgericht
mein name ist es peter wittkes
65 jahre alt homogener volljurist
rechtsanwalt
richter am bayerischen
verfassungsgerichtshof
verheiratet zwei söhne
mit immer mehr bauchgrummeln und
verzweiflung noch römisch-katholisch
seit meinem eintritt in die partei im
jahre 2017 war ich vier jahre lang
mitglied des landes schiedsgerichts
bayern
dabei auch zwei jahre in der funktion
als dessen präsident
diese erfolgreiche vierjährige arbeit im
landesschiedsgericht möchte ich
fortsetzen und stehe für eine arbeit im
bsg nun mehr zur verfügung
damit will ich die partei in dieser
wichtigen internen funktion mit meiner
arbeit unterstützen und weiter
voranbringen
mit meiner früheren arbeit im
landesschiedsgericht und meiner
allgemeinen juristischen berufstätigkeit
bringe ich langjährige kenntnisse von
partei rechtlichen aspekten ein nach den
bisherigen vier jahren im lsg bringe ich
dafür mit kenntnisse im partei recht
erfahrung kontinuität gradlinigkeit und
berechenbarkeit kurzum herrschaft des
rechts und sonst nichts dafür stehe ich
mein motto ist immer geradeaus
[Applaus]
das bundesschiedsgericht ist ein
internes organ der gesamtpartei damit
einen teil der ganzen hfg familie mit
und durch meine arbeit im bsg diene ich
nicht nur dem bundesschiedsgericht
sondern der gesamtpartei sie meint sie
meine damen und herren sie die alle hier
und heute da sind die ihnen durch ihre
anwesenheit deutlich unerkennbar der
partei sie repräsentieren die herzkammer
der partei sie die mitglieder der partei
zeigen wo es lang geht das ist der kern
der botschaft der afd der einzelne der
freie deutsche bürger steht im
mittelpunkt mit ihrer wahl abstimmung
heute bestimmen sie wo und wie es weiter
geht und das ist gut so
mit meiner arbeit im
bundesschiedsgericht will ich dem ziel
der gesamtpartei dienen nämlich das land
wieder vom kopf auf die füße zu stellen
das recht muss herrschen
meinen teil will ich dazu beitragen aus
überzeugung und aus pflicht als
parteimitglied mut zur wahrheit
deutschland aber normal gott schütze
unser deutsches vaterland
danke
[Applaus]
vielen dank herr
doktor ditges gibt es fragen an den
kandidaten
fünf fragen möchten irgendjemand eine
frage anmelden
das kann ich nicht erkennen dann losen
wir jetzt drei fragesteller aus
die erste frage stellt wolfgang viele
die zweite frage stellt georg rock
die dritte frage stellte benjamin nolte
als erstes her viele
sind sie haben roten mikrofon
sind sie ja bitte
wolfgang wolfgang wille
bezirksvorsitzender afg oberbayern
beim bundesgericht gibt es
auch nach meinem wissen einen grossen
stau an noch nicht erledigten verfahren
jetzt waren sie herr dr diskus am
bayrischen landesschiedsgericht vier
jahre wie hat sich denn in ihrer zeit
dort die abarbeitung von fällen
entwickelt
antwort will ich gerne kurz darauf
antworten
dort wurde eben zeitgerecht gearbeitet
insbesondere eben auch bei allen
maßnahmen relativ zügig sehr zügig
innerhalb der üblichen drei vier fünf
tage dafür
am ende meiner amtszeit waren laufende
fälle 34 übrig alles andere war aber
abgearbeitet
vielen dank
als nächstes hat herr hock die
gelegenheit zur frage bitte vielen dank
mein name ist georg mitglied des
landesvorstandes bayern inzwischen zum
dritten mal sehe eine doktortitels ich
habe gehört man hätte ihre tätigkeit ab
landesschiedsgericht als anführer eines
exekutionskommando gegen missliebige
mittlere sex flügels bezeichnet können
sie dazu stellung nehmen
manfort
was andere sagen oder tun entzieht sich
meiner kenntnis david dazu kann ich gar
nicht sagen das sind halt die abfällige
bemerkungen lieb und nett das müssen die
mit sich ausmachen die derartiges von
sich geben und
die letzte frage stellt herr nolte am
roten saal mikrofon
benjamin heute ebenfalls mit im
landesvorstand bayern allerdings erst
zum zweiten mal herr dr dickes in ihrer
amtszeit als präsident des landes
schiedsgerichts haben sie den heutigen
präsidenten des landes schiedsgerichts
den kollegen lienhard des amtes enthoben
das waren jetzt nämlich dubiose
geschichte und dieser entscheidung ist
ja sogar vor bundesschiedsgericht auch
zehn sekunden vom bundesschiedsgericht
kassiert worden also was wollen sie
jetzt hier in diesem gremium war jedoch
offensichtlich sich mit der satzung und
schiedsgerichtsordnung nicht so sicher
sind
antwort
herr nolte sie sprechen die dinge an die
sind gerichtsinterne sie werden
sicherlich verständnis dafür haben dass
ich
in interner nicht nur außen trage
sondern mich an recht und gesetz halte
vielen dank herr doktor dickes sie sind
mit dank entlassen als nächstes stellt
sich herr ulbrich vor
guten tag herr ulbrich auch sie darf ich
zunächst fragen ob sie die befähigung
zum richteramt besitzen ja ich besitze
ich gehörten sie bisher den
bundesschiedsgericht an ich bin ersatz
schiedsrichter
sie hörten also noch an ersatz
schiedsrichter okay aber damit gehörten
sie ja nicht dem bundesgericht im
bundesstaat arbeiten okay dann ist das
klar dann müssen sie auch nicht darauf
eingehen wie der arbeit stand ist und
entsprechend haben sie dann jetzt vier
minuten zeit um sich vorzustellen
bitteschön meine damen und herren liebe
parteifreunde
interessant dass ich hier in der
situation auf herrn dr
dies stoße wir sind schon miteinander
konfrontiert gewesen auch in der
schiedsgerichtsbarkeit ich als
verteidiger
meiner mandanten und herr dr als richter
also so haben wir uns jetzt einer
anderen konfrontation nun wieder
getroffen nun zu meiner rede wo recht zu
unrecht wird wird widerstand zur pflicht
und wird und für diesen widerstand ist
es höchste zeit ich spreche hier nicht
nur von den unhaltbaren zustände in
unserem land von denen es mehr als genug
gibt sondern auch leider von den
systemkonformen ansätzen in unserer
partei die leider immer mehr zu nehmen
das müssen wir dringend ändern um für
die wähler wieder glaubwürdig zu werden
mein name ist roland ulbrich 61 jahre
verheiratet seit 1992 in leipzig
rechtsanwalt mit eigener kanzlei
fachanwalt für strafrecht
2013 die afg eingetreten bin ich seit
2009 10 abgeordneter im sächsischen
landtag und stadtrat in leipzig im
landesverband sachsen wurde in das amt
des landes schiedsrichters gewählt habe
ich eben schon erwähnt
liebe freunde wir leiden in deutschland
unter unzähligen problemen vor allem
unter dem dass geltendes recht nicht
mehr durchgesetzt wird und wir sind als
partei- mal angetreten weil es anders
sein sollte erinnert sich jemand noch
dunkel an diesen hehren vorsatz wir
wollten anders sein weil das in unserem
land dringend nötig ist aber dennoch
haben wir uns im laufe der jahre
schleichend in eine richtung entwickelt
die nicht gut ist die partei mit ihren
vielen engagierten basismitglieder nicht
unser image nicht und dem land und
seinen menschen erst recht nicht
mittlerweile wird die partei
überschwemmt von vielen phv
parteiausschlussverfahren das
parteiordnungsverfahren
und anderweitig missliebige mitglieder
für diskreditieren oder ganz loszuwerden
man kann
man kann sich heute bereits ein pkv
anfangen wenn man sich für den dexxit
ausspricht 1 der teil unseres
parteiprogramms ist kontakt kontakt
schuld ein weiterer irrsinn der immer
mehr um sich greift wie zb die teilnahme
an einem ferienlager vor gründung der
afd
[Applaus]
tatsache ist die meinungsdiktatur die
werde im system vorwerfen hat sich
leider auch bei uns breit gemacht und
lähmt uns in unserem handeln
deshalb wird es mit mir als
bundesrichter keine bav orgien mehr
geben
[Applaus]
ein parteiausschluss ist das schärfste
schwert was wir besitzen und das sollte
nur im äußersten notfall eingesetzt
werden wer ständig angst hat von unseren
gegnern als rechts was auch immer das
heißen mag verunglimpft zu werden sollte
sich eine andere partei suchen
eine partei die eine ernst zu nehmende
opposition sein will darf keine angst
davor haben anzuecken wenn wir von
unseren gegnern gelobt werden haben wir
etwas falsch gemacht vielen dank für
eure aufmerksamkeit
gibt es fragen an den kandidaten
ulbrich
eine bisher möchte noch irgendjemand
eine frage stellen
das kann ich nicht doch ja ist das eine
zusätzliche frage oder sind sie der
fragesteller
okay gut ich weiß noch einmal darauf
hinweisen es da jetzt irgendwie bewegung
gibt also um eine frage anzumelden
müssen sie die karte auch einwerfen wenn
sie sich jetzt nur ein anstellen ist das
nicht ausreichend
das habe ich schon gedacht genau
möchten sie dann noch eine karte
einwerfen oder lassen sie es dann sein
ja dann warten wir noch einen moment
dann haben wir jetzt zwei karten ja
parteitag pur ohne debatte und natürlich
mit debatte aber entschuldigung ohne
kommentar wir wollten ihnen dieses
rohmaterial oder dieses unkommentierte
stück von einem parteitag der art bieten
für alle die sich jetzt gerade jetzt
noch zu schalten ganz kurz der überblick
die partei hat noch nicht zu den wahlen
zum bundesvorstand begonnen begonnen hat
aber die wahl der insgesamt fünf bundes
schiedsrichter die neu gewählt werden
wollen und vier davon erziehungs weise
der vierte ist gerade im wahlverfahren
mit dabei das ist herr roland ulbrich
einen rechtsanwalt aus sachsen und er
ist zu einem landesschiedsgericht von
sachsen
die
fünf bundesrichter werden neu gewählt
und jetzt geht es um die fragen die an
ihn gestellt werden von den saal mit
gefunden
wer einen moment bitte meine damen und
herren wir müssen uns darauf
verständigen dass wir uns nicht
gegenseitig aus wir hören uns jedes
stimmberechtigten delegierten in ruhe an
und ziehen unsere schlüsse dann bei der
wahl vielen dank und er ist dürfen sie
vor zusätzlicher über 35 jahre lang
richter zuletzt direktor des
amtsgerichts 15 jahre schöffengericht
nicht weiß wovon ich rede mir auch als
ein heimschiedsrichter
vorsitz in dieser allgemeinheit phv
augen vorzuwerfen sie müssen jetzt eine
frage stellen absolut unwürdig sind sie
bereit noch irgendwie sachlich zur
arbeit ferien angriffs barkeit sich zu
äußern
herr förster
ein
parteiausschlussverfahren wird von einem
vorstand eingeleitet
der das einfache mitglied hat gar nicht
das recht dazu und naja das gericht muss
dann damit leben und kann die anträge
abweisen was ich natürlich kritisch sehe
ist der versuch politische probleme
nicht politisch sondern juristisch zu
lösen und das ist der die kritik an den
vorständen nicht an dem schiedsgericht
vielen dank herr ulbrich sie sind mit
dank entlassen meine damen und herren
wir werden dann in zwei minuten die
türen schließen und zur wahl kommen
so das war aber nicht der haben es ja
mit krieg das war nicht der einzige
kandidat für die wahl des 14 bundes
schiedsrichter sondern auf den
vorschlagslisten steht für diese wahl
auch noch peter dicks das heißt es wird
eine stichwahl geben es reicht die
einfache mehrheit der anwesenden
delegierten der saal hat sich nach oder
mit beginn der wahl nach der
satzungsdebatte um die frage wieviel
bundessprecher will die partei künftig
haben ein wenig gelehrt das hängt aber
auch damit zusammen dass es in so war
dass die tagesordnung debatte sehr sehr
lange gedauert hat weil man doch sehr
viele debatten punkte hatte um die frage
wann reden wir über was und wie reden
wir über was feststeht dass das thema
kernenergie ist fasse ich jetzt noch mal
zusammen als thema behandelt wurde da
geht es um die resolution und die
haltung der partei zum bau neuer
kernkraftwerke
und zur frage eines atomaren endlagers
dann gab es die satzungsdebatte
vorab natürlich die frage wie und
welches gerüst sich die partei für diese
tagesordnung gibt die ist dann
schlussendlich geklärt wurden nach
ungefähr zweieinhalb stunden debatte und
dann gab es die frage bundes
satzungsänderungen zur neuwahl von
bundessprecher geeinigt hat sich die
partei auf einen antrag von birke
nämlich der dass der bundesparteitag und
der bundesvorstand sprecherposten auf
ein oder zwei begrenzt wird also die
bisherige satzung formel 2 oder 3 wird
es künftig nicht mehr geben oder gibt es
nicht mehr dieser kostenlos mehr ist
das wichtigste in aller kürze und die
wahl der bundesrichter ist ja nicht ganz
uninteressant weil genau diese bundes
schiedsrichter sich zusammensetzen um
über parteiausschlüsse zu reden und da
geht es auch immer darum dass die
jeweiligen strömungen ihre leute
natürlich in diese schiedsgerichte
schicken wollen damit sie sozusagen
mäßig allerdings natürlich
logischerweise als prämie immer
unabhängig aber
derartig
unabhängig aber trotz alledem strömungs
ausgerichtet über diverse geschichten
entscheiden soll so hat auch das
bundesschiedsgericht jetzt noch für
diesen parteitag entschieden dass der
landesverband berlin mit seinen 24
delegierten nicht antreten darf und
lediglich als gast diesen parteitag
besuchen darf so die abstimmung
elektronisch läuft in der frage wie und
wer gestaltet den bundes den vierten
bundesrichter bei der afg und da werden
wir jetzt gleich
fünf vier drei zwei eins null der beiden
ist geschlossen und
ich
damit ist der kandidat aus sachsen
erster kandidat roland ulbrich die
erforderliche einfache mehrheit erreicht
hat er übrig nehmen sie ihre wahl an
herzlichen glückwunsch herr ulbrich wir
kommen dann zur wahl des fünften bundes
schied richters hierfür nehme ich ihre
vorschläge an den mikrofonen entgegen
das wird dann auch die letzte wahl des
bundes schiedsrichtergespann es sein
dass neu zu besetzen ist in seiner
satzung hat sich ja auch ich lag der
bundesparteitag daher entschieden dass
unter schiedsrichter und ersatz
schiedsrichter
gleichzeitig ihre arbeit aufnehmen
sollen jeweils zum ersten januar des
kommenden jahres
golombek golombek golombek golombek okay
gibt es weitere vorschläge
ja
bitte schön
doktortitel
so ehe ich das wieder vergessen gibt es
fünf unterstützer für ein comeback
das ist der fall gibt es fünf
unterstützer für ein doktor dickes
auch das ist der fall gut
nur mit diesen fünf unterstützern darf
sich jemand zur wahl stellen die müssen
weit namentlich genannt sein
das ist nicht der fall dann würde ich
mit ihrer zustimmung die kandidaten ist
zu schließen wer ist für den schluss der
kandidatenliste
danke schön wer ist dagegen
wer enthält sich dann ist die kandidaten
liste
geschlossen
meine damen und herren dann frage ich
die bereitschaft der kandidaten zur
kandidatur ab herr golombek stehen sie
zur verfügung
ich habe nichts vernommen
sie stehen zur verfügung ok und herr dr
ditges stehen sie zur verfügung stehen
auch zur verfügung
dann ist der einzige kandidatin sich
hier noch vorstellen kann herrn golombek
den ich nach vorne bitte
roland golombeck
aus görlitz
so guten tag herr golombek verfügen sie
über die befähigung zum richteramt
über verfügen sie über die befähigung
zum richteramt nein
also sagen sie das noch mal ruhig ins
mikrofon rein kurz
also sie haben sagen sie einfach nein
ins mikrofon ein wunderbar und dann
abgehörten sie dem bundesschiedsgericht
bisher
nicht dann müssen sie auch nichts zu
einer etwaigen arbeit und wohnen
schiedsgericht berichten und dann haben
sie jetzt vier minuten zeit um sich
vorzustellen bitteschön
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
mitstreiter kurz zu meiner person ich
heiße roma in colombo bin 45 jahre jung
verheiratet stolzer vater von zwei
hübschen töchtern
nach meiner schulischen ausbildung
erlernt ich den beruf eines koches und
leistete nach erfolgreicher
berufsausbildung meinen wehrdienst ab
1998 trat ich in den dienst der
bundeszollverwaltung
wo ich im jahre 2000 meinen weiteren
bildungsweg mit auszeichnung absolvierte
bis zum mai 2004 wirklich so dann in den
bereichen des grants soll die nächstes
mit all seinen facetten
mit der eu-osterweiterung
veränderten sich meine einsatzorte und
fachgebiete er schickte mich in die
bekämpfung der illegalen beschäftigung
vom streifendienst bis hin zur betreuung
von komplexen ermittlungsverfahren in
der organisierten
wirtschaftskriminalität
auch zeitweilig abstecher in die
überwachung des flughafen verkehrs
durfte ich durchleben
eine spezialisierung erfolgt im rahmen
einer sängerischen laufbahn des weiteren
mit einer erfolgreichen ausbildung zum
einsatz trainer
über ein jahrzehnt durfte ist so
nachwuchskräfte
schülerpraktikanten
auf ihren wegen begleiten und erfahrenen
haudegen
techniken und regeln zur bewältigung des
in der tat nicht immer ungefährlichen
dienst alltages lehrern verinnerlichen
und automatisieren zuletzt wurde ich mit
der beendigung meines dienstes im
vollzug in der verwaltung eingesetzt und
bearbeitete dort mit der anderen
beihilfe angelegenheiten und
reisekostenrecht man erkennt also ich
habe in meinem bisherigen leben diverse
rechtsgebiete durchlebt und bin
jederzeit bereit mich und neuer
einzuarbeiten
gesetze verordnungen satzung et cetera
sind dabei nicht mit berührungsängsten
behaftet so weit so gut liebe freunde in
meinen adern
der name sagt es fließt das blut eines
kalender ex dreier stolze nation
deutschland tschechien polen
mein herz schlägt für ein europa der
vaterländer
und genau deshalb
ist milch mit dem indikator meiner
beruflichen erlebnisse im jahr 2014 im
januar in die afg wo ich ebenfalls in
vieler hinsicht erfahrungen kompetenzen
erlangen durfte
und genau deshalb stehe ich heute für
euch ich möchte unsere gemeinsame sache
auf diese art und weise mit herzblut im
bunde schiedsgericht weiter unterstützen
meine erfahrung aus meiner arbeit den
parteivorständen ausschüssen stadt so
die kreistagsfraktionen werde ich
einbringen gewiss allerhand dazulernen
und das mag aus zu sein denn eines tages
möchte ich mit euch gemeinsam feiern
sagen können wir haben zusammen den
teufel aus der heute geschlagen und
unser wunderschönes deutschland vor dem
verenden gerettet wir haben zusammen
dass fahrer europa mit gestaltet ein
europa souveräner nationalstaaten die in
friedlicher koexistenz
harmonieren die festung europa befreit
vom joch der europäischen union
liebe freunde dafür brauche ich euer
vertrauen dafür werbe ich um eure stimme
wenn ihr möchtet gibt mir die chance und
das vertrauen ich werde nicht weisen
abschließend ich habe in meinem leben
jedes gelöbnis jeden alt in meinem leben
auf unser vaterland stets mit glaubens
vor mir gesprochen das tue ich hier
heute wieder für unsere gemeinsame sache
bis zum letzten atemzug so wahr mir gott
helfe vielen dank mit patriotischen
grüßen
soweit die bewerbungsrede dessen nicht
touristen
golombek
und es ist zeit vielleicht für ein
zwischenfazit am set von alexander
keller
ja und dieses zwischenfazit werde ich
nicht alleine ziehen sondern mit
bewährten kräften mit ann kathrin müller
vom spiegel oder alexander kissler oder
neuen zürcher zeitung ja wir sind noch
gar nicht durch am ersten tag wir warten
mit spannung auf die neuwahl der
parteispitze angefangen mit den zweiten
bundessprecher der sprecherin wie es
aussieht kann man schon trotzdem
irgendeine tendenz erkennen herr müller
was das ich heute bisher zu tragen hat
oder ist das doch noch alles vor spiel
und man weiß nicht so genau wo es
hingeht es ist schon ein vorspiel weil
es natürlich bislang in den abstimmungen
meistens darum gehen was jetzt auf der
tagesordnung stehen soll das heißt nicht
unbedingt dass die leute dann auch so
entscheiden wie bei diesem ersten
abstimmung
aber man kann schon sehen dass jemand
sehr viel unterstützung hier erfährt
also er ist sowieso sehr aktiv aber er
hat auch schon mehrere dinge
durchgebracht und das mit einer
ordentlichen mehrheit wie lässt sich
diese rolle von hawke jetzt was wir
heute gesehen haben
sehen dass in dresden war ja auch sehr
aktiv beim wahlparteitag für die
bundestagswahl da hat er ja noch in
seinem sinne eine ganze reihe von
wichtigen positionen gedreht zum
beispiel den text also raus aus der
europäischen union obwohl sich
eigentlich eine andere mehrheit
angedeutet hat ist
heute zurück nachdem er zum beispiel in
kalkar bei dem großen auftritt von
leuten die eigene partei daran
attackiert hat ja überhaupt nicht zu
sehen war ja kalkar war der letzte große
siegte sogenannten bürgerlich liberalen
lagers sind allerdings hier schon eine
gemischte bilanz von hätte er hatte
gleich am anfang relativ am anfang das
wort ergriffen wollte haben dass der
ansatz eine der antrag eine
programmkommission einzurichten
vorgezogen wird darin ist er gescheitert
nicht durchgesetzt hat er sich auch mit
dem antrag herrn kalbitz von einem
auftrittsverbot zu befreien relativ
knapp aber er hat verloren ungefähr 54
durchgesetzt hat er sich mit dem von ihm
unterstützten auch präsentierten antrag
dass es künftig die möglichkeit geben
soll auch ein einzige person an die
spitze zu stellen also die formulierung
zwei oder drei wurde geändert zu einer
oder zwei bundessprecher das ist schon
ein durchaus ein erfolg für ihn aber es
klingt nicht alles eben hat er jetzt
eine wahl zur verlängerung zur
verkürzung der pausen knapp verloren als
die partei bleibt gespalten hätte ist
aktiver als sonst manches gelingt ihm
aber nicht alles
der antrag zur calbe zwar nicht von ihm
sympathisieren machthaber gelaufen und
hat durch gebracht was trinkt ist sehr
wichtig ist dass sich damit befasst wird
ob man so eine kommission einrichten
soll die die parteistruktur reform
angeht
und da hat er ja offenbar auch
kommissionen drauf dann damit zu wirken
insofern hat er da auch einen musik
herum dann nehme ich das jetzt gleich
mal als stichwort diese partei
strukturreform die er dadurch ziel als
vorsitzender dieser kommission was im
schilde es sagt ja man müsse die partei
professionalisieren politische vorhaben
konkretisieren vielleicht auch mit einer
ganzen reihe von hauptamtlichen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern was
steckt eigentlich dahinter dass gerade
gern hatte das so forciert also ich
glaube dass das sein versuch ist um
jetzt zu zeigen dass er eben diese dinge
angeht das sind themen die er schon
länger hat auch die nachwuchsförderung
die dieser kommission an sozusagen
anheizen will und besser machen und
wenn er dann diese kommission zum
beispiel leiten wurde oder damit
arbeiten würde könnte er nach zwei
jahren natürlich sagen so wir haben hier
die perfekten vorschläge wer das
durchsetzen will der braucht mich als
parteichef und es sind alles themen wie
die basis interessieren dürfte das heißt
es sind sozusagen kernanliegen der ard
wie man sie zumindest früher formuliert
hätte insofern ist das natürlich eine
gute band leitet er den seinen eigenen
weg an die spitze der partei er hat ja
vorhin wir haben auch schon angesprochen
zukunft ein oder zwei bundessprecher
sprecherinnen an der spitze stehen hat
er ja wörtlich gesagt bei der
vorstellung ich bin übrigens dieses mal
noch für zwei bundessprecher beim
nächsten mal aber dann für einen war das
ein klarer fingerzeig was er im schilde
führt einerseits sitzt mit dem was
katrin müller gesagt hat mit den mit der
programmarbeit oder mit der
programmstruktur reform genauer gesagt
und auf der anderen seite seine
persönlichen ambitionen
bisher war ja auf bundes- verzeiht das
muss man sagen er hat die offene
auseinandersetzung auf eine abstimmung
gescheut wollte hinter den kulissen
mehrheiten für sich zusammen schaffen
was man geklappt hat mal nicht diese
programmkommission hat natürlich
insofern an einen produktiven sinn als
sie ihn gehen gehen wird zur
professionalisierung auf bau von
bildungszentren von schulungsmaßnahmen
das braucht natürlich eine junge partei
wie die afg immer da werden auch
verschiedene lager natürlich zustimmen
andererseits hätte diese
programmkommission zumindest im
vorliegenden text auch gewisse
durchgriffsmöglichkeiten hin zum
vorstand könnte gewissermaßen lungen
durchsetzen also er ist besteht die
gefahr dass wenn ein sehr machtbewusster
mensch das ist ja herr höcker ein
machtbewusster mensch an die spitze
geräte dass so ein gerät dass ich so
eine art zweites parteizentrale dort
bilden würde und das wird natürlich
fatal aus sicht der partei wenn man
einerseits vielleicht eine strengere
formierung hat eine spitze der partei
aber so einen neben apparat an macht
ähnliches hat auch nach erneuten mal
probiert ist damit gescheitert also das
ist ja schon eine entsprechend stoffe
die partei wenn diese kommission mit
dieser machtfülle oder macht
konzentrierung von herrn brücke geleitet
würde vor allen dingen weil der leiter
dieser kommission auch angedockt sein
soll an den bundesvorstand und sie
finanzielle mittel bekommen soll also
tatsächlich ein instrument was durchaus
einfluss habe es wäre kein
unverbindliches think tank bis war ein
paar tage später denkt mal darüber nach
wo holen wir den hintertreffen uns im
kreis das wissen auch ein machtbasis das
heißt wie ein höcker will eigentlich
einen parteitag ein wahlparteitag
sturmreif schießen dass er ihnen wählt
ohne dass er jetzt das risiko eingeht
alexander kissler hat gesagt er war viel
zu feige dazu das risiko einzugehen da
eine niederlage zu erleiden er bzw ich
glaube es so taktisch auch ein bisschen
feige aber vor allen dingen ist glaube
ich seine erzählungen ja er kommt wohin
und alle feiern ihnen das heißt er kann
keine klassische kampfkandidatur machen
wo er dann mit knapp 52 prozent oder so
gewinnt sondern eher brauchen ergebnis
von 70 8 prozent oder so und das muss
man natürlich vorbereiten das würde bei
der partei die sie jetzt heute hier die
delegierten gestellt hat noch nicht
funktioniert es gab auch viele
gegenstimmen gegen ihn wurde gesagt
haben also es gibt zwei menschen hier
wie herr hüppe die halten sich für den
alleinigen hals bringen aber wir sind
der demokratische partei bei uns gibt es
keine springer und man hat auch gemerkt
hat seinen reden gab es jetzt nicht
tosendem beifall und kann es den
innovations- also man hört ihm zu weil
der professionelle auftritt weil der
thüringische landesverband relativ gut
dasteht aber ich spüre jetzt hier nicht
eine sehnsucht gesamtpartei
sicherheitslücke zu unterstellen
gerade läuft ja die wahl zum
bundesgericht das ist er hat ja eine
wichtige funktion gerade bei den fragen
von
parteiausschlussverfahren da gab es eine
ganze reihen der afd ist diese wahl
jetzt verlaufen wer kommt da rein wirkt
da reinpasst es in den ganzen kontext
dessen was wir gerade schon besprochen
haben dass sich die partei neu
ausrichtet sich neu erfindet eine partei
neuen typs vielleicht sogar wirklichen
typs also es war auf jeden fall so dass
die partei unzufrieden war mit dem
letzten runde schiedsgericht bzw ein
bestimmter teil der partei nämlich eher
der und um hüppe weil man das gefühl
hatte dass das bundesschiedsgericht dazu
durch bleibt und jetzt hier eben jemand
gesagt er möchte diese ausschluss orgien
beenden und es gewählt worden und da
gab's danach lautet für jugend laut ist
jubelrufe im saal insofern kann man das
schon so sehen dass das sich politisiert
hat und offensichtlich auch erfolgreich
das finde ich eigentlich schon sie waren
laufen ja noch hier gerade weil das
fünfte im bunde schiedsrichter aber noch
sehr viel für ein fahrzeug aber als
beobachter für die es schon sehr
bemerkenswert oder irritieren das
natürlich eine rechtsstaatspartei die
dia sein will
eine derart politisierung des
bundesschiedsgerichts also der inneren
gerichtsbarkeit zuletzt also die leute
bewerben sich hierfür ein
bundesschiedsgericht posten mit aus
ihrer sicht lauterer sinn um einer sagte
eben wir haben die gefahr dass wir zu
systemkonform werden was ist denn das
für eine aussage für jemand der
eigentlich sachlich neutral nach partei
gerichtlichen kriterien entscheiden soll
also diese extreme politisierung der
inneren schiedsgerichtsbarkeit finde ich
schon sehr irritierend zeigt mal wieder
dass die fdp meines erachtens kein
rechtsstaat partei ist das heißt also
muss auch damit rechnen dass in zukunft
dieses bundesschiedsgericht das ja eine
durchaus unabhängige funktion in der
parteisatzung in verteilten statut haben
soll möglicherweise gar nicht mehr so
unabhängig ist na ja da muss man schon
mal abwarten wer alles noch gewählt
werde ich habe jetzt auch nicht alle
verfolgen haben sie mein fazit ziehen
könne gerne wieder hier machen aber die
tatsache dass natürlich für eine
juristische position im politischen
weltanschauung vorträgen bewerten das
für die schon eine vermischung der
kategorien die nicht guttut
gab es offensichtlich eine große
verärgerung auch über die arbeit des
bundesschiedsgerichts bisher ist das
sozusagen jetzt die reaktionen darauf
also die tatsache dass die reden sind
politisch sind wieder kissler sagt zeigt
ja dass es offensichtlich den wunsch
gibt beziehungsweise auch da eben diese
verschiedenen lagern sich wiederfinden
wollen und dementsprechend dann auch
ihre leute was tatsächlich kurios ist
wenn man eigentlich gute juristen
einfach nur da haben will die eben nach
rechtlichen kriterien entscheiden ob man
ein ausschuss angehen sollte aber nicht
zb
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe man
sind kann die richtige richtung sein das
sieht richtig er ist ja vielleicht kein
zufall das gespräch dauert jetzt schon
einige minuten dass das gar nicht der
name kilo kubala gefallen ist der
parteichef der im moment einzige der das
auch wieder werden möchte ist das jetzt
ein zufall dass wir den gar nicht so im
auge haben was wird aus ihm eigentlich
naja also nach wie vor ist der große
favorit für die wahl des 1
von beiden bundessprecher nicht glaube
nicht dass der kleine wächter oder her
kleiner ist der erste bekannte
gegenkandidatin der welt streitig machen
können aber ich denke nicht dass es ihm
gelingen wird sein komplettes tableau
durchzubekommen ich glaube es wird heute
weder in der ökopartei rauskommen noch
nachschub aller parteien aber brutaler
wird hoch wahrscheinlich bestätigt im
amt und er macht es gewissermaßen auf
auf leisen pfoten momentan ist seine
devise eigentlich keine experimente volk
minar also eine gewisse beruhigung nach
innen um dann zu schauen wie man sich
wirklich neu aufstellt insofern müssen
wir wirklich mal gucken am samstag ob es
am ende wirklich eine richtungswahl war
oder ob da vielleicht doch nicht
verschoben worden ist einfach sagt
erstmal so weiter im gewohnten tritt und
schauen was sich ergibt wenn ich das
jetzt richtig in erinnerung dass roth
morgen zwar den parteitag eröffnet hat
aber seit der zeit eigentlich nicht mehr
in erscheinung die welt ist er hält sich
vornehm zurück kann ja sehr entspannt
gucken was passiert weil er sicherlich
einen der sprecher kosten bekommen wird
würde mich zumindest sehr wundern wenn
nicht und dann ist für ihn eigentlich
eher wichtig was danach passiert und
dann wird er vielleicht eher in die bütt
steigen als jetzt aber muss ja gleich
wieder reden um die bilanz zu setzen und
das gehört aber zu den abend das ist
geradeaus läuft und ab läuft er kann es
sein dass er sich zurückgehalten hat
gerade darum seine wiederwahl nicht zu
gefährden denn er hätte ja heute auch
mehrmals das wort ergreifen ja ich
glaube er hätte sie gar nicht so richtig
gefährden können es gibt halt kaum
alternativen und die die antreten
ansonsten die sind als nicht gut
gelitten in der partei das muss man
einfach so sagen also ein norbert klein
lichter hat zum beispiel in brandenburg
alles was er jemals versucht hat wofür
er mehrheiten haben wollte ihn nicht
durchbekommen ist natürlich auch ein
schwieriger landesverband mit ehemals
samt seiner spitze aber
hat sich da viele feinde gemacht und
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass er hier
wirklich eine große chance hat sehen wir
denn jetzt hier eine schleichende
entmachtung der west landesverbände afd
die ja auch wenig geliefert haben bei
den letzten landtagswahlen ist das auch
so eine tendenz die man vielleicht auch
spürt der westen ist zumindest ich
kampagnenfähig ich mein nrw ist glaube
ich hier mit 90 delegierten vertreten
ist ja schon ein pfund das ist ja
deutlich mehr als thüringen
beispielsweise die hier präsenter wirken
durch äußerungen des klatschens und so
der westen ist auf jeden fall in der
größeren die identitätskrise aufgrund
schlechter wahlergebnisse niedersachsen
wenn sie vermutlich auch nicht reisen
schließlich deutschland sind sie
rausgeflogen man kann eigentlich nur auf
beiden sicht hoffen dass man
gewissermaßen einen stellungskrieg
momentan beendet indem man die stellung
hält dass man sagt dass sie im westen
mal weitermachen und wir im westen sind
bereit dafür im gegenteil der fall in
anführungszeichen zu ertragen wie gesagt
entscheidend wirklich sagen ob es diese
kommission mit herrn hüppe an der spitze
geben denn dann müssen wir die debatte
habe ich nochmal führen kann es sein
dass die afg so wie sie jetzt auf stritt
oder wie sie sich gerade entwickelt wie
sie aktuell da steht in den meisten
westlichen bundesländern gar nicht mehr
vermittelbar ist jedenfalls mit einer so
großen anzahl von wählerinnen und wähler
dass die partei da noch eine rolle
spielt also meiner meinung nach und das
zeigen ja auch studien gibt es eben in
deutschland ein potenzial von 10 bis 15
prozent mit von menschen mit
rassistischen einstellungen und wenn die
sich eine partei auswählen sollen dann
kommen sie halt awp die afg insofern
wird es auch in west
natürlich noch dazu kommen dass sie die
fünf-prozent-hürde schaffen wie groß das
potenzial ich würde sagen immer so bis
rund zehn prozent schätzt schon ein vor
allen dingen wenn es noch mehr richtung
krise geht könnte die dfg davon
natürlich nochmal profitieren aber man
merkt ganz stark dass die gemäßigteren
wie es immer so heißt das die wirklich
schlechter vorbereitet sind ich finde
das merkt man auch hier die andere seite
hat sehr klar vorbereitet wer wann wie
ans mikro tritt da ist mit klarer
choreografie sozusagen das ist bei den
anderen einfach nicht wo dann könnte das
liegen das nennen wir jetzt mal noch
heute frieden oder was davon übrig
geblieben ist da hier nicht durch
aktivitäten erscheint so ein bisschen
vielleicht auch an die wand gespielt
wird von den sehr aktiven um hüppe um
oder bahn um andere herum hier aus
ostdeutschland eigentlich weiß ja nach
dem bundesparteitag in dresden oder hieß
es ja eigentlich nur wollen das system
quasi etablieren west ost also jedes
jahr den ort des unsere seite als
wechseln der sollte dann glaube ich in
wiesbaden stattfinden dann kam corona
dabei den saal nicht bekommen es ist mal
wieder zum zweiten mal nach dresden
wieder in sachsen dh es gibt ja ein
bisschen standortvorteil also je weiter
man anreisen muss unsere bringen dass
der prozentsatz derer die da sind heute
ist freitags ist für viele natürlich mit
längere anreise noch ein arbeitstag als
infrastrukturelle bedingungen und zum
einen ist natürlich auch schwer im
westen auf ein konzept zu kommen
angesichts westliche landesverbände die
zwar verlieren an zustimmung aber immer
noch deutlich höhere zustimmungswerte
erregen als im westen also der westen
hat innerhalb der partei schwinden der
argumente eigentlich dass man auf ihn
hören soll außerhalb und das ist
eigentlich entscheiden sich größere mail
adresse gast ob man das freilich damit
einer partei ein programm chef in
anführungszeichen lücke wird ausschöpfen
können ist wirklich sehr sehr die frage
und das
und es gibt ein grundproblem meines
erachtens sind die vom ex flügel die
haben ein sehr klares ziel wo sie
hinwollen die wissen ganz genau was sie
anstellen wollen und was sie lieber herr
aufstellen wollen wenn die anderen
eigentlich nur den geist zurück in die
flasche bekommen wollen die wir selber
geöffnet haben und ist natürlich sehr
viel einfacher sehr aktiv zu agieren als
reagieren
die die westlichen landesverbände sind
eher so haben sie erst die einstellung
test partei das genügt uns erstmal
während jetzt im osten dieser diese wut
und dieser protest auch richtig gut
organisiert sind das ist richtig die
frage entscheidet sich willmann system
opposition sein oder werden wir wirklich
regiert also mehrere ist welche
landesverbände zur hohe prozentzahlen
haben bei wahlen aber sehr weit entfernt
von einer gestaltungsoptionen die er
moderator auftreten im westen viel
weniger prozent wären aber theoretisch
näher an der gestaltungs optionär
machtoption dass wir darum wird ihnen
von osten vorgehalten hat man gerade
eben gehört als zuviel system
konformität insofern ist es ein ganz
großes dilemma da wo sie erfolg haben
und eigentlich arithmetisch näher an der
macht sind sind durch eine schärfere
programmatik gerade weiter weg von der
macht und im westen wo sie
programmatisch etwas gemäßigter
auftreten werden sie eigentlich näher an
der macht haben wir viel schlechter
ergebnisse das heißt man hat
gewissermaßen - loose momentan man kann
vielleicht wirklich so machen wie es
europa in seine anfangs redlich gesagt
hat dass man dort geschieht regionalen
kräfte in regionalen verantwortlichkeit
entlässt das hat er so angedeutet er
würde noch zwei reden halten mindestens
das muster glaube ich noch aus formieren
um ost wie west für sich zu gewinnen
wir haben jetzt den rahmen skizziert der
afd dass wir möglicherweise kommen
könnte hier auf dem parteitag und in
nächster zeit und ab morgen werden wir
das mit inhalten und auch mit
personalentscheidungen auffüllen bedanke
mich 12 ann kathrin müller vom studium
mit seiner kissler von der neuen zürcher
zeitung und wir geben jetzt weiter
wieder an doris müller
vielen dank alexander kähler für das
erste zwischenfazit und die erste
analyse am ende eines parteitags der
aber noch nicht zu seinen höhepunkt
gefunden hat beziehungsweise man die
debatte um die tagesordnung außen vor
lässt nämlich um die wahlen des neuen
bundesvorstandes das wird erst noch
kommen weil wir jetzt zur zeit immer
noch in der wahl entschuldigung des
bundes schied sodann schiedsgerichts
sind zwei werden genauso viele
ersatzrichter jetzt gewählte
schiedsrichter heute gewählt sind das
ist ja immer wichtig wenn einer aus
moskau direkt derjenige ersetzt werden
und in diesem wahlprozedere sind wir
zurzeit und zur wahl haben diese zwei
personen gestellt ich da
dieser eine satz ich gerade recht bisher
nicht an zum rednerpult begeben hat sich
bereits zum rednerpult gegeben während
fischer ist das meiner meinung nach
der gerade von der versammlungsleitung
gefragt wird ob er vielleicht sich zum
richter am geschäft nicht angehört
allerdings ein landesschiedsgericht in
der vergangenheit dann jährigen sich auf
fragen zum arbeits zum bearbeitungsstand
und demzufolge
erfüllt haben sie jetzt vier minuten
zeit um sich und ihr programm
vorzustellen
liebe delegierte liebe mitglieder liebe
freunde muss ich ja sagen weil ich sehr
ist er viele freunde
es gibt ein altes englisches sprichwort
das möchte ich zuerst auf deutsch sagen
das heißt ändere nie ein rennen das
system auf englisch never change a
running system
das ist aber nur die halbe wahrheit das
kann ich ihnen sagen ich heiße werden
fischer ich bin seit 45 jahre
unternehmer
25 jahre in asien mit mehreren
fabrikationen vertriebssystem
der punkt ist wir brauchen ein update
die afd braucht ein update und das
update das machen wir heute wir machen
das aber nicht für uns wir machen das
für deutschland weil deutschland braucht
die afd wir schon mal vor
ich möchte zum schiedsgericht kommen ich
habe mir auch ein stück papier hier
vorbereitet das schiedsgericht es wird
leider immer wieder unterschätzt
und es muss aber ein anderes gewicht
haben auch untersuchen auch in den
ländern über die landesgerichte
gerade aufgrund meiner positiven aber
auch negativen erfahrungen im
landesschiedsgericht möchte ich mich
hier heute einbringen das
bundesschiedsgericht muss zwingend
neutral gerecht gerichtsfest und was die
bearbeitungszeit angeht auch transparent
auftreten gerade die afg kann und wird
sich keine juristische fehlern er
zukünftig überhaupt leisten können in
einem starken team von volljuristen
werde ich deshalb besonders ehrgeizig
und unter zugrundelegung der geltenden
gesetze und satzungen aktiv mitarbeiten
und mich das wissen auch sehr viele
vollstens einbringen
dass das bundesschiedsgericht
räumlich gesehen direkt vor meiner
haustüre liegt bei stuttgart das sehe
ich persönlich auch ein vorteil für mich
weil ich kann so gewisse
vorfeldorganisationen mit übernehmen
ehrenamtlich für die verschiedenen
kammern
was sicherheit angeht braucht das
bundesschiedsgericht
zukünftig ein eigenen e-mail-server
und für den datenverkehr und für die
korrespondenz unter den richtern und
unteren prozess oder
verfahrensbevollmächtigte hunde einander
das ist meine erfahrung in der
vergangenheit das ist nicht angehen kann
dass urteile schon in facebook
abgebildet sind die forste der
prozessbeteiligten überhaupt bekommen
hat das muss abgestellt werden wir
brauchen hier eine saubere richtlinie
über eigene datenverkehr und
korrespondenz in den eigenen
e-mail-server
als internationale unternehmen und nach
45 jahren in derselben branche
schlage ich natürlich auch zukünftig
einen barrierefreien zugang von mitglied
und verpasste zuvor aber auch zum
schiedsgericht wir brauchen hier mehr
die nähe
ich sage ihnen wissen und können sind
zweierlei stiefel genauso wie rät nun
machen ich bin ein macher ich bin ein
visionär ich bin ein produzent ich bin
ein praktiker ich bin in
produktentwicklung und ein organisator
und in dieser position nur in dieser
position bringe ich mich hier heute ein
dankeschön
vielen dank herr gaben die rede von
bernd fischer aus dem landesverband
baden württemberg
laut twitter und seinen äußerungen ist
er nicht unbedingt einen neuen freund
erneuten ist halt derjenige der im
januar als bundessprecher die partei
verlassen hatten
sodann losen wir mal die reihenfolge aus
so ist dürfen fragen gestellt werden an
den kandidaten drei fragen die ungefähr
reister säkular nur dennis dauern können
und dann hat der kandidat eine minute
zeit zu antworten jürgen kögel herr
klecker sie sind als erstes dran
ja mein name ist den es länger ich bin
stellvertretender vorsitzender vom fg
kreisverband heilbronn
und ich habe die frage an der fischer
gegen der fischer liefert zahlreiche
ordnungsmaßnahme vom kreisverband
heilbronn über jahre hinweg
wanke ist noch offen und außerdem auch
ein parteiausschlussverfahren
das bav ist auch formell immer noch
offen es wurde zwischenzeitig auch nicht
bearbeitet weil der herr fischer seinen
wohnsitz dann gewechselt hat nach
thüringen ziehen müssen die frage jetzt
ohne deshalb meine frage hat der fischer
ist das parteiordnungsverfahren gegen
sie in eines parteiordnungsverfahrens in
dem moment wo ich den wohnsitz wechseln
im übrigen zur erklärung an alle das
parteiordnungsverfahren hat sich
gehandelt weil ich verschiedene kachin
eingestellt habe auf facebook ich habe
niemand öffentlich beleidigt ich bin
kein im schienbein getreten ja wir haben
hier ein sehr strenger kreisverband in
heilbronn die kontrolleure von alle
mitglieder täglich die facebook einträge
ich bin auch der meinung dass man
zukünftig als auch an alle anderen
kreisvorsitzenden die hier sind wir
sollten zuerst mal miteinander reden
zuerst mal miteinander telefonieren und
nicht gleich auf jemand drauf schlagen
weil jedes mitglied das sich hier
einbringen will ist gold wert und wir
brauchen die mitglieder die aktiven die
auch vom herangehen und die auch
ranklotzen so wie ich danke
vielen dank und die zweite frage stellt
dann herr kögel
mein name ist jürgen kögel ich war
sprecher vom kreisverband heilbronn und
bin mit schatzmeister des kreisverbandes
heilbronn herr fischer unsere
zusammenarbeit war abgrundtief schlecht
wie wollen sie jetzt beim
bundesschiedsgericht positiv für unsere
partei arbeiten wenn sie uns als
kreisverband geschädigt haben
ich habe heute
ich möchte einmal feststellen ich habe
den kreisverband nicht geschädigt der
kreisverband macht wie manche
landesverbände auch gewisse
rechtsgutachten dienst leere laufen
ich bin hier heute in der funktion von
bundesschiedsgericht und ich werde
sicherlich keine entscheidung treffe die
irgendwann mal metall brunn
zusammenhängt da bin ich also dann raus
das werde ich dann also mein rückzieher
machen in so einer sache mit geht es um
die partei mir geht es um deutschland
und da dafür aber ich hier seit neun
jahre seit sieben jahre aktiv und seit
neun jahre als unterstützer und dass ich
mir schwieriger kreisverband bin das
muss man auch mal sagen das wissen die
baden württemberger das kann man jetzt
hier nicht von ableiten dass also in
meiner arbeit hier brand gemeistert wird
dankeschön
vielen dank sie sind dann müssten
entlassen herr fischer und als nächstes
werden wir dann die vorstellung von den
de erschienen
holger stienen der sich ebenfalls zur
wahl des zweiten satzes richters stellt
kommt aus dem
landesverband schleswig holstein
gehörten sie bisher den
bundesschiedsgericht an nein dann
erübrigen sich fragen zur bearbeitung
dort und dem f zufolge können sie sich
jetzt vier minuten an vorstellen mittel
schön danke schön in die auch in die
runde ich bin sehr glücklich hier heute
auch wieder bei ihnen sein zu dürfen mit
abstimmen zu können
ich komme aus schleswig holstein
ich bin
im kreistag fraktionsvorsitzender kreis
herzogtum lauenburg ist noch einer der
kreise die mehr als deutlich mehr als
fünf geholt haben bei der letzten wahl
und
möchte mich kurz vorstellen ich bin
promovierter naturwissenschaftler
gut das ist ein ganz anderes mädchen
und man hat sicherlich einen anderen
blickwinkel
auch ich war ein drei
technologieunternehmen in den
geschäftsführungen lange jahre und
danach auch im consulting im selben
bereich technologie und
habe viele allerdings auch
geschäftsführende also erfahrungen
gemacht
kaufmännischen und vor allen dingen auch
im juristischen fragen also da kommt man
dann in den jahren zu vielen verfahren
für ein oder die man auch selber gegen
die firma geführt werden oder die man
auch selber führt im arbeitsrechtlichen
sinne aber auch sogar im
zivilrechtlichen auch vor allem auch im
strafrechtlichen sinne was davor kommt
und da habe ich zumindest in der
hinsicht die eine oder andere sehr
interessante erfahrung sammeln dürfen
und würde mich freuen jetzt einfach auch
von meiner position warte aus hier etwas
beitragen zu können ich meine dass wir
in den letzten jahren manchmal etwas
unglücklich agiert haben vom
bundesschiedsgericht her das betrifft
natürlich auch insbesondere
ausschlussverfahren die in verschiedene
richtungen meine ansicht eben nicht so
gut gelaufen sind aber und da könnte ich
dann mit beitragen dass eben auch im
sinne derjenigen und natürlich der
partei in anderer front und weise auf
neue füße zu stellen vielen dank
vielen dank herr de erschienen
gibt es fragen an den kandidaten
wolgast in der sie nicht
dann herr de erschienen sind sie
ohne fragen gleichwohl mit dank
entlassen
meine damen und herren wir werden dann
in zwei minuten die türen schließen
unsere abstimmung gelangen
zwei minuten schließen heißt dass der
saal komplett verriegelt wird und die
delegierten keine möglichkeiten mehr
haben raus und wieder rein zu gehen
sondern dass die zahl derjenigen die im
saal mit abstimmen gleich bleibt und
deswegen auch diese wahl zu einem ersatz
schiedsrichter beim bundesschiedsgericht
konform und regelbetreuung ablaufen kann
das ganze wird elektronisch gemacht
logischerweise es gibt eine
kampfabstimmung in auf diesem platz um
die frage des zweiten ersatzschläger
beim bundesschiedsgericht sie haben die
fragen gehört die dann von den saal
mikrofonen gestellt werden es gibt auch
immer gelegenheiten unbequeme fragen
gehört zu bekommen als kandidat oder
aber auch gefälligkeits fragen die dann
sozusagen auch noch mal strategisch den
kandidaten erhöhen oder zumindestens
positiv darstellen lassen das ist ein
gut ausgeklügeltes strategisches ziel
von denjenigen die ihre kandidaten
durchsetzen wollen das ist üblich bei
der afg dieser mikrofone stehen eben
immer entweder rechts oder links an der
seite der gesamten parteitags
an dem gesamten parteitags saal so dass
der gang für mehrere
kandidaten die sich an dieser mikrofone
begeben wollen auch relativ lang ist und
die platten fahrplatz haben um sich hin
zu stellen so der kandidat hatte keine
fragen die ihm gestellt wurden insoweit
sind jetzt diese zwei minuten die
vorher bei der wahl ausbaldowert wurden
mit
berechnet worden und nach zwei minuten
beginnt die abstimmung wird eine
kampfabstimmung um die frage wer das
wird 10 die türen sind geschlossen es
wird niemand mehr rein oder rausgelassen
und dann meine damen und herren kommen
wir jetzt zur wahl des zweiten ersatz
spricht dass sie haben folgende
abstimmungs möglichkeiten 1 bernd
fischer 2 dr holger stimmen 3 nein zu
allen vier enthaltungen der wahlgang ist
eröffnet sie haben 40 sekunden
in den 40 sekunden möchte ich ihnen
nicht vorenthalten dass es einen
weiteren antrag von björn röcke in
diesem wahlverfahren gegeben hat der
versucht hatte die wahlmöglichkeit oder
bzw abstimmungsmöglichkeit auf 30
sekunden zu kürzen also der saal sollte
nur 30 sekunden geschlossen werden damit
man das verfahren einfach etwas verkürzt
und diese wahlen die iren doch sehr zäh
und sehr langatmig sind dann ein
bisschen komprimiert vollzieht das ist
aber leider nicht gelungen der antrag
von birke wurde das haben wir ja gerade
schon vorhin in dem gespräch von
alexander kähler mit den beiden experten
journalisten experten ann kathrin müller
gehört ist abgeschmettert worden jetzt
gibt es eben die zwei minuten und jetzt
gibt's gleich das ergebnis
und herr de erschienen hat die
erforderliche damit eure stimme gewählt
mit fast 60 absender deutlich ihre wahl
an und damit geht es weiter in der wahl
der ersatz schiedsrichter glückwunsch
herr de erschienen wir kommen dann jetzt
zur wahl des dritten ersatz
schiedsrichters davor behandeln wir aber
einen geschäftsordnungsantrag am roten
sein mikrofon
ja lieber versammlung wir haben jetzt
fünf richter zwei ersatzrichter gewählt
denn ihr müsst das bundesschiedsgericht
ordentlich auch für ausfälle aufgestellt
zumal auch eine ganze reihe anderer
wichtiger tagesordnungspunkt die wir
bearbeiten wollen idealerweise noch
heute und deshalb möchte ich doch mal
beantragen dass wir jetzt diesen tage
volles punkt beenden und zu den top 8
und 9 übergehend vielen dank
vielen dank zu diesem antrag eröffne ich
die aussprache wird jetzt für das wort
gewünscht
die auch der zweite versuch her ist
diese debatte auch nochmal abzukürzen es
gab schon mal einen antrag den
geschäftsordnungsantrag
eben diese debatte einfach zu beenden
und auch die wahlen zu beenden für die
ersatz schiedsrichter
das hat der parteitag aber abgelehnt
jetzt gibt es den zweiten versuch
und jetzt wird der parteitag darüber
debattieren ob es ein ende der wahl gibt
für die ersatz schiedsrichter ja oder
nein
ja wir können das ist so wie immer in
der afg wir können sich namen
vorschlagen und dann den hundertsten
ersatz schiedsrichter wellen aber das
ist völlig irrelevant
die arbeit muss gemacht werden wir haben
schiedsrichter gewählt und die sollen
sie jetzt tun wir haben aber noch eine
ganze große menge an
tagesordnungspunkten vor uns und
deswegen kann ich mich nur für den geo
antrag aussprechen dass wir das ding
jetzt beenden und weitermache in der
arbeit
gibt es weitere wortmeldungen zum
verfahrens antrag jetzt an dieser stelle
mit der schiedsrichter war schluss zu
machen bitteschön
so ja also ich bin wäre dagegen wenn wir
brauchen ja dass schiedsrichter wir
wissen alle wenn schiedsrichter aus
zahlen der schiedsgerichts wesen ist
etwas elementar wichtig ist in unserer
partei deswegen bin ich dagegen und wir
sollten mindestens einen ersatz
schiedsrichter wählen und dafür tun wir
uns nicht das ist in fünf minuten oder
sechs minuten erledigt und ich denke das
ist jetzt hin hier nicht die
argumentation dass nach hinten zu
schieben schiedsrichter sind wichtig und
dessen sollten wir uns bewusst sein das
sollten wir nicht nach hinten schieben
rechtsstaatspartei wir brauchen
schiedsrichter wir brauchen auch er dass
schiedsrichter dankeschön vielen dank
gibt es weitere wortmeldungen
ich kann nicht erkennen dass es weitere
wort doch
das ist keine wortmeldung sondern einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag
ich bitte um ein sofortiges ende der
aussprache und beginn der sofortige
abstimmung es wurde ein antrag auf ende
der debatte gestellt gibt es hier zu
einer gegenrede
das kann ich nicht erkennen dann ist der
antrag auf ende der debatte angenommen
und dann stimmen wir jetzt über den
verfahrens antrag ab nämlich die
schiedsrichter war an dieser stelle zu
beenden wer ist für diesen antrag
danke schön wäre es dagegen
dankeschön wer enthält sich dann ist der
antrag mehrheitlich angenommen worden
das ist parteitags dynamik von zehn
minuten hat sich die partei dafür noch
anders entschieden
aber jetzt hat sie eine andere
entscheidung getroffen und jetzt gibt es
noch einen geschäftsordnungsantrag
kommen sie ans rednerpult
gut mein geschäft und lautet rückkehr
zum tagesordnungspunkt 8 wir haben uns
zusammengesetzt haben eine resolution
quasi zusammen geschrieben wir haben uns
geeinigt ein einziger punkt aber ich
weiß nicht ob der herrlichkeit seinen
antrag selbst zurück dieser
änderungsantrag ansonsten könnten wir
über die resolution jetzt abstimmen
das ist der antrag zum
tagesordnungspunkt
8 der resolution zur kernkraft
zurückzukehren wird hierzu das wort
gewünscht zu diesem antrag
das
diese
das ist sozusagen der versuch eines
geschäftsordnungsantrag ist das thema
kernkraft wieder abschließend auf die
tagesordnung nehmen
zur erinnerung da hatten sich ja die
lager oder bzw fachleute zusammen
gesessen dann keine lager sondern
fachleute zusammengesessen um präzise
auszuformulieren wie diese resolution
auszusehen hat davon aus dass das
ergebnis gut ist aber wenn wir jetzt
einfach beschließen ohne dass wir den
antrag überhaupt mal gesehen habe fand
ich das dann doch ein bisschen zu viel
dienst und werde darum bitten dass man
schon kurz erklärt bekommen könnten das
klasse ist ein gaben kurz einblenden
aber die verfahrensfrage ist ja
unabhängig davon ob sie sich noch mit
einem schlechten oder guten
resolutionstext befassen wissen sie ja
sozusagen erst nachdem sie sich mit ihm
dazu entschlossen haben sich mit ihm
überhaupt zu befassen darum geht es ja
jetzt so aber wir haben ihnen jetzt
trotzdem eingeblendet es ist natürlich
beziehungsweise beziehungsweise bitte
ich darum ihn einzublenden weil ich
sehen schon sie sehen ihn aber noch
nicht
der neue text für die resolution die die
partei verabschieden soll für den bau
neuer atomkraftwerke in deutschland mit
den einzelthemen oder intensiv themen
atomendlager und der frage soll man die
kohle damit rein bauen und das thema
kohle energie mit rein bauen oder nicht
aber dieses ist mit den fachleuten
unterschiedlicher strömungen dann in
einen eintrag in ein
einseitig einseitigen einmütigen
resolutionsantrag jetzt gemündet und um
diesen geht es dass wir
erzählen ob dieser anteil jetzt
abgestimmt wird oder nicht das thema
kernenergie und kernkraftwerke in
deutschland
so meine damen und herren das ist zu
ihrer information der antrag der dann
möglicherweise gleich behandelt werden
könnte aber zunächst einmal ist dann
auch die zustimmung oder ablehnung zum
antrag von herrn hilfe erforderlich
nämlich dass wir in den
tagesordnungspunkt 8 zurückkehren wer
ist für diesen antrag
dankeschön wer ist dagegen
danke schön wer enthält sich dann ist
dieser antrag mit großer mehrheit so
beschlossen und dann hätte würde ich
ihnen das wort erteilen um jetzt ihren
ihre neufassung sn 2.4 auch vorzustellen
inhaltlich ja
ihr konntet lesen
dass wir also die vorschläge die meisten
vorschläge also eingearbeitet haben wir
haben uns ja meine damen und herren an
dieser stelle sage ich erst mal jetzt
gibt es da jetzt geht es darum dass
dieses thema kernenergie und kernkraft
und atomkraftwerke in deutschland finale
abgestimmt wird die fachleute haben sich
darauf geeinigt fest steht dass die afg
für den bau neuer atomkraftwerke in
deutschland ist mit allen präzisen
feinheiten die es dazu in der resolution
auch auszuführen gibt man mit diesen
worten gebe ich jetzt
als sun alexander keller
ja der noch dazu führen dass wir ja im
laufe des abends noch weiter hier am
parteitag dran bleiben bei unseren
sendungen der tag jetzt um 17 30 und
später ab 23 uhr sie über die neuesten
entwicklungen
informieren soll ja noch zur wahl
zumindest der beiden bundessprecher
könnte auch eine un-sprecherin sein
kommen darüber werden wir sie auf dem
laufenden halten und morgen früh dann ab
10 uhr genau diese wahl ganz genau unter
die lupe zu nehmen heute war ja ein tag
wo es sehr viel und formalia gegen aber
auch um politisch wichtige inhaltliche
politisch inhaltlich wichtige formalia
die möglicherweise jetzt den weg dafür
bereiten was morgen und übermorgen auf
dem fdp bundesparteitag noch so alles
passiert das war es jetzt erstmal hier
aus riesa in sachsen und ich gebe für
die sendung der tag zurück nach bonn
der bundesnachrichtendienst
sieben jahrzehnte spionagegeschichte
der kampf zweier deutscher staaten
gegeneinander
eine geschichte von versagen und verrat
von skandalen und legenden und von
geheimoperationen mit globalen
auswirkungen
der hemmnisse des bnd drei folgen